Õpetaja: Aa, Recording on jälle vaikimise pealt. Ee, ma lähen kohe muudan ära. Selle sätt.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta võib olla nüüd peale, Aga Ta oli enne peal juba. Ühesõnaga on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, tekitab mõttetult. Ee, seda ruumi siin pikast.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, Okei, ee. Teeme selle jutu ära.
Õpetaja: Tõesti, ei ole kunagi väga meeldinudki. See autorekaard.
Õpetaja: Jah, lõpusele näha.
Õpetaja: Artur, kas rekordimine tundus, et läks muidu okeilt teile, et sa ei ei tundunud, et mingeid probleeme oleks. Ja nädalavahetusel kindlasti vaatan. Ee, vaatan kah
Õpetaja: Ee, mis te tegite?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen siis kohe Ee, Screenshot I Siis hakkame vaikselt. Ee, siin asjadega pihta.
Õpetaja: Natukene tundub kuidagi veel Hõredad, Read Aga kinnisvari kriis? Ee, siis. Ee,
Õpetaja: mis ma mõtlen, ma Panen kõigepealt ee, ühe tegevuse käima.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja ma näitan teile ka, kuidas ma seda teen, Siis võibolla mõtlete teilegi homme ekraani jagatud
Õpetaja: mingi Tähta siin.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, siit. Ma lähen lihtsalt recording. See on transcripts
Õpetaja: Mm, mis tähendab siis salvestused? Põhimõtteliselt koos. Aa,
Õpetaja: noh, ütleme siis ee, Subtiitritega kaine.
Õpetaja: Ma võtan siis ee, aluseks Ee, eilse päeva.
Õpetaja: Mm, ja siin on kokku siis kolm rekordingut. Noh, see viimane on siis teine Teie oma, nagu näha. Nelikümmend seitse minutit. Ee, mis ma siit teen? Ma võtan siit audio transcript ja võtan siit download. Ma tahan seda Lihtsalt alla download, ida, muid asju. Ma ei taha
Õpetaja: lubanud Downloads ka osta.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma jätan selle nii nagu ta on selle faili nime, Ma teen seda teisega ka.
Õpetaja: Jah, no, olime selle ka.
Õpetaja: Ja loomulikult. See kolmas ka.
Õpetaja: Jah, nii paneme selle ka ehk. Siis nende kolme Video transcript on olemas
Õpetaja: päeva enne seda ka midagi üldse tegime midagi. Jõudsime vist teha, või?
Õpetaja: Mis? Me tegime. Teisipäeval Teisipäeval Me ikkagi juba Midagi tegime, eksole?
Õpetaja: Siis ikkagi otsime selle ka ülesse. See on ee eraldi päev.
Õpetaja: See on see
Õpetaja: Jah, siin on ka terve päev ja Siin on terve päev rekordingut. Aa, peaaegu võitlevad tund ja siis. Ee, kuidagi pikalt. Okei, vahet pole, on mis on
Õpetaja: teen samamoodi sellest kah
Õpetaja: Mm, ta juba ütleb, et see justkui on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ahah okei, no, kindluse mõttes ma. Siis. Ma vist ei jõudnud midagi sellega teha. Ma Lihtsalt Tegin lahti ja näitasin, et tiitrid on. On ju
Õpetaja: kindluse mõttes. Ma lihtsalt kustutan selle siit Ee, ära ja lihtsalt replace in
Õpetaja: me Teame siis selle teisega ka. Nii.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, kuna me kavatseme. See protsess, mis on, on, ma palun talle, et tee.
Õpetaja: Ee, tee lihtsalt Kokkuvõte.
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu sellest. Ee, see on transkriptsioonist.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Eesti keeles on üldse see sõna? Mingi. Aga mis see
Õpetaja: ongi? Vä? Issand, kui kole sõna.
Õpetaja: Ehk
Õpetaja: võibolla midagi. Siis peab pikemalt kirjutama. Ma ei tea, kas ma oleks võimeline seda Eesti keeles isegi ära spellima.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et Sellega isegi veel saaks hakkama. Aga juba väga kole sõna.
Õpetaja: Mõte on see, et. Ee. Meil on siin nüüd. Ee,
Õpetaja: vähemalt kolm nädalat ees, Kus Ee, sooviks seda tegevust teha? Pigem, isegi võibolla neli, Võibolla isegi mõned päevad peale.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, ee. Mis mõtted on, Kui ma tahan anda talle mingit ja ta teeks midagi. Ja siis mul mõte on seda uuesti ja uuesti kasutada seda sama frompti, mis ma võiks teha.
Õpetaja: Institutsioon on ümberkirjutus.
Õpetaja: Noh, näed, ümber kirjutas.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame seda ümber. See mõte on see, et me anname selle faili ette, Ütleme, et Teeme ikka kokkuvõte
Õpetaja: tee, kokkuvõte. Ee, ja siis, ee. Tee sinna ülesse nagu mingi Niukene Sammari punktide kaupa, et mis teemad on seal kaetud Ee, seejärel soovime, et ee, siis pikemalt Natuke räägib, et mis teemades seal arutlete tehku Ühtlasi Ka mingeid õppematerjale antud teemadel.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on Mingisugused koodijutud. Siis koodibaasist võib vabalt asju vaadata. Noh, päris mitu tegevust, eksole?
Õpetaja: Aga mu mõte on see, et kui ma tahan täna seda prompte kasutada homme seda prompte kasutada ülehomme seda prompte kasutada. Mis me võiks teha?
Õpetaja: Kõlab nagu skill, onju? Noh, kaua me teeme nagu seda Sama juttu, siis. Ee, siis seda teemegi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma võtan siis ee terminali lahti. Ee, selle ma teen nüüd. Aa,
Õpetaja: ee, Seda ma nüüd ei taha teha Cloudiga. Ma tahaks oma token. Eid küll, nagu säästa.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatan, kas mul Wsl läheb siit läbi terminali käima, Näete, siin On midagi teistmoodi, kui me vaatame Näiteks
Õpetaja: Windowsi Niiöelda Command prompt,
Õpetaja: siis ta näitab C Project Grupp. Nelikümmend Bankfront, on Nii rada. Lihtsalt vaata, Kus ma hetkel olen? See on see kauss Siin
Õpetaja: kogu projekt.
Õpetaja: Kui Mina suhtlen. Ee, nüüd, kui ma Cloud I käivitan siin, siis ta Põhimõtteliselt suhtleb selle kataloogiga ee läbi põhimõtteliselt terminali taustal toimub veel mingit hookust.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame nüüd ubuntu
Õpetaja: siin on mingi hoopis mingi Janss, Neil juhus on kunagi gamer. Name Counter Strike. Dave Ee Defeet. Mõned muud mängud,
Õpetaja: kus ma mängisin. Ja siin on rada mingi mm, nelikümmend bankfond. Kui me vaatame neid kahte tükki kõrvuti,
Õpetaja: siis me näeme, et, ee, siin nägu on midagi sarnast, Kui vaadata seda. Ja seda kas on nii?
Õpetaja: Ainult. Aga ainult kuni siiamaani, onju Ja kirjaviis on natukene erinev. Ka
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, millega on tegemist? Miks, miks see kuidagi teistmoodi. Mis? See, mis see Mmt võiks tähendada?
Õpetaja: Anna vihje, et see sõna on. Mount
Õpetaja: on Niukene kontseptsioon, kus sa nagu otseselt ei saa Nagu mingile asjale ligi Vaid sa. Saad kuidagi nagu tema peale minna, tema peale midagi ehitada ja sealt ligi
Õpetaja: siis, ee, milles on asi on see, et see siin ongi Windows.
Õpetaja: Mitte lihtsalt sellepärast, et see on. Aga nagu, põhimõtteliselt. Ee, see kaust on Windowsi kaust
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on tegelikult, et meil on süsteemis. Kui ma teen Explorer I lahti.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siit selle kinni,
Õpetaja: siis pange tähele. Mul on siin, Ma teen selle lahti. Mul on siin mingid kettad. Ee, peamiselt on mul see C ketas. Mis on siis ee, kus ma nagu igapäevaselt Toimetan nii, nagu ikka ma selle kontseptsiooniga vastu olete tuttavad,
Õpetaja: aga siis on mul veel selle Peale seda. Bcd on siin eraldi Linux
Õpetaja: Ee, Ei, aga tõesti võttes. Tegelikult on mul üks operatsiooni süsteem. Hästi, peab täpsed olema. Kui ma ütleks, et kaks operatsiooni süsteemi on arvutis, siis viitaks. Pigem sellele, et see hetk, kui ma arvuti käima panen, ma saan valida, kumba ma lähen.
Õpetaja: Aga minul on hoopis niimoodi et kogu See asi on ikkagi ju Windows.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Windowsi sees on alamsüsteem
Õpetaja: operatsiooni sees nagu virtuaalne. Niiöelda süsteem ee õpetaja õppematerjalide tegemiseks. On mul mingi Putu kakskümmend, kaks null, neli, mida iganes. Tegelikult ma kasutan seda. Noh, seda ma tegin, et lihtsalt. Kuidas seda installida. Ma tõmban selle maha Mingi hetk
Õpetaja: näete seda. Kakskümmend neli, null, neli. Mida iganes, onju. Kui mina siit tegin endal lahti, siis ma valisingi. Et Kuule, tee terminal lahti. Mitte Windows, vaid palun tee seda siis. Ee, Windowsi alamsüsteem. Linux.
Õpetaja: Kakskümmend Kakskümmend. Neli.
Õpetaja: Võib niimoodi mõelda, kui see aitab sul mõelda, et Ta on nagu veits nagu server. Tõesti. Vaata, ee. See ongi see, mis oli seal. Õpetuste käigus. V. Kaksisvsl Windows. Subsystem. Linux.
Õpetaja: Üks operatsioonisüsteem on teise sees Miks üldse. Niuke asi on? Ee, kes selle tegi? Ee Windows ise. Microfonti mehed ise on selle võimaluse loonud miks sellepärast, on teatud tööriistad ja asjad mis lihtsalt ei tööta. Kuidas nüüd öelda, native ei tööta? Windows? Is
Õpetaja: Põhiliselt, jah. Et on rakendused ja asjad, mis Ei, tööta Tegelikult Windows. Põliselt, sest nad on disainitud töötama Linuxis
Õpetaja: Ja siis küsis nagu. Aga ma saan siis neid asju kasutada. Et Kas ma siis nüüd ee, kolin Windowsit üle Linux Ile? Noh, ma arvan, Microsofti mehed seda ei taha.
Õpetaja: Tahad ikka jätta võimaluse et sa, Saad kasutada ka neid asju? Ee, kõige klassikalisem näide kõige klassikalisem näide dokter
Õpetaja: on siis selline vahva, tarkvaraline lahendus. Ee, mis on siis põhimõtteliselt Niukene konteiner
Õpetaja: Virtualiseeritud konteiner. Kui nii võib öelda, kus sees saad panna Põhimõtteliselt kokku Ee. Mingisuguse.
Õpetaja: Ütleme niimoodi. Mingisugused programmid ja asjad, mis kõik Elavad seal oma eraldatud virtuaalses konteineris ja kõik Vajalik ee, mis seal selle nagu programmi Niiöelda, mis iganes tarkvara või programm seal sees, on Selle käivitamiseks on seal sees endas olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga Dokker ei tööta Windowsis Nativily.
Õpetaja: Nii et juba see
Õpetaja: see juba põhimõtteliselt arendajale nagu Kaindluse sisse. Kirjutatud. Tal on vaja saada ligi dokeri vastu. See on tänapäeva tööriist. Mis probleemi tokker lahendab?
Õpetaja: Doker lahendab seda probleemi. Sinul on üks läpakas Mingisugused Os I, mis? Mis iganes os sul on. Operatsioonisüsteem, seaded, versioon, asjad nii edasi. Aa siis Rakendused tihtipeale vajavad ligipääsu mingi andmebaasidele. Kas Sa hakkad oma arvutisse seda installima. Ükstaspuha, mis? Soft? Vaata, käib tarkvaraga kaasas. Mingisugused asjad, millest ta sõltub ja mida ta kasutab?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis See mõte on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, kui ee. Klassikaliselt. Vanasti oli niimoodi, et sa läksid kuskile tööle, siis sulle anti. Siiamaani on see Nii, ee, antakse sulle mingi tutikas läpakas. Selles mõttes, Noh, mitte tutikus poest toodud. Vaata, selles mõttes et on midagi seal peal, pole Üldjuhul on niimoodi, et arendusmeeskond arendaja ise laseb peale kogu vajaliku krempli,
Õpetaja: mida tal vaja on, et ta saaks teha tööd.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mõnes kohas on ka niimoodi, Et kus antakse? Kus on mingi image I pealt. Mingid asjad juba peal on ju? Natuke. Mida teil siin? Kes Bc I Läpaka Said? Vaata, et et on juba kohe midagi peal. Üks variant võib ka olla, aga klassikaliselt pigem mitte.
Õpetaja: Aga mis see mure nüüd Ongi see siis, et kui mina tahan lihtsalt jooksetada mingit rakendust kohalikult oma masinas?
Õpetaja: Ma arendan mingit ee programmi
Õpetaja: sul, et selle asja tööle saada. Sul võib minna põhimõtteliselt mingi nädal vabalt Ära vabalt lihtsalt saada mingi asju nagu tööle ja käima
Õpetaja: Installi. Seda installi toda seal mingid Seadistused, asjad, värgid. Bla blaab. Siis on ikkagi tulevad mingisugused erisused välja ja nii edasi. Ja siis on see, et sa. Sul on nagu seal kõvasti aega, et lihtsalt asi käima panna oma masinas nagu lihtsalt jooksma
Õpetaja: Dokkeriga on niimoodi, et tema on eraldi väikene konteiner.
Õpetaja: Seal on kõik ära määratud, mida tal on vaja, mida ei ole. See kogu see Staff et ta saaks nagu lihtsalt joosta, on juba selles niukses pildis olemas, et projektis tehakse pilt. See on meie rakendus, Frontend. Sellest nagu teed pildi.
Õpetaja: Ja sa võid anda kellele põhimõtteliselt, kui sa teed Sellest, nagu sa võid. Põhimõtteliselt kellele iganes. Ee, kui see inimene saab selle doker konteineri, siis tema saab oma arvutis selle lihtsalt käima tõmmata, Sest kõik on selles virtuaalses konteineris juba olemas seadistatud. Mida iganes, nagu et see töötab ka enda niimoodi
Õpetaja: kõik töötab. Kõik tarkvara on olemas. Kõik kom, kõik töötab. Põhimõtteliselt.
Õpetaja: Doker on selles mõttes niuke tööriist, mida igapäevaselt kasutatakse.
Õpetaja: Doktor, üks on Aa. Miks ma teda nagu õpetades, nagu Muidu ma võiks teda kasutada. Aga ma. Sellepärast ma ei kasuta
Õpetaja: tee. Pugida ei saa.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on tee pugimine, kes teab, Jaa, vigade Fiximine. Ee, väike ajalooline taust ka. Vaata, et mis asi see on. Kui Me ütleme, et ära tee on nagu, et tee mingi asja Ära demine. Vaata, nagu pannud pommi Vaata, demine nagu tee pomm Kahjutuks. On ju
Õpetaja: pahaks, et kui koodi ei tekivad pugid,
Õpetaja: kas te teate Miks üldse nagu on niuke? Miks selline termin, nagu.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõlemad tahavad rääkida. No palun,
Õpetaja: jah, see on täpselt õige. Story Ee, tegemist on Puuse looga. Üks esimese ühesõnaga. Vanasti olid mingid toasuurused. Aparaadid olid arvutid, mitte nutikella sugused asjad, mis võiks käe peal olla ja mingi miljon. Korda. Nõrgemad, on ju?
Õpetaja: No, mingi miljonist mitte. Aga ikka väga, väga, Palju kordi nõrgemad, et suured arvutid olid ee tuba, Tuba oli täis arvutit põhimõtteliselt. Ja mäletate, Vanasti olid need lambid ja pirnid ja mingi niuke värk käis, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja siis mure oli, selline et ee mingi Programm jooksis ja lihtsalt kuidagi andis valet tulemust. Ja noh, ma siis. Olid Need mingid perfokardid ja asjad, ja nagu vaatasid kõik asjad üle, Et nagu peaks toimima. Aga ei toimi. Lihtsalt Ei toimi nagu tuleb lihtsalt vale tulemus.
Õpetaja: Oligi. Mingisugune sitikas. Oli lihtsalt saanud sinna aparatuuri. Sisse Oli kärbed seal mingi kahe ühenduse vahel. Ära vaata Ja siis andnud niiöelda Connection It selles mõttes vales kohas
Õpetaja: ja, noh, ühel hetkel nad Saidki aru, et midagi peab olema. Noh, ikka. Ühel hetkel hakka. Riistvara võiks kuidagi vaatama. Eriti Noh, nendel aegadel, kus kõik oligi Niukene
Õpetaja: veits Mina Ei tea kuidagi haamriga kokku löödud. Ma arvan,
Õpetaja: ee, et nad leidsid lõpuks siis selle putuka ära. Ja kui nad võtsid putuka ära, Siis on ei mõelda,
Õpetaja: et. Aga mida see meile praktiliselt tähendab? Seda on, et me saame oma koodi panna niukseid asju nagu Break point.
Õpetaja: Noh, koodis lihtsalt visuaalselt. Nad näevad seal, kus nad numbrid on. Koodi rea numbrid, klikid. Kuskile reale. Sinna tekib üks mummu
Õpetaja: ja see mummu ütleb põhimõtteliselt, siis sellele tööriistale, et kui kood kunagi peaks mingi. Noh, kui kood käivitub, tuleb sisse mingi sõnum. Mingi kood käivitub mida iganes, Kui kood läheb juhuslikult üle selle rea või tahab õigemini üle selle rea minna, siis jää seisma.
Õpetaja: Jää seisma
Õpetaja: protsesse, sa noh, käivitad kas nuppu või tuleb mingi sõnum. Vahet pole, kuidas see kood käivitub. Kas tegemist on serveriga. Lihtsalt arvutisprogrammile. Käivitad Nuppu, Vahet pole, kui ühel või Teisel viisil Kood. Tahab jooksutada just seda rida, nagu sina oled mummu pannud. Siis Ta jääb seisma. See on
Õpetaja: Ja mis see nüüd, töö, Mis on need, mis see nagu tähtis on see, et ee. Siis kui see kood seal niimoodi seisab,
Õpetaja: siis selle integreeritud arendus ee keskkonna Tööriistaga nimega Ultimate, millel on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, Siis sa saad jääda sellel joonel seisma ja sa saad vaadata,
Õpetaja: mis on näiteks mingi muutujate sisu,
Õpetaja: Mis seal praegu toimub? Nagu just sellel hetkel.
Õpetaja: Seal on mingi. Kui seal peaks tegelikult taga olema Rain, siis sa näed seda
Õpetaja: või Seal on mingi numbriline väärtus.
Õpetaja: Seal on mingi tõe väärtus. Siis sa näed seda. Kõige parem on niimoodi, et nüüd sa saad niimoodi samm sammult hakata, et mine nüüd üks samm edasi
Õpetaja: ja vaata. Koodil on ju koodi. Me kirjutame niimoodi, et me ju käivitame koodi erinevates kohtades, et Mul võib olla üks koodirida. Mis nüüd tähendab, et kui see käivitatakse, siis hoopis kuskil teises failis käivitub mingi meetod mingi nimeline koodileih
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd läheb sealt edasi. Aga kui sa nüüd samm sammult niimoodi lähed, siis sa näed. Vaata, Ma olen. Siin on mingi If lause, muidu Ise võib peas mõelda, et see rehkendub truuks, onju? Sa peaks rehkenduma Truuks. Aga viga ongi.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd sa lähed sellest Wifi lausest üle Vaatad? Oi, ta ei läinudki siia truu sisse, vaid ta läks juba Else juurde ja Elsast juba hakkab kuhugi mujale minema. Näiteks
Õpetaja: siis on nagu. Aa, Oot, oot, oot, siin see ei. Minu teadmiste kohaselt See ei peaks nii käituma. Praegu. Ilmselt siin on mingi loogika viga
Õpetaja: tiba Ja Siis ta kuskil näiteks hüppab ühte kohta teise kohta. Sa saad lihtsalt niimoodi. Samm sammult. Saad niimoodi jälgida,
Õpetaja: mida see kood teeb? See on arendaja parim Parim tööriist ausõna. Ee, vot see on ainuke asi, mis mul tokkeri juures ei meeldi. Et Ee, sa saad kõik need Selles konteineris. Kenasti põmm, põmm, põmm, Käsuread käima tõmmata ja vaadata oma rakendust ja testida. Vaata seda sa saad teha
Õpetaja: aga sa ei saa teha seda teepugimist. No, ma olen lugenud, et kuidagi mingi imeasjaga kuidagi peaks saama. Aga mina ei tea, Keegi ei ole seda lahti suutnud muukida. Mina ei tea, et Ee, see on nagu ainukene downside.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et siis ta ei jookse enam läbi. Kui sa käivitad selle rakenduse läbi, siis Tema nagu teab täpselt nagu mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Kui sa käivitad selle läbi Dokeri, siis Intelligence ei tea sellest midagi.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ongi Mingid võimalused on. Kuidas saab ta kuidagi seda peegeldada? Asja Aga ma ütlen ka. See ei vääri küünlaid. Ee, kui on tegemist ikkagi nagu Enamvähem niukse lihtsama rakendusega ega nagu päeva lõpuks. Aga kõik asjad peavadki olema võimelised käima ka panema lokaalselt.
Õpetaja: See lihtsalt võtab aega ja mida iganes, et on mingid sätted, võibolla mingid muuted mingid asjad, Eks Sa siis pead selgeks tegema Tavalises dokumentatsioonis on niikuinii need kõik kirjas, kui Vähemalt minimaalselt on selles dokter. Failis on kirjas Kindlasti, Kui seal on mingid mingisugused sätted ja asjad, mida sa pead teadma käivitamise hetkel
Õpetaja: sõltuvused On kõik ju kenasti seal. Dependentsite all olemas, nii et, Noh, põhimõtteliselt pole võimalust, et sa ei saaks seda käima, aga, noh, see võib olla keeruline.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma töötasin. Näiteks Lhv S
Õpetaja: Ee. Töötasin Lhv S. Töötasin No Seal on Veel Workeround. Ka. Loomulikult. Aa, kui sa töötad. Sa saad teha logi. Ridasid
Õpetaja: Nagu, seda, et konsooli viskab. Lihtsalt nagu sa saad panna, et ei, siin on mingi muutuja. Võta selle sisu ja pane see lihtsalt logisse. Konsoolist Logi jookseb või lausa tekstifail võib olla. Kui tahad, saad panna, et ta kuskile, teeb tekstifaili ja muudkui lisab. Vaata, kui ta paneb reast üle. See on ka enda nagu tee pugimine.
Õpetaja: Aga mitte nagu sellel mõnusal viisil, kus sa niimoodi Samm sammult. Saad nuppe vajutada ja näha.
Õpetaja: Sa lihtsalt saad panna mingi sõna, et näed. Ta on umbes siin If Lause juures ja siin On mingi muutuja, et paned, et kas tal läheb see If lause sisse? See on nagu, kui ma pangas töötasin meil interneti pank
Õpetaja: ee, Seal ei olnud võimalik is. Ma sain koodi arendada, Ma sain seda kõike näha ja ta isegi mõistis seda süntaksit ja oskas mulle öelda Kui ma tegin nagu süntaksi või mida iganes, Aga mida ma ei saanud kunagi teha seal, Ma ei saanud mitte kunagi käivitada seda oma
Õpetaja: oma lokaalses intellendises, et Break Point E panna, et ta seisma. Ma võin öelda kohe, et jah, töö saad tehtud ja saad seal ka Niiöelda aru, kust midagi valesti läheb ja nii edasi. Aga mitte nii mõnusat. Näiteks kui käivitad mingi jaava projekti endal masinas ja paned Break Point I Ja ongi kõik,
Õpetaja: et. Ee,
Õpetaja: jah. Kusjuures. Aa, okei, Mul Põhimõtteliselt, et se seda ee, Linuxit on siiski kahjuks vaja, sest et on tööriistad, mis seda vajavad. Samamoodi. See Cloud algselt töötas täitsa ainult selle Linuxiga. Nüüd ma olen aru saanud. Ta töötab ka natuke teistmoodi,
Õpetaja: Aga mitte päris perfect. Excel on ka mingid omad probleemid.
Õpetaja: Nii aga see siin on ee,
Õpetaja: Näha siis, et ta, et tegelikult mis ta Nüüd teeb.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta teeb niimoodi, et ta läheb kanda läbi selle niiöelda serveri.
Õpetaja: Siin on Niukene kataloog. Nagu home. Siin on Yanks neli, U Näete, nüüd juba hakkab tulema. Yanks. Neli You see on minu kasutaja, mis ma lihtsalt valisin.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi, et tema nüüd teeb niimoodi sellise triki, et ega siin ei ole ju neid faile.
Õpetaja: Need failid on ju mul siin C Kataloogi all. Noh, ma otsin ülesse selle, Mis te niimoodi lahti lubate. Siin ei luba. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Grupp.
Õpetaja: Nelikümmend. Oo, palju faile on ka. Nii Vaatame
Õpetaja: ei näita County Kuusteist Kuueteistkümnes grupp olete? Vaata, kui lihtne oli aru saada mitmesgrupp. Nii, ee, ühesõnaga. Kui tulla siia, sisse. Siis Siin on see projekt, aga See asi
Õpetaja: siin ei ole ju sinu puntu all.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kas ta mountain näitab ära. Te ei näita Aga kus see oli, Home,
Õpetaja: et See Ei ole see sama. Vaata, need on erinevad. See ei ole ju See sama. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see mounta on lihtsalt see, Et tema nagu oskab, siis nagu ei mine kuskile mujale Ja siis nagu mingi trikiga. Ta saab ikkagi projektile ligi, lihtsalt, et oleksid teadlikud, Kui Te näete niukest kirjaviisi, et siin on Niukene hookuspookus. Ee, mina avan kodeks.
Õpetaja: Kodex on siis ee Chat Ipt. Niiöelda see Ee terminali tööriist.
Õpetaja: Command Line Interface Käsu Rea tööriist võiks öelda I guess, aga interface ligipääs?
Õpetaja: Nii, ma vaatan korra.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen ta lihtsalt. Hello, Ma Ei tea isegi, kes ta töötab või ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Bad Request. Ee, okei, ee, teeme niimoodi. Ma praegult ei hakka tegema seda transcript asja.
Õpetaja: Teeme seda, teeme seda hiljem. Ma tegelen selle murega nagu pärast poole. Aga ma kavatsen kodeksiga lihtsalt teha, et Token It kokku hoida Cloudiga, ma Ei, julge nagu kulutada
Õpetaja: ega ei taha ka.
Õpetaja: No tead, siin on kõik nii suhteline ka. Vaata aga, aga, lihtsalt kui mina, nagu oma projektis. Ütlesin Ee. Kodeksile, et palun tee mulle implementatsiooni plaan mingisugust taaskist teel. Lihtsalt üks Md fail. Vaata, et noh, mi kuidas sa selle lahendada kavatsed? Mis sa teha kavatsed
Õpetaja: ja. Ja siis ma tegin niimoodi, et ma ütlesin alati niimoodi, et ma lasin kodeksil kõigepealt ja Siis ma ütlesin Cloud Ile täpselt selle sama ülesande et ole hea tee implementatsiooni plaan
Õpetaja: ja siis ta tegi selle ära ja siis ma Põhimõtteliselt ütlen, aga nüüd ta ei tea. Vaata, sealt Ta ei teadnud midagi, et keegi on juba teinud mingi plaani. Vaata, onju, Mul on see niimoodi üles sätitud.
Õpetaja: Ja siis lõpuks ma ütlesin, et. Kuule, Aga tee Review ka. Vaata, nagu et võrdle kahte plaani omavahel, palun leia nagu. Mulle. Nagu, et kumb plaanidest on parem. Vaata, et kas. Nagu plaan. Üks või plaan, Kaks
Õpetaja: ja kogu aeg lihtsalt, ee, Cloud leidis Nagu Cloud I Plaan oli kogu aeg parem. Vahel oli abi ka sellest, et seal olid mingid väikseid asju. Vaata, mida ka Claud ei mõelnud, ee või teinud niiöelda. Aga pea enamus ajast oli, niimoodi, et et Cloud lihtsalt teeb nii nagu vaja
Õpetaja: ja, no okei, võibolla enne Kui läheme õppeasjadele, siis räägime natuke ka eilsetest asjadest. See on nagu võibolla läheb teemasse, onju, et, ee, see asi on nii kiirelt muutumas
Õpetaja: Täna Cloud Homme kodeks
Õpetaja: antigraviti. Mis siin kõik veel on? Kursorid ja igast toredad asjad. Paljud neist tegelikult taustal kasutavad neid samu keelemudeleid nagu Põhjad on neil samad kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja iga pea iga nädal tuleb midagi uut välja. Juba nagu, et nagu
Õpetaja: kõik muutub nii kiiresti, Selles mõttes seda ei saa. Öelda Ja ma ütlen ka, et neid artikleid tuleb nagu pea iga päev, et Nagu jälle, näed seda I Try, Nagu need kolm mudelit kuu aega
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Tuleb. Hakkad lugema seda artiklit ja siis ta lihtsalt põhimõtteliselt jahub seda. Vaata, sellel on nagu Mingi omad plussid. Sellel on mingid omad plussid. Seal on omad plussid. Ja siis viimasena ütleb. No minu arvates see on kõige parem. Vaata, on ju? Aga ütleme, et üldine Foon on ikkagi see, et praegu Cloud on nagu üks parimaid,
Õpetaja: et kui ta kõige parem ei ole, Siis ta on kindlasti üks parimaid. Ee, sellest võib olla veenduda.
Õpetaja: Ee, nad on rohkem natukene spetsialiseerunud sellele progemisele. Minu meelest räägiti sellest. Ka
Õpetaja: Teeme niimoodi see kunagi. Mulle meeldib üks lugu, et räägi, kuidas teie päev läks. Ja siis räägi mina. Kuidas Minu päev läks.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see läks
Õpetaja: produktiivsed
Õpetaja: Arvutusta.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, Vot see ongi just, mida me tegelikult vajame. Ja mida me otsime,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, kas te saite asju selgemaks?
Õpetaja: Noh, selgemaks. Vaata, see. Noh, kui mõne jaoks on see midagi uut? Täiesti, onju? Mõne jaoks, võibolla. Noh, jõudis midagi varem on vaadanud onju Kasvõi eelkursusega.
Õpetaja: Aa, Liis. Arvatavasti meelis
Õpetaja: lõhna. Pikk vend Sven
Õpetaja: Okei, keegi rohkem mind pole otsimas käinud, nagu Vaata, aga ta ütles, et ma Läksin kuskile.
Õpetaja: Ta ütles, et ise õpetajate iseenesest.
Õpetaja: Ee, meid õpetab. Aa, Okei, me siis Rainiga lõpetame selle lepingu ära ja pole vaja,
Õpetaja: Okei, Ma vaatan, mõtlen nädalavahetusel. Ma kindlasti Vaatan ära, nagu mis te tegite.
Õpetaja: No oota korraga. Nii lihtsalt ei pääse.
Õpetaja: Võtame korra lahti, siis ee. Selle asja, mis? Ee, Mission oli nagu, ee,
Õpetaja: tegelikult. Kuule, aa, see asi ka, et kas te tegite siis täitsa ilusti presentatsioonid.
Õpetaja: Pange siis Üks haava selles järjekorras. Ee, number üks, Number kaks, number kolm. Pange ka
Õpetaja: ükshaaval. Mingid failid. Mida iganes, nii palun.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga teeme siis selles järjekorras, et laud. Üks laud, kaks, Siis Ta on nagu kohe haiges järjekorras, Sest need teemad nagu veits haakuvad, on ju
Õpetaja: ee kuigi leiab need kätte ka. No mina teen selle lahti siit. Vaata, et see esimene oli siis rühm Üks ja värja pluss.
Õpetaja: No nüüd ongi niimoodi, et ma küsin veits küsimusi. Vaata ja siis. Aga ärge siis see tiim, kes presentatsiooni tegi. Ärge siis teie hõigake endale selgeks,
Õpetaja: mis Asjad on muutujad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaikus nagu oma sõnadega Üli. Lihtsalt, kuidas?
Õpetaja: See ei ole Nagu päris see, mida ma ütlesin. Kuidas andmetüüp on Üks osa muutujast Javascript on tüübitundetu. Polegi tüüpi
Õpetaja: objekti.
Õpetaja: Muutuja ei pea olema objekti sees tingimata.
Õpetaja: Kuigi üldjuhul ta on muidu ma ütlen, aga Ta võib olla ta. Noh, siin on tein. Siin on. Vaata, kas ta on, ee, instantsi muutaja või ta on kohalik muutaja, et siin ikkagi on. See ei ole nagu päris see, mis ma ütlesin.
Õpetaja: Väärtus on muutuja sees.
Õpetaja: Vot see on nüüd praegu parim.
Õpetaja: Mingisugune asi, millele saab väärtuseid anda.
Õpetaja: Aga ma nüüd toon ühe kontseptsiooni. Ma oma õppematerjalides kasutasin ümbrikut, aga mulle meeldib hoopis. Ee, see näide rohkem ma vaatan. Kas mul on siin ühe suuremat näidet?
Õpetaja: Muutuja On See tegelikult Muutuja On see, mis asi on
Õpetaja: lühi märk, peaaegu natukene lihtsamalt veel, Mis Asi see on,
Õpetaja: mis ta nüüd on, Mis te mäletan.
Õpetaja: Vot silt.
Õpetaja: Põmm Muutuja siit muutujale on silt ja seda silti saab külge panna objektidele.
Õpetaja: Nii selles mõttes kui mina. Panen siia praegu silt.
Õpetaja: Noh, eestpoolt. Nüüd lugeja peab, saab. Ütleb kaugelt. Võib olla ei näe lugeda, mis Siin on kirjas
Õpetaja: Nii siis sisuliselt. See siin praegu on tüüp.
Õpetaja: Kui me räägime jaamast.
Õpetaja: Nii person, et seda silti ei teegi üldse, vaata, Kellele millele või kellele sa vastu külge panna?
Õpetaja: Personile sellest alustame. Tüüp nii persse on.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd mina teen, kas musta ei ole kama seal on,
Õpetaja: kui mina teen nüüd. Tead mis see joonistus siin peal panen?
Õpetaja: Ei ma ei taha. Ma ei. Tahtnud seda, sellepärast, et selle Sildiga on ikkagi parem toimetada.
Õpetaja: Nii kui mina panen siia ülesse, kirjutan
Õpetaja: String.
Õpetaja: Siis Mis siin see tüüp on?
Õpetaja: Jah, tekst sõne, sõne on, siis. Noh, see ongi täpselt see, et. Vaata, Me ei tahaks edaspidi rääkida Eesti keeles programmeerimis terminil. Iga kord öelda, sõne on õige,
Õpetaja: aga Noh, ütleme tekst. Muidugi. Võibolla tekst ütleme. Me mõtleme lihtsalt tekst. Hästi, Lihtsalt vaata. Edaspidi ütleme Loomulikult, strengi
Õpetaja: tekst.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see on tüüp, alles
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on vaja nagu see, et et me saaksime pöörduda üldse nende siltide poole on neil vaja, mida
Õpetaja: peab ise tegema.
Õpetaja: Pealkiri ei Ole päris see, aga lähemal lähedal oled. Sellele
Õpetaja: mitte pealkirja ei ole. Vaja. Ma teen lihtsalt väga, lihtsalt. Kui sa soovid minu poole pöörduda, Nii,
Õpetaja: tead, kuidas ma saan? Te olete objektiiv. Kõik te olete personil. Igal ühel võiks panna personal person külge
Õpetaja: mul. Kui ma ütleks. Ee, Palun tule aita nüüd.
Õpetaja: Kas te kõik tormata või mitte, keegi ei tule?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma ei tea, nagu. Eks siis paistaks nime on vaja,
Õpetaja: Teil on nimed ju? Ee. Arturile andis ema
Õpetaja: ilusa nime. Artur. Ilus ja naine andis talle veel ilusama perekonnanime.
Õpetaja: Aa Ilus on vä, Kui on kirjaviga Ilus ja ilus. Sa ei teadnud mitte midagi. Ei ole, Ei näinud
Õpetaja: mul savi. Ilus nimi, ilus. Ma mõtlesin ka Väga ilus nimi. Ma olen varem kunagi perekonnanimegi olnud. Jah, no täpselt. No, peaaegu. Ongi ilus,
Õpetaja: et ee, ikka nime on vaja.
Õpetaja: Meil on objekt orienteeritud Programmeerimine. Mida kiiremini te hakkate seostama? Seda vaatajaid. Ee, meil on. Ee. Meil On andmed kui objektid.
Õpetaja: Aga kui te oskate paralleeli kogu aeg Mõelda siis. See on objekt.
Õpetaja: See on objekt. See on objekt, See on objekt. See on objekt. See on objekt. Te olete kõik objektid Laud on objekt ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Kui te sooviksite suhelda, Ee, rääkida kellegagi arutada mingisugusest asjast,
Õpetaja: siis ee, kui neid asju on mitmeid või Mis iganes, siis on vaja nimetusi. Noh, üldine nimetus Sellel on laud, on ju
Õpetaja: mida Iganes.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Kui mina, panen siia selle Stringile juurde,
Õpetaja: No ma ei mahu ära. Siia panen First
Õpetaja: ja kahe rea. Mida niimoodi kirjutada ei saa.
Õpetaja: Väga halb marker.
Õpetaja: Siis see tähendab seda kahte asja. Vaata, et esiteks, et siin peaks olema tekst.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd idee järgi saab selle siduda mingisuguse nimega, onju?
Õpetaja: No Vaatan korra, kas ma Panin ühe asja ära, aga ma ei leia praegu ühtegi ümbrikut.
Õpetaja: Tuleme selle muutuja juurde veel tagasi. Ka praegu Lihtsalt tulebki mõelda, et ee, Mõtleme sellest muutujast kui sildikesest.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et me ei saa mõelda neid ka kuidagi andmeid. Vaata, et kui ma panen seesama ee,
Õpetaja: ma panen selle person ile külge.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis ma panen?
Õpetaja: Ma panen muutuja nimeks.
Õpetaja: Cool Cool.
Õpetaja: See on ee person. See on cool,
Õpetaja: et te saate Te peate saama aru Vaata, isegi. Kui esialgselt on see näiteks üles.
Õpetaja: Siis see muutuja ei ole seotud. Forever and Ever konkreetselt selle objektiga, Aga See muutuja võib
Õpetaja: selles mõttes programmis meil alles olla. Tema sisu võib muutuda. Näed,
Õpetaja: et see võib selles mõttes muutuja ei ole kuidagi Fixed objektiga.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes Forever muutuja on selles mõttes. Ee, meie ainukene viis, kuidas me saame programmis suhelda sisuliselt tavaliselt andmetest.
Õpetaja: Need on andmed Ja need muutuja nimed representeerivad nii hästi kui vähegi võimalikult. Ee siis seda sisu, et mis seal sees on,
Õpetaja: et kui meil on mingi õpilase andmed, Siis selle klassi nimi võiks olla student.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me teeme ühe muutuja, nagu siin on Person,
Õpetaja: siis kujutame ette, et see on hoopis student. Ma panengi student. Olete ka student Id? Paneme muutva siis rohelisega. Või selle tüübi student.
Õpetaja: Nii tudeng siis ee, kui mina Teen objektist student
Õpetaja: edaspidi ja mul on programmis. Ongi nagu seal. Selles konkreetses programmis. Kui Kaua Kas te skoobist ka rääkisite, kui kaua elab Üks ee muutuja
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et sellest ei ole rääkinud.
Õpetaja: Jaa, no sest et see oligi üldiselt teema. Püstitas, et seda ei olnud seal Sees
Õpetaja: muutuja eluiga on alates sellest loogilisest sulust,
Õpetaja: Kus sees ta on? Ja ta sureb selle paarilise juures ära.
Õpetaja: No kui me teeme päris natuke jaavat, Siis saab seda rohkem rääkida. Nii, poodibloki sees elab
Õpetaja: ainult koodiploki sees elab kui sul on koodiblokk,
Õpetaja: mille sees on koodiplokk ja Seal Sees on muutuja, siis selle konkreetse
Õpetaja: koodiploki sees ta elab. Sa ei saa kuskil mujal viidata väljaspoolt. Noh, ma teen hästi niimoodi lihtlabaselt selle Näite siin kohe ära.
Õpetaja: Ma teen lihtsalt koodiploki siia. Html I. Vahet pole. Teen, et sinna koodiblokk
Õpetaja: on koodiplaat, Noh, kui ei usu, Siis on nad oma paarilised.
Õpetaja: On, kui mul on nüüd siin sees veel üks koodiblokk.
Õpetaja: Mul on siin sees muutuja nimega First Name
Õpetaja: noh, Kui ma teeks päris hea, vaat siis ütleks String First Name.
Õpetaja: Siis ma ei saa esiteks seda siinpool öelda. Vaata, hei,
Õpetaja: et tee midagi Temaga näiteks või ma. Okei, ma panen mingi print. Panen näiteks konsooli prindid Väärtus, Jah,
Õpetaja: miks ma ei saa seda teha ja siin on Isegi see, et kool liigub ülevalt alla, on ju, et ma viitan siin, et. Hei, Prindi konsoli. Sind pole isegi olemas.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen, nagu, et kood jõuab alles siia, siis nüüd see. Nüüd on see asi ka hästi tähtis. Kuidas kuidas tekib üks uus muutuja kirjaviisiliselt ma mõtlen, Kuidas tekib,
Õpetaja: kuidas tekib muutuja süsteemi jaavas eelnevalt sisse kirjutatud.
Õpetaja: See ei ole päris see kirjaviisist. Vaata, kuidas ta tekib on, see, et kui Sa ütled tüüp
Õpetaja: ja siis mingi nimi.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi tekib üks uus silts. Süsteemi ongi. Näiteks kui panen String Rigo, siis on tekib.
Õpetaja: Kui sa Paned String Riho,
Õpetaja: siis. Sul on muutuja nimega Riho. Mida sa muidugi programmis teed? Mille sisse on kirjutatud Niukene Inimene muutuja nimega Riho on Jälle küsitav. Pigem on hoopis see, Vaata, et see oleks alati ikkagi
Õpetaja: representeerib, et mis tüüpi info siin sees käib, mitte tüüpi, vaid mis Ta taoline
Õpetaja: first name. Noh, pigem oleks siin see asi. Vaata, nüüd on meil süsteemis muutuja.
Õpetaja: First Name.
Õpetaja: Hakkame siis sellest struktuurist pihta. Muutuja, Defineerimine, tüüp, tüüp, nimi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui tuleb võrdusmärk ja midagi muud.
Õpetaja: Väärtus kolm osa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Ee. Mida mina soovin, et te mõistaksite, et kuidas Süsteemi tekib üks uus muutuja. On see süntaks,
Õpetaja: kus on mingisugune objekt objektitüüp.
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuleb mingi tekst.
Õpetaja: Tänu sellisele süntaksile tekib siin programmis Siin, selles vahemikus Üks uus muutuja nimega First Name. Hetkel on ka väärtus Riho.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui mina sooviksin seda kasutada, näiteks printida niiöelda konsooli ma Hästi, lühidalt kirjutasin. See Ee, jaavas on pikemalt, onju?
Õpetaja: Sissekäiks. Umbes niimoodi. Kutsu välja meetod print
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma viitan. See on nüüd Täpselt See, nagu ma ütlen. Nagu siin on see vahe. Vaata, Artur, tule, Ole hea. Tule aita mind. Ma ütlen praegult. No teeme siin Näiteks paneme Riho. Riho, ma Näen. Ma viitan Riho tule aita mind Näiteks siis see tegevus olla. Näe, seal meetod mida me käivitame, on Help me.
Õpetaja: Noh, tegevus on. Kes?
Õpetaja: Vaata programmis me. Kui me päris programmi kirjutame, siis meil ei ole mitte kunagi nagu neid väärtusi põhimõtteliselt niimoodi koodi sisse kirjutatud? Vahel arvan, ka, kui on vaja. Aga põhimõtteliselt aastad lihtsalt tulevad sõnumiga kuskilt internetist.
Õpetaja: Me näemegi, et käivitatakse mingit tegevus Tegevusel antakse kaasa First Name. Aga see tuleb juba internetist sõnumiga. Programmis loedki. Ee, et, ee, Ahah. Siin on mingi tegevus et raini aidatakse Kes, First Name Rain? Noh,
Õpetaja: keegi, kes mingi isik. Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Nii ma selle tagasi Nüüd, mis vahe on sellel kasutamisel
Õpetaja: ja loomisel, ma Tahan, et te sellest saate aru, Kui te vaatate seda teksti ja seda teksti, mis on nende vahe?
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: ja vaata, siin ongi see mõte. Vaata, et me ei tee seda niimoodi, Et kui mina, nagu käivitan tegevuse ee, aita niiöelda raini,
Õpetaja: siis ma ju ei kirjutanud seda niimoodi ei kirjutanud.
Õpetaja: Kui me kasutame
Õpetaja: mingid muutujad, siis Me ei pane talle tüüpi ette sellepärast, et see annab kompilaatorile nagu sõnumi, et loo silt,
Õpetaja: kui sa tahad kasutada. Ma näen seda algetel kogu aeg,
Õpetaja: et nad mõtlevad, et kogu aeg muutuvad. Peab nüüd edaspidi kasutama niimoodi niimoodi, Nagu kirja paned. See ongi see konks. See on sõnum programmile, et loo üks uus objekt muuta. Vabandust, jah,
Õpetaja: jah, see on täpselt see on õige sõna. See on täpipealt õige sõna. Siin me defineerime muutuja. Me ütleme, et meil on teksti tüüpi muutuja nimega Edaspidi programmis Me saame seda kasutada. Me saame sellele viidata.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kas tema nimi algab tähega. Ee, vaata, kui pikk on tema nimi,
Õpetaja: tee midagi salvestuse andmebaasi, bla, bla, bla, bla. Me saame kasutada seda seda silti.
Õpetaja: Võtke nüüd. Mõelge kogu aeg. Nüüd muutu ainult silt.
Õpetaja: Mina kasutasin oma õppematuse ümbrik. Vaata, et saad nende sisse panna, et ümbriku peal on nimi student.
Õpetaja: Noh, silt. Võibolla. Nagu. Vaata, on see, et kui siin on mingi väga palju väärtusi. Vaata siis see Silt nagu on kuidagi halb analoog. Ja see ümbrik on parem. Minul oli seal eelmaterjal. See oligi student. Kas oli. Niimoodi, et seal oli see näide? Vaata, et tuleb uus õpilane Ja annab oma andmed. Isikuandmed ümbrikas
Õpetaja: Ümbriku peal oli kirjas, et Siin võib olla tekst.
Õpetaja: Ja seal sees oli first name Või mingi full name või mida iganes vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oli see niuke näide minu meelest, et härrasmees võttis selle ümbrik või siis läks päris arvutisse? Vaata, sisestas selle vist praegu.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ongi see, et te Saate aru, tüüp. See definitsioon on niimoodi. Ee, muutuja Defineerimine, et meil on üks mingi asi programmis kasutusel, üks sildikene tüüp
Õpetaja: ja siis nimi, Nii ja ja väärtuse andmine Käib. Ühe võrdusmärgiga ühe võrduse märgiga.
Õpetaja: Mida me teeme kahe võrdusmärgiga Jaavas?
Õpetaja: Me võrdleme
Õpetaja: klassikaline viga, Näiteks et keegi, Tahab vaadata, kas First Name võrdub midagi. Näiteks on ju, kui sa paned. No vi. Viitad mingile muutujale.
Õpetaja: Teen korra siia mingi If Lause. Ma teeksin. Kavas Oleks lihtsam kirjutada. Noh, teed If lause.
Õpetaja: Huvitan kirjutada, kui ma panen siia. Sisse. Vaata, et kas, ee.
Õpetaja: Kas ee first Name võrdub.
Õpetaja: Riho, Nüüd on minu küsimus, et. Kas me tuleme siia koodiploki sisse või mitte? Kas me tuleme siia If Lause sisse või Ei, tule.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, ei tule. See kood isegi Ei, kompileeru.
Õpetaja: Miks sellepärast, et siin see sisu peab alati rehkenduma? True või False,
Õpetaja: on nii, Aga mis siin toimub? Siin on muutujale uue väärtuse andmine.
Õpetaja: Kui oleks niimoodi. Noh, siis juba läheks sisse. Aga muidugi string on objekte objekte ei võrrelda. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Objekti võrreldakse meetoditega nimega Equest Selleni. Jõuame nüüd see sama asi. Näiteks, et. Ee. Okei, Ma küsin nagu siin, et kas Kood kompileerub.
Õpetaja: Kas kood? Oota korra, Kas kood
Õpetaja: üheksa?
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et. Ee. Vaatame korra. Lihtsalt idee järgi. See see päris võrdlus ei ole Päris õige, nagu ta annab vale tulemuse. Aa võib kaine õige tulemuse andma. Ei, ole primitiivne. Aa, tüüp. Ma ei tea, tüüpe. Õppisite
Õpetaja: täpselt Ainult tüübid, mis on olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga See käis ka läbi et Primitiivsed objektid.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: okei, ma räägin sellest, kui me jõuame sinna, vaata. Ma väga palju ei tahaks selle pealt. Ma lasen Chat Cloud Il aidata. Meil tookord selgitada seda asja. Nii, aga põhiline mõte on see, et Kas praegult koodil on mingisugust probleemi?
Õpetaja: Küsimus on see,
Õpetaja: kas kool kompileerub? Nagu. Et. Kas. Kas siin on koolis mingeid vigu, et kompilaator ütleb, et Ei, seda ma paitkoodist küll ei suuda teha,
Õpetaja: Martin.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, okei, siis sul on näidus. Siis ta ei kompileeru. Kas ta nüüd kompileerub?
Õpetaja: Miks sa ei usu Põhjenda Kordad seda?
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, väärtus.
Õpetaja: Aga miks ma. Miks ma ei toh? Kui klassikaliselt ei olegi? Nagu Ütleme, siis Informatsioon tulebki sisse kuskilt internetist ja ma programmis Tahangi vaadata, et Kuule, kui eesnimi selle first name I väärtus on Riho siis ma, noh, Soovin midagi teha. Näiteks
Õpetaja: soovin ta riha andmebaasi lisada. Või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, Kuidas return ei pea siin olema sellepärast, et siin pole isegi meetodit Meil, Mm, täpselt
Õpetaja: vastus on see, et. Ee. No te mõtlesite kindlalt, et siin peab, et ta ei tööta, Vaata, et miks ma Niimoodi küsin. Ta töötab
Õpetaja: süntaksil. Midagi viga pole. Ee tulem. Päriselus Seda Ei, ei, vot String Ei, tegelikult võrdleks Vaata numbreid ja asju, mis On primitiivid. Neid me võrdleme niimoodi. Et kas on võrdne? Kas on suurem väiksem võrdne ja kõik See on ju
Õpetaja: nii stringe, Tegelikult, ee peaks, et loogiliselt. Ma mõtlen, et tal viga on sees selle poolest, et me peaksime seda
Õpetaja: ee ka niiöelda võrdlust tegema niimoodi Equalsus meetodiga, et see oleks nagu korrektne. Vaata, on ju? Aga ta oleks kompileerunud niikuinii ja kohati isegi. Võiks töötada ka, aga minu mõte nüüd on Okei, ma teen ta niimoodi korrektseks. Vaata, nii oleks korrektne. Kuidas teksti vaadatakse. Kas first name. I sisu võrdub
Õpetaja: stringiga liha
Õpetaja: Ta kompileerub küsimus ei ole, et kas Ifi sisse läheb? Ma küsin. Noh, vaata, ma teen valesse kohta. Ma panen. Jätame selle tühjaks ja ma küsin lihtsalt siin üleval seda.
Õpetaja: Kas kood kompileerub?
Õpetaja: Kas see rida kompireerub? Okei, nüüd ma võtan selle If lause ja lähen natukene madalamale.
Õpetaja: Tulen siia.
Õpetaja: Ei, Miks Ta ei kompileeru?
Õpetaja: Ta suri ära. Seal, kus on, ütleme. Ma teen seal rohkem, et on. Ma teen siin lihtsalt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, mingi Kood. Vahet pole, mis kood? Mingi kood.
Õpetaja: Aa, Mingi kood.
Õpetaja: Siis on mingi kood.
Õpetaja: Nii, see siin on Skoop.
Õpetaja: Siin on mingi koodi koodiplokk.
Õpetaja: Tema eluiga hakkab, mi? Mis hetkest? Alates? Mis reast? Alates first name. Sildikene on süsteemis olemas.
Õpetaja: Kakskümmend neli. Millal on viimane rida, Kus ta veel on olemas.
Õpetaja: Keegi pakkus. Kakskümmend, kaks nagu Aa, Okei, kolmkümmend kaks Siin Ta sureb. Miks sellepärast, et me peame vaatama et nagu, kus Tema nagu eluiga hakkab, hakkab siit. Järelikult lõpeb siin.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa siin programmis viitad nagu. Hei, First Name, siis tal on nagu ta oli talkinga. Palun,
Õpetaja: sind pole olemas.
Õpetaja: Hea küll, selline asi on Muuta See ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kuidas teha, et ühes koodipokkis kõik
Õpetaja: muuta, et ei saa kuidagi panna niimoodi. Ei, see see, miks. Miks see hea on vä.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellepärast, et me soovimegi seda, et ütleme niimoodi, kui mul oleks programmis erinevates kohtades. Ma tahan kasutada. Muutuvad First Name. Täiesti erinevad. Tegevused. Erinevad Asjad, Mida nad seal teevad, Siis ma ei taha viidata. Vaata, küsimus on jällegi. Vaata, ära unusta ära. Küsimus on selles objektis.
Õpetaja: Mina panen, Ma teen. Ma teen selle ühe asja ka ära, ma teen selle. Ma panen student.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen muuta nimeks S. Üks
Õpetaja: Teeme siis niukse korraliku. S, Üks ja ma panen student
Õpetaja: S kaks, Nii
Õpetaja: kui ma panen, jälle. Ma kasutan No kasutan neid läpakaid Niimoodi lihtsam, Siis te kõik näete ka, et korraks liimin siia ülesse sööda. Üks,
Õpetaja: kaks.
Õpetaja: Kui minu soov on ikkagi midagi kartuliga adresseerida või temaga midagi koos teha. Või Ta tuleb appi. Vaata, siis, mul on vaja, Vaata, et siin sellest ühe taga on täpselt see inimene.
Õpetaja: Kui meil Nüüd oleks ainult üks sildikene, ja kaks objekti.
Õpetaja: Nii siis praegu on ikkagi selles mõttes seisnud. Vaata, et see silt saab ainult ühega olla seotud, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu oleks ta Arturiga seotud, et kuskil teises lõigus. Mina tahaksin. Öelda Vaata, et ma soovin kasutada, Aga tegelikult mu mõte oleks justkui siin olukorras. Ma soovin, et on hoopis, siis mul on probleem. Kui need mõlemad, et see üks asi, mida ei saa jaavas teha,
Õpetaja: on see, et üks muutuja viitab kahele objektile.
Õpetaja: Ma ei, Noh, isegi füüsiliselt nagu panen selle, nagu kuhu ma panen, ei saa. Ühe ühe Muutuja taga saab olla ainult üks objekt selle taga. Objekt On mitmekihiline olla. Mida iganes, Vaata, on ju. Aga ainult üks objekt.
Õpetaja: Aga mida ma saan teha on see, et ma ütlen, et alguses näeb. Üks on Artur ja Stuudet. Kaks on liha
Õpetaja: Programmis Ei takista mind mitte miski tegemas seda liigutust,
Õpetaja: et mul on mitu sildikest, mis viitavad ühele samale objektile. See on tavaline asi, mis programmis ka juhtub.
Õpetaja: See on okei, Okei,
Õpetaja: täiesti Fine. Ma. Ma tahan, et te saate Hästi, kiirelt aru sellest. Vaata, silt ja objekt on erinevad asjad programmis.
Õpetaja: Nad on erinevad asjad.
Õpetaja: Kui te. Näete kuskilt muutuja nime, see ei Tähenda veel objekti.
Õpetaja: Siin objekt siin selles aa väikses lõigus. Aa, praegult
Õpetaja: Praegult võib öelda, et sellel First name il ei olegi tegelikult tagajõu objekti
Õpetaja: mina. Kas te näete, et siin on kuskil võrdusmärk Ee ja midagi väärtus Siin alles see muuta ja luuakse. Kui ma vaatan, mis tahes rida siin koodis, siis. Kas ma näen, et tal on kuskil väärtus antud?
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaks talle väärtust anda,
Õpetaja: siis ma peaksin kuskil hiljem. Noh, ma teen isegi veel hiljem Seda kuskil näiteks. Ma ei tea. Oletame, et siin tuleb väärtus,
Õpetaja: mis ma kirjutan, kui ma tahan Anda talle väärtust, mis? Ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Just nii, võrdud. Jah, First name võrdub. Ja siis annan mingi nime. Noh, annan. Rain hoopis talle Nimeks
Õpetaja: saate. Aru Seal on kaks erinevat asja. Silt ei tähenda tingimata objekti.
Õpetaja: Okei, ma toon veel teistsuguse näite Nii,
Õpetaja: ma panen nimede siia, Ma kirjutan koodi. Lihtsalt rain.
Õpetaja: Kas tuleme siia sisse?
Õpetaja: See sisse, Okei?
Õpetaja: Kuidas kuidas ma saaksin viidata praegult sellele objektile?
Õpetaja: Ee, real. Kakskümmend kolm. Sellepärast, et kui sa kirjutad niimoodi. Oot, sa. See siin on. Kuidas java täna toimetab? Vaata, niipea kui sa teed mingisuguse string objekti niipea Kui sa kirjutad jutumärgid ja mingi tekst siis taustal tekib tegelikult string objekt. Ma näitan teile, kuidas see väga vanasti oli
Õpetaja: ja väga vanasti oli umbes niimoodi
Õpetaja: uus. Objekt.
Õpetaja: Võtmesõna. New
Õpetaja: teeb objekti. Jah, Jah, see See objekt tekib. Ee, päriselt mälus. Me jõuame sinnamaani ka. Kus ma Räägin mälust
Õpetaja: numbritega. Jah, ee, noh, jah, põhimõtteliselt küll.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt küll,
Õpetaja: aga numbrid ei ole objektid. Nad on primitiivsed väärtused. Lihtsalt vaata aga põhimõtteliselt võib nii mõelda. Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Nüüd minu küsimus on, ee. Kuidas ma saan suhelda selle objektiga? Rain praegult.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan selle? Kuidas ma hetkel saan suhelda Selle, Kui ma siin üt siin, tahan midagi teha,
Õpetaja: Tahan siin ee, Objektiga Rain midagi teha. Kuidas ma saan
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt vastu jääb. Sildi peab peale, aga. Noh, vastus on. Siin See on va vastus. Tegelikult on siin selles mõttes, et ei saagi
Õpetaja: programmis On meil. Ee, meil on objekt. Orienteeritud. Programmeerimine. Objektid on meil andmed. Alati
Õpetaja: Meil on andmed. Noh, me. Noh, päris inimene ei ole. Vaata, Ma võin person kirjutada kuskile personal Classi, aga see ei ole nüüd päris inimene. On ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, et. Ee.
Õpetaja: Meil on Meil programmeerimises ongi vaja suhelda andmetega,
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas? Noh, kui ma tahaksin suhelda teiega iga päev ja rääkida ja teil siin suhelda ja teil ei oleks nimesi,
Õpetaja: Noh, siis hakkaks ju sina sealt vasakult. Ee, teine rida mul. Ma ei saa kuidagi otse viidata aga aga programmis me soovime andmetele ja objektidele viidata Ainukene moodus, kus me saame seda teha? On Need sildikesed muutuja on kui.
Õpetaja: Nagu, et see tundub ju tegelikult loogiline, kui mõelda Nagu päriseluga ka, et mul on mingi tegevus, mida ma soovin käivitada, on ju või? Või Ma soovin kellelegi midagi nagu öelda. Vaata siis Päriselus sa ka ju Pead saama kuidagi sellele subjektile või objektile, nagu viidata.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja noh normaalses elus on siis need nimed, Vaata, kui Meil on lihtsalt kahekesti. Oled siis sa võid niisama rääkida, on ju? Aga idee järgi, kui mul on vaja tõesti öelda, et ühel inimesel siit klassiruumist, et et ole hea. Tule, tule mind, Aita. Vaata, siis. Nimi on ainukene moodus. Kuidas ma saan viidata
Õpetaja: sellele objektile?
Õpetaja: On teil Küsimusi. Selle koha pealt ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ee, see vaikselt hakkab peast veel paika loksuma. Mida varem te hakkate mõtlema sellele, et meil on Ee,
Õpetaja: Meil on muutujad, mis on tegelikult sildid
Õpetaja: ja. Ja asjad, mida te alguses ei saa Aru vaata, kohe, miks, Aga oletame, et meil on Mingi klass nimega klass. Seda ju õppisite, onju? Oli seal nimekirjas,
Õpetaja: kui meil ongi näiteks student. No studenti sees on first Name ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan teha muutujate student.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, kui ma tahan teha objekti student ja anda talle mingi ee sildikese, siis mis võiks olla Selle sildi nimi
Õpetaja: enamus ajast, kui meil on konkreetses Niiöelda programmi lõigus, on lihtsalt mingist mingit tüüpi objektist.
Õpetaja: Ainult Üks objekt on selles Ee, Niiöelda programmi lõigus. Ainult üks tudent on siis kõige parem.
Õpetaja: Muutuja Nimi ongi lihtsalt selle klassi nimi väikse tähega.
Õpetaja: Kui mul oleks programmis näiteks kaks õpilast, siis ma enam niimoodi ei saaks teha. On ju?
Õpetaja: Sest et kui mul on kaks objekti, kellele ma soovin suhelda, siis mul Peab olema kaks silti. Ükski silt ei saa olla sama nimega. No, ma võin ruttu teha. Vaata, on ju, et kui ma panen siia Niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: kui mul on siin üks objekt ja teine objekt.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd teen, selle rea siin. Vaata, ma teen lihtsamalt. Vaata jälle. Ütleme niimoodi kohe siia alla.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: okei, te ei saa päris ma seda ringina tegema, aga ma ei tahtnud seda niimoodi teha, nii et Kui ma praegu ütleks, et print
Õpetaja: oletame, et ta saaks seda välja printida. Ja noh, mis iganes,
Õpetaja: Sest tal oleks ju siin päris suur küsimärk. Vaata, et mis siis konsooli? Nüüd peab minema, Saate aru, meil ei saa olla mida,
Õpetaja: onju? Aa, okei. Kuule, ole prindi mulle student välja. No noh, masin. Miin nagu
Õpetaja: saate seda aru. Vaata, et sildikene vähemalt skoobis. Peab olema unikaalne,
Õpetaja: sest muidu programm ju kui meil oleks Kaks Sam, kaks silti. Ja me teame nüüd seda. Vaata, et siltide taga ei ole Fixed. Nagu mingisugune üks objekt. Et ta võib muutuda seal taga. Mis iganes veel treener tekib, see on täpselt see asi. Vaata, et meil ei saa olla ühte silti, kus on taga kaks objekti,
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei saa olla ka kahte silti sama nimelist.
Õpetaja: No siin on natuke probleemi. Keegi ütleb. Rain, tule, Tule, aita mind, siis Ma näen, räägin,
Õpetaja: läheb, jookseb või mina jooksen. See on see sama küsimus. Noh, klassiruumis saab olla kaks räini Programmeerimises ei saa olla kaks Räini
Õpetaja: saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et me kuskil programmis ju tahame viidata sellele asjale, teha temaga midagi lugeda, Andmeid kirjutada andmeid. Siis temal oleks küsimus, nagu. Aga. Kuule, need on
Õpetaja: mis? Mis objektile sa nüüd siis nagu kavatsed? Siis nagu viidata. Kellest sa räägid, Mida sa jahud? Vaata,
Õpetaja: Meil Ei, saa olla rohkem. Ühes koopis saab olla ainult üks
Õpetaja: ee Selles. Mõttes unikaalsuse mõttes peab olema kõik Kõik muudajad peavad olema unikaalsed, See kood. Ei kompileeru. See kood Ei, kompileeru. Kompilaator ütleb kohe ära juba, et meil ei ole mõtet niukest programmi mul ei ole mõtet hakata vaeva nägema, et teha seda sinu soperdist koodiks Sest see ei tööta niikuinii.
Õpetaja: See See siin on probleem sisse kirjutatud. Kompulaator ütleb No Can Do.
Õpetaja: Meie ei pea. Vanasti oligi niimoodi, et sa pidid käivitama programmi, mis kompileerib sealt. Jaava sidekriips. See pidi mingi faili nime ütlema, et kompileeri see paik koodiks ja nii edasi, on ju? Meil on praegu, kes teeb reaalajas seda kompileerimist.
Õpetaja: Punased jooned, mis tulevad alla. Ja Sõnumid, mis tuleb, ütleb, et. Ee. No go punane. See Ei, kompileeru joon on all. Probleem ütleb ka Kui sa. Nüüd ikkagi käivitaksid selle programmi, siis sa näed, et kompilaator ütleb põhimõtteliselt selle sama sõnumi sulle,
Õpetaja: et ei tee reeglite vastane, Okei,
Õpetaja: kas nüüd peaks seal print nagu selle meetodi taga olema, siis nagu nimi. Seda nime peaks seal.
Õpetaja: Kui meil on kaks nime, siis meil peab olema kaks erinevat silti,
Õpetaja: aga Ma üritasingi Minu mõte oli see, et enamus ajast kui meil on niuksed eritüüpi. Me ei räägi nendest tüüpidest, mis on jaamasse sisse kirjutatud String Ja nii edasi. Ma räägin nendest tüüpidest, et Student Person
Õpetaja: Order product. Noh, nende küljes on informa. Need on andmed ju andmeobjektid
Õpetaja: siis Enamus ajast, kui te kirjutate tüübi
Õpetaja: nii öelda juba ära, et te teate, et mul on student objekti vaja, siis ma räägin nagu nimedest Me üritame hoida neid nimesid alati selles mõttes võimalikult lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Kui see on üks student, objekt, siis selle muutuja nimi on lihtsalt student. Kui See objekt on person. Siis selle muutuja nimi on Person.
Õpetaja: Seni kaua kuni üheskoobis pole. Mitu ee, objekti.
Õpetaja: Ma toon näite teile Account pangandus Ee, teeme niimoodi. Meil on pisikene pangarakendus. Ee, Ee,
Õpetaja: mm Pangaülekanne Ühelt kontolt teisele.
Õpetaja: Oletame, et tegemist on meie meie pangaga Me oleme tuvastanud, ära, et mõlemad niiöelda need, ee kontod on meie meie panga kliendid.
Õpetaja: Me saaksime teha siis ju panga sisese makse. Mäleta? Teate, et see käib niimoodi vanasti. Kui polnud välkmakset, vaata siis. Ainukene välkmakse oli Noh, sama panga kliendile
Õpetaja: kui süsteem tuvastab ära, et mõlemad inimesed on, ee, Meie niiöelda pangakliendid, Siis ta saab käivitada niukse tegevuse nagu et ee maksed. Ee. Mõlemad nagu meie konto vahel, on ju? Meil on kuskil, Ee, mõlemal mõlemal kontol. Kontol. Teeme selle siin ära. Juba
Õpetaja: account.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja kahte. Meil on andmebaasist vaja Saada kätte põhimõtteliselt kaks rida, Mis võrduvad meil programmis täielikult, siis kahe objektiga.
Õpetaja: Meil on keegi, kes. Ee, noh ma panen hästi lihtsamalt,
Õpetaja: muidu võiks panna kredit ja deebit, Aga ma pean panema niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et siia Me ei saa enam panna ju niimoodi. Meil on kahte account I vaja võtta. Eesmärke, et Ühel peab Balance
Õpetaja: Ee, minema väiksemaks ja teisel peab minema suuremaks. Konto. Jääk on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui mina kannan sotti kellelegi, siis minu kontol, Seda pole enam seda sotti. Ja keegi ei teinud seda Soti võrra rikkamaks, eksole?
Õpetaja: Näiteks sellises olukorras. Ee, on meil vaja programmis ühel hetkel tegeleda kahe kontoga potentsiaalsed.
Õpetaja: Ja siis me ei saa teha. Niimoodi, Vaata et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, et meil on mõlemad niiöelda, et me me ei saa seda tava järgida, et me üritame hoida kogu aeg neid muutuja nimesid võimalikult lihtsalt mis peegeldavad sisuliselt seda tüüpi. See tüüp peegeldab seda Infot, millega me tegeleme, on ju? See on kellegi konto, et
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis, kui see plaan on siin. Näiteks see, Vaata, et mina Tahan öelda Account
Õpetaja: Set. Setid olid teil teema või ei olnud nii? Ee, set balance.
Õpetaja: Sada.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ee. Ja siis sellele teisele. Ee, tahaks panna. Ma ei tea, null, et tal sott oli onju? Siis see probleem. On, see et siin ei saa seda tava jälgida. Vaata, et et see muutuja nimi oleks lihtsalt põhimõtteliselt tüübi nimi. Sellises olukorras meil on vaja mingisugust muud nime Siia
Õpetaja: siis saaks teha niimoodi Account Prom Näiteks
Õpetaja: ja Account Two On erinevad nimed
Õpetaja: aga objektid. On mõlemad account Id Ja on erinevad objektid ka tegelikult. Need. On erinevad kontod ja Nüüd siin selles ma saaksin öelda nagu Account From.
Õpetaja: Ee, set balance Sada ja näiteks Account Two Set
Õpetaja: balance Noh. Tegelikult, peaks Arvutama, aga, Kujutame ette, et siis just sott oli ka teisel pool null. Saate mõttes aru, et see praegu on nagu
Õpetaja: või noh, nagu sildid, aga,
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas see sild peaks ju tekkima tulenevalt sellest, kes kellele kannab, et ta ei saa olla Sul süsteemis sees juba nagu, et et Ma Ei tea, Artur on From süsteemis Süsteemis. On See et sul tuleb sisse. Vaata, sa oled sisse logitud panka. Sul on selline asi Nagu
Õpetaja: User. Id abil otsitakse ülesse account tabelist. Õige konto, siis. Ee, nüüd näiteks Selle Konto numbri järgi otsitakse ülesse, Kellele see peaks minema Vaadatakse, kes on meie pank. Panga klient. Kontonumbri järgi vaadatakse ära, et Oled sa meie. Oled see ka meie panga klient.
Õpetaja: Nii kui sa Oled Meie panga klient, siis üldse käivitub see protsess, et on sisene makse. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, see, kes sisse logitud on igal juhul, meie, Ee, klient. Seda me teame juba. Lihtsalt küsimus, kellele see raha läheb? Vaata, kas on meie klient või ei ole. Meie klient, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui Me saime selle selgeks. Siis on täpselt samamoodi, et ühe konto Me otsime User Id Abil. Ülesse, kes ise logis teise Account I. Me Otsime ülesse tema account numbri järgi. Aga siis
Õpetaja: programm. Kui see käivitub, siis ta siis tema alles annab Selle nagu nime Account From,
Õpetaja: See on programmis kohe olemas. Lihtsalt see sisend. Noh, ma ütlen, et see. Kujuta nüüd ette vaata, nagu, et, ee, see programm ei olegi kunagi Selles mõttes selline, Vaata, et meil on siin Artur või Riho.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma teen selle siis natukene paremaks. Ee, account from
Õpetaja: Ma õudsalt hea oleks saanud teinud kohe seda. Jaavas oleks saanud süntaksit hoida. Miks ta nüüd niimoodi joonib? Siin mul jäi see asi pooleli. Vä.
Õpetaja: Tuleb Niimoodi meeldi need vä.
Õpetaja: Noh, kõik on nii kole.
Õpetaja: Nii Ee,
Õpetaja: ta kunagi käsitsi koodi kirjutas on alati vahva mõelda.
Õpetaja: Kurat võtaks, sellega ma just Lähen hulluks ära. Ma ei viitsi niimoodi
Õpetaja: meetodeid üldse õppida, On ju?
Õpetaja: Klassimeetodeid pole? Ee,
Õpetaja: mul seda. Vaid
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on parem internal Aa
Õpetaja: Meetodi parameetreid õppisite, Aga jah,
Õpetaja: see see tegevus käivitatakse Internetist. Tuleb sisse. Sõnum meie serverisse. See see meetod käivitub. Lihtsalt Lepime, selle kokku, mit Kuidas. Mis moodi see koodilõik käivitatakse selle nime järgi?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma panen siia lihtsalt et oleks, võibolla isegi lihtsam. Ma panen
Õpetaja: internal transfer internal Mm, ee, sissetulev objekt. Ma teen ruttu selle ka. Valmis
Õpetaja: sisse tuleb. Ee, objekt sisse.
Õpetaja: Transfer Request.
Õpetaja: Siin on sellised väljad nagu. Ee, ma Korra panen siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul oleks natukene lihtsam teha niimoodi, et kood oleks normaalne.
Õpetaja: Ee, sisse tuleb. Ee, näiteks Ee Integer User Id.
Õpetaja: Ee, Paneme transfer
Õpetaja: transfer too account number,
Õpetaja: Siis see tuleb. Ee, Amount.
Õpetaja: Noh, see oleks midagi. Pigem oleks long. Muidugi, tegelikult.
Õpetaja: Ee, Big Testimaal.
Õpetaja: Nii, See on objekt
Õpetaja: klass. Sellest on võimalik teha objekte. Sellest on võimalik teha tuhandeid objekte sadu. Tuhandeid objekte programmi sees. Tahaks
Õpetaja: iga objekt elab Oma elu.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes vahet pole, Meile tuleb sisse sõnum. Jasonina tekstifail tuleb sisse. Mida meie siis süsteem teeb? Selle klassi objektiks automaatselt meile ära. Seal sees on mingisugune väärtus user. Ido, account number. Ja Amount
Õpetaja: Mõte on selge. Enam vähem. See on lihtsalt objekt. Me te peate oma Ei tee seda. Vaata, te peate ette kujutlema Selline objekt on meil süsteemis. Olemas.
Õpetaja: Sellist objekti on võimalik luua niimoodi, et nendel väljadel User Id, Transfer Account number ja Amount on mingid päriselu. Noh Päris väärtused ja tulevad väljastpoolt süsteemi. Arusaadav,
Õpetaja: Nii kui meil tuleks niuke sisse Internal Transfer Order. Siis siin ongi see meetod, et siin on vaja meetodit defineerida. Meie ütleme, et see koodilõik
Õpetaja: siia, seda on nimeliselt võimalik Käivitades öeldes Transfer Service näiteks punkt kaasa. Me nõuame, et peab tulema sisse objekt. Mis objekt? Transfer Request. Objekt
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et edaspidi siit hakkab Skoop. Näete, et edaspidi me programmis siis saaksime sellega objekti suhelda. Mis asi see siin on?
Õpetaja: Mis asi see siin on, mis me just rääkisime.
Õpetaja: See on parameeter, Aga see on ühtlasi ka.
Õpetaja: Silt, on ju? See on siit See on parameeter. Parameeter on ka muuta.
Õpetaja: Nii See on silt. See tähendab seda, et edaspidi Meil on olemas Niukene sildikene objekt. Ja seal taga peab olema objekt. Mis objekt Seal on? Seal on objekt täpselt nende andmetega. Mis meil sealt internetist sisse tuli? Palun teeme meie pangas. Ee konto üle ülekande ühelt kontolt teisele, on nii
Õpetaja: Okei, Cool ja meetod on üle kandnud.
Õpetaja: Meetod on ülekanne ja Internal Execute Internal Transfer küsimusi.
Õpetaja: See on tegevus.
Õpetaja: Meetod. Meetod on tegevus
Õpetaja: Mis Asi on meetod. Noh, ma ütlen ma täna rohkem küsimusi. Küsimus aega. Mis asi on ee meetod? Meetod. On Nimeline koodilõik.
Õpetaja: Nimeline koodilõik.
Õpetaja: See on samamoodi, kui mu naine ütleb, et mine vii prügikast välja.
Õpetaja: Siis siin on põhimõtteliselt mis? See, mis see tegevus siin on, mine vii prügikast välja Nii, nüüd. Minul on ära defineeritud sammud. Mida ma selle jaoks pean tegema? Nüüd tuleb see sisu. See koodi Sisu.
Õpetaja: Mine kõnni prügikasti juurde. See nüüd on programmi sisu selles selles koolideedias.
Õpetaja: Ava. Seega võta prügikast.
Õpetaja: Võta see prügi kätte. Siin on mingi jama, Ole vihane
Õpetaja: ikka oma naist. Miks mu elu on selline? Äkki ma olen hoopis sõprade juures ei ole. Need asjad ei ole naised, nad on ära programmeerinud meid, et mine võta ja ei vingu. Ja siis on need sammud. Lähed välja paned prügiast blabla, saate mõttest aru,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd ongi see. Vaata, et mis miks, on nagu. Miks su programmeerimise võlu ongi see. Vaata, et meil on meetod. Meil on imelised meetodid, kui keegi ütleb. Vaata, et mine vii prügikast välja. Vaata siis ta ei ütle. Vaata mulle seda Ju see oleks. Oi, ma vihkaks. See on mikromanageerimine, Drain, mine prügikasti juurde.
Õpetaja: Tee prügikasti uks lahti.
Õpetaja: Võta see välja, et niimoodi niimoodi ei soovi keegi käske saada. Vaata, on ju ei soovi Programmis me niimoodi ei soovi koodi lugeda.
Õpetaja: Meid ei huvita, et Mine võta ja tee ja liigu. Astu ja ava uks ja keera uks kinni. Ja
Õpetaja: Me tegelikult programmis tahame näha meetodi nimesid. Miks sellepärast need kõnelevad meiega nagu inglise keeles raamat?
Õpetaja: Kui sa lood loed niimoodi If
Õpetaja: If see prügikasti uks on kinni. Sul ei ole jalatseid siis pane jalga. Ja If, üks samm on tehtud. Siis pane teen. Noh,
Õpetaja: seda Seda koodi ei taha keegi lugeda. Seda ei taha keegi lugeda. See on seal olemas koodilõigus, aga me ei taha seda lugeda Kuskil mujal Mind huvitab see.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: nüüd me natukene mängime siin kaasa. Ma ei taha siin lõputult jääda kirjutama, mis? Meil on nüüd vaja teada. Meil Tuleb see request sisse.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja siis ee, mingit kontot? No ma teen selle ka veel.
Õpetaja: Account Account is on väljad. Ee, Private String Account number.
Õpetaja: Ja ma teen ainult ühe välja. Siia, veel juurde. Tegelikult oleks loomulikult rohkem oma panganduses töötanud. Ma tean, kui palju seal välja on?
Õpetaja: Ee, Paneme siis ee. Big Desimal
Õpetaja: ma all ja paneme selle nimeks hoopis Balance.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on kõige minimalistlikum kui üldse ka, ole, onju? Nii? Mis meil nüüd ülesanne on? Vaatame, et see Transfer Request is on olemas user Id.
Õpetaja: Meil on olemas kontonumber, kellele see peab kuuluma.
Õpetaja: Ja meil on olemas
Õpetaja: Amount. Vaata. Ee, mida me soov. Mida üks soovib kanda. Vaata, on ju, et minu Id ga. Mina Soovin kanda kontonumbrile sada eurot.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Mis need Action Id siin meil on on see. Vaata, et kõigepealt
Õpetaja: Meil on siis süsteemist, ehk andmebaasist on vaja leida ülesse Kõigepealt. Ee, üks konto.
Õpetaja: Kus on Balance? Ja teine konto? Kus on Balance, On nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, ma nüüd. Ee. Ma Mina teen lihtsalt selle objekti. Ma ütlen New Account
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen, et ma mängin, et kõigepealt otsime user Account I ülesse user
Õpetaja: Account, Aga lihtsam oleks tegelikult mõelda selles transaktsioonis. Vaata, see kanne on ju meie kasutaja poolt alati tehtud. See saab ainult väljuv olla. Te ei saa panka sisse, logida ja panna teha niukse. Ma ei saa panka sisse logida ja teha seal tegevus. Artur kannab mulle soti
Õpetaja: ja keegi veel.
Õpetaja: Ma saan alati ju teha, mida ma saan Ise kanda ju sellest välja. Et mina pangakliendina ei saa ju kuidagi. Me saame juba praegu öelda põhimõtteliselt ja loetavuse huvides Vaata, me saaksime teha, et ee, account
Õpetaja: from.
Õpetaja: Nii, meil on sama asja vaja saada. Account too.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Mina lihtsalt kirjutasin need siia praegult niimoodi. Päriselus Need objektid tuleksid andmebaasist. Me lihtsalt mängime juurde. Leiti andmebaasist.
Õpetaja: Ma teen veel niimoodi ka. Näete, See Transfer Request,
Õpetaja: onju? Ma võtan Getteriga. Võtan selle get user Id välja ja teen siia ühe user Id.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma ütlen, leiti, Ee, uuser Id
Õpetaja: abil Ülesse
Õpetaja: on arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd ma selle account u ga põhimõtteliselt Me mängime seda samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on siis Ee Transfer Request. See on see, on See informatsioon on selles objekti sees. Me võtame
Õpetaja: transfer. Too account. Numbri. Võtame sellest Request ist sõnu. Mis tuleb. See on sõnum, mis tuleb sisse.
Õpetaja: See siin on sildikene, et me saame selle objektiga suhelda. Kus on informatsioon olemas? Seal on olemas,
Õpetaja: Seal on olemas transfer to account number. Ja seal on Amount.
Õpetaja: Noh, siia võiks samasuguse asja panna, peale et
Õpetaja: leiti ee, no mis siin Sees oli
Õpetaja: user Id Abil. Leite Associ Account Transfer Two Account Numbri Järgi leite. Üles teine. Account On nii tähele panime. Account From Teise Panime Account. Two On Nii
Õpetaja: nii? Nüüd, Meid huvitab see mount Mis, on ka siin sees
Õpetaja: siin. On mingi summa kujutame. Ette et, see on sott.
Õpetaja: Nii, siis ma saan teha kõigepealt näiteks sellest Account Form ist.
Õpetaja: Võtan välja, Näete, siin sees on ju informatsioon Balance, on nii
Õpetaja: Nii ma panen account. Ma teen, et account from get.
Õpetaja: Ee, oota. Ma kohe. Siia panna, tata peale pole gettereid settereid.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd on Nii, Account. Cat Balance.
Õpetaja: Ma teen sellest muutuja. Ma Ma kirjutan nagu paremat poolt ennem ja siis teen nagu muutuja. Sildikese silti ei ole. Praegult
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et ole hea.
Õpetaja: Tee mulle üks sildikene.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma panen selle account. Ma panen balance. Ee, ma olen Pikalt
Õpetaja: ma niimoodi ei teeks. Kogu see asi oleks natuke teistmoodi, onju? Aga mul on Account. Balance. Account From Balance.
Õpetaja: On see arusaadav ma panen siia juurde ka kommentaari. Vaata, et me nagu oleks praegult see mingi mõttelõng.
Õpetaja: Sada eurot.
Õpetaja: No okei, las ta olla rohkem kakssada, siis on nagu millestki lahutada ka seda ka mõistma
Õpetaja: no. Nii mina, muidugi peaks seda lahutama või. On kakssada selles? Mõttes Vahet Pole
Õpetaja: ee. Paneme, siia peale kakssada. Eurot
Õpetaja: on selle asja Siin rehkendus on see arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on meil samasugune tegevus vaja teha. Sellega meil on vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, kus See Tuo on konto siia.
Õpetaja: Account Two Gate Ee. Balance, teeme. Samamoodi account To balance Nii
Õpetaja: Hetkel kel, iganes ee. Account see. On tema Balance on hetkel lihtsalt. Aa. Paneme ka mingi muu numbri. Paneme. Temal on viiskümmend.
Õpetaja: Nii, mis meil on? Teeme selle läbi. Vaata, et meil Tuleb sisse. Request, kus on olemas User Id
Õpetaja: Transfer Account number. Ja tegelikult on Amount ka, mida me veel ei ole puutunud. Kõigepealt me üles otsime. Aa, selle konto. Aa, kes? Aa, Kes me ise oleme?
Õpetaja: Ja täpsemalt sealt seest. Võtame välja, et mis on hetke meie Balance, Nii,
Õpetaja: ma panen siia veel juurde ühe sõna
Õpetaja: juba etenägelikult. Current Balance, saate aru.
Õpetaja: Hetke. Seis ja Transfer Too Account Aa talents
Õpetaja: Current, see on muut. See kohe muutub.
Õpetaja: On nagu lihtsam jälgida. Siis hetkel on ju mingi balance.
Õpetaja: Ühel on kakssada. Teisel on viiskümmend.
Õpetaja: Mis on üldse Tegevus, mis ma nüüd pean tegema?
Õpetaja: No andmed, on mul kõik olemas. Mis ma pean tegema.
Õpetaja: Nojah, mis see tähendab ülekanne?
Õpetaja: Täpselt, Onju ee. Siis nüüd tuleb mängu. Vaata, et aga. Mis oli üldse see? Mount, mis tuli sisse, Onju,
Õpetaja: Näete Amount User Idount. See tuleb sõnumina sisse.
Õpetaja: See informatsioon on see, mis tuleb süsteemi sisse, mis käiv käivitatakse. See meetod.
Õpetaja: Kui server serverisse tuleb sõnum, käivitatakse See meetod Kui tuleb selline Tegevus. Keegi vajutab nuppu.
Õpetaja: Noh, ise vajutab kasutaja nuppu.
Õpetaja: See meetod käivitub.
Õpetaja: Leiame üles konto, konto, hetke jäägi, vaatame kuidas teisel on ja nii Edasi on ju?
Õpetaja: Mis meil on vaja teha. Meil on siis vaja võtta. No Teeme siis kõigepealt maha võtmise. Ära Vaata, nii on kõige Tähtsam süsteem läheb katki. Peaasi, et maha saab raha võtta. Kas kellegi juurde tuleb? Noh, keegi nutma ei hakka, kui tal ee raha juurde Ei, tule. Ja ta ei tea, et tal pidi juurde tulema.
Õpetaja: Aga kui läheb midagi katki ja maha läinud
Õpetaja: valesti, mida iganes hakkavad nutma, Noh, Vahet pole, mis järjekorras mõlemad tegevused tuleks. Ära teha Nii või? Na
Õpetaja: meil on vaja siis arvutada ju ära, et mis hakkab olema
Õpetaja: Selle Account From Us Balance, onju? Olen nõus, Mis me selleks peame tegema?
Õpetaja: Sellest tuleb lahutada. Aa, ma võibolla veel ikka veel võtnud Vaata Request ist.
Õpetaja: Võtame samamoodi Muuta välja Amount, et meil oleks ta silme ees. Amount
Õpetaja: või Transfer. Amount. Kuidas te soovite, et kutsute seda Lihtsalt Amount.
Õpetaja: Ma olen Transfer Amount. Noh, see on jälle. Vaata küsimus, mis rohkem kõnetab, On ju koodi loetavus.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis temaga peab juhtuma mis Sellega peab juhtuma.
Õpetaja: See peab vähenema, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma juba vihkan, et ma tegin Big.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see on objekt.
Õpetaja: Aa, oota, Savi Ee, Põmm, kas ma saan? Aa, ma ei saa refaktureerida.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen selle integriks Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et praegult tüüpi ei saa refaktureerida, Kui ma Tahan seda reflektoreerida. Mõtleb, et näete. Niukene klass on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ta mõtleb, et ma tahan muuta seda.
Õpetaja: Nime.
Õpetaja: Seda ma ütlen, ma tahan seda ära muuta nime. Aa, ma seda ei taha teha.
Õpetaja: Siis ma lihtsalt praegu teen siin niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ma teen üldse, et täis arvudeks teen ruttu ümber.
Õpetaja: Ma oleks pidanud seda ette nägema, et lahutustehe ei saa tulla enam nagu meie tava lihtsa matemaatikaga, et kasutades miinuse pluss märke ja jagates ja nii edasi, et on objekt.
Õpetaja: Tal on meetodid Ad subtract ja nii edasi. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Aa, te Ei, pea seda teadma, Ma lihtsalt praeg. Teen korda, et on, ee.
Õpetaja: Ja on, sest et nüüd ma saan teha lahutusi. Ee, ilusti Siin ka veel intergare.
Õpetaja: See lihtsalt on sündaks.
Õpetaja: Mul on niimoodi lihtsam teha. Nii missioon oli see, et temalt kahesajalt tuleb võtta maha. Mis see Transfer remont on? Oleme seda kokku leppinud üldse vä?
Õpetaja: Teeme. Teeme sada. Vaata, onju. See on Niuke, et igast eri noh jäävad niuksed. Numbrid, mida ei saa tekita mingit segadust, et tulemused peavad olema kindlasti väga erinevad, on ju? Sellelt tuleb lahutada maha. See olete nõus.
Õpetaja: No siis Ma võtan ju selle. Muutuja on ju sisu muutuja. Mul ei ole kuskil seda kahte. Sadat
Õpetaja: siis sümbool sümboliseerib?
Õpetaja: Ee, ütlen siin niimoodi, et see Account From Balance miinus mis asi.
Õpetaja: Noh, Transfer Amount, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma panen selle tulemusse ja panen selle
Õpetaja: Account From
Õpetaja: New Balance. Ma teen niukse muutuja lihtsalt nii see Mul on olemas, on Nii
Õpetaja: sa nüüd välja arvatud. Olete nõus.
Õpetaja: Mis veel nüüd peaks tegema,
Õpetaja: Tontoo?
Õpetaja: Teeme selle sama arvutuse. Ära vaata ka siis teisel poolel. Aga tegelikult siin on veel siis samm. Vaata, siin ongi nagu see, et me peame hakkama mõtlema. Ee, vaata, teie peate mõtlema seda, et see account objekt ja see account objekt. Need justkui on üks rida andmebaasist,
Õpetaja: kus kuskil on veerg amount. Saate ma tast aru.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, me tegelikult peaksime nüüd tegema niimoodi. Vaata, et. Noh, ärme lähe siis selle järgmise kallale, et me nüüd teame, et Account From Il peab tekkima uus balance
Õpetaja: siukse summaga. See siin on põhimõtteliselt. Ee, kus sa siin oled?
Õpetaja: See on kakssada.
Õpetaja: Miinus viiskümmend oli onju Ah, persse, Sada
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et see uus uus ee tulemus on siis meil siin Selle muutuja sees palju
Õpetaja: sobivad.
Õpetaja: Teine on sada Viiskümmend. Okei, ma seda veel ei ole jõudnud ära. Teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, Euro. Märk nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, sa samasuguse tegevuse saaks siis teha ka Noh, Ütleme Siin allpool on siis see, et Ee, account.
Õpetaja: Ee, account Balance.
Õpetaja: Mis me siin teeme?
Õpetaja: Liidame ja liidame selle Sama transfer Amount, I on ju
Õpetaja: nii. Sellest saab ka teha. Ee, oma muutuja.
Õpetaja: Siin on veel Jäänud tüüppaigast ära.
Õpetaja: Kui see oli Account From New Balance, siis selle nimi võiks olla Account Two Balance
Õpetaja: On. See kair Exco Objekt ah.
Õpetaja: Miks? Ta selle sinna lõppu kõrvetab
Õpetaja: nii?
Õpetaja: Jah Nii,
Õpetaja: ee temal, on siis. Ee, mis see siis From Balance oli? Ütleme selle, ära mis see vastus on. Mul on lihtsam niimoodi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, sada viiskümmend on Ju Sada viiskümmend.
Õpetaja: Siin on
Õpetaja: viiskümmend pluss sada, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Niimoodi tegime ära. Nüüd on tegelikult päriselus. On siis see, Vaata, et me Leidsime ühe rea andmebaasist. See hakkab teil niimoodi olema. Ja see elab siin objektis.
Õpetaja: Siis seda sama objekti. Nüüd on vaja kasutada Et Salvestada see ka andmebaasid tagasi maha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ongi niimoodi, et küsimus on see. Vaata, et siit ju ühel oli Balance mis siin, oli Vaata Balance Kakssada
Õpetaja: teisel oli viiskümmend
Õpetaja: Nüüd päriselt seal objektides nendes, samades objektides. Nüüd peab muutuma nende väärtused ka. Ja siis me salvestame selle objekti ühe Reana ära. Nagu
Õpetaja: et ma võtaksin siin praegu. Ee, account from set Balance.
Õpetaja: Ja see on siis mis see Ee, account From New Balance Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd sama. Teeksin sarnase Asja Teeksin tegelikult ka.
Õpetaja: Account Two Ee. Set balance. Ja Temal. On siis account To New Balance
Õpetaja: ja siin kain ta nüüd siin lõpus oleks, siis kujutame ette lihtsalt salvesta Account From ja Account Two Andmebaasi
Õpetaja: Okei, noh? Niukene, Väikene, Esimene puudutusobjekt. Orienteeritud maailma.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, me muid asju praegu ei katsu. Vaata, sest me hakkame vaikselt nagu neid asju tegema ka päriselt ja Avast läbi. Ma saan midagi käivistada ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Aga, ee, see peamine asi, mis mis ma ütlengi see A, B, C ongi ju Esimene asi, mis meil on Praegult, on muutuja.
Õpetaja: Te peate hakkama aru saama, et muutujate taga on meil objektid,
Õpetaja: isegi isegi Frontend is. Meil on samamoodi. Tegelikult seal. Objektid on seal muutujate taga.
Õpetaja: Seal objektide sees on väljad ja väljade sees on väärtused.
Õpetaja: Account Balance. Noh, see on Meie, see. Me andmeobjekt.
Õpetaja: Andmeobjekt?
Õpetaja: Kas kas meil on kaks klassi siin? Kas siin on kirjutatud, et Niuke klassi nimi nagu Account Aa Two Ja
Õpetaja: Ei ole, on ju? Me kasutame seda sama objekti andmete kandjana, et tee üks objekt sellest
Õpetaja: Noh, süsteem. Me. Me siin ei tee Objekti. Siin on see, et leia andmebaasist üks rida.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et tee sellest reast Account objekt. Miks
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et meil objekt oli Programmeerimine selle objektiga. Me saame programmis siis niiöelda toimetada. Saame teha seal programmis.
Õpetaja: Miks meil on vaja nimesi? Sellepärast, et pro sel selle programmi sees me Tahame viidata andmetele Account From Two
Õpetaja: Ma. Tahan sellega midagi teha ma. Tahan sellega midagi teha
Õpetaja: kui, meil. Ei oleks kui, meil oleks lihtsalt Näiteks student uue studenti süsteemi, onju? Andmebaasi lisamine seal. Meil ei ole vaja. Mingi student. New student.
Õpetaja: Tüüp on student ja muud. Nime ei Ole vaja panna New student.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et seal lõigus on seda ainult ühe korra. Niikuinii. Las ta olla lihtsalt student. Meetodi nimi on Ad New student.
Õpetaja: See võib ütleb, mis siin toimub.
Õpetaja: Andmebaasist Fine student muuta. Ja, oo, tüüp on student. Nimi on student.
Õpetaja: Andmebaasis leitakse selle sisu, saad selle kätte all midagi teeb? Vabandust, internetist tuleb andmebaasi. Läheb või vastupidi, kuva Saate ma lihtsalt aru.
Õpetaja: Meil on objektid. Meil on imesildid. Mida kiiremini te hakkate seda lahti enda peas muukima. Ee, et te tõesti saate aru. Mis asi on muutuja?
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et me kohe Nüüd teeme pausi, Aga nüüd. Ma Võibolla räägiks ka korra, mis Mina eile kuulsin,
Õpetaja: See praegult rigeldas mind täielikult. See, mis ma räägin, Ee, Mis ma räägin?
Õpetaja: Noh, oli tuline.
Õpetaja: Ee, see. See oli sõna otseses mõttes arutelu. Kuskil neli inimest Siis olid paneelis Istusid seal ees.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis seal oli Ee, Telia ja keegi veel. Ja siis olid inimesed, kes istusid umbes nagu niimoodi. Aga natuke. Rohkem nagu ringi igal pool. Istusid ja siis me hakkasime asju arutama. Meil oli võimalus nagu nendelt suurtelt ettevõtetelt küsida.
Õpetaja: Mis nad siis tahavad, Mis, see kuidas nemad näevad,
Õpetaja: Mis see, mis see. Noh, me arutasime üldse muidugi seda seisu hetkel, et. Kas me. Kas asi on nii hull? Aa, nagu Aa meedia Seda kajastab.
Õpetaja: Ee, leidsime seda, et, ee. Tähendab, et tegelikult, see asi, et juunior arendajaid ei ole enam vaja, ei vasta tõele.
Õpetaja: Bullshit See on jama
Õpetaja: ajakirjanduses Seda niimoodi. Ee, tõesti, see tuleb. Ma ei tea, kuidas teil, kui te tulite siia kursusele. Kas teil oli nagu veits Seda tunnet ka. Vaata, ma tulen midagi õppima. Aga kas kas mind on üldse vaja? Vaata, Sest mult on küsitud seda.
Õpetaja: No kui kuskil Redditis loed. Seal on ikka see, et keegi kirjutab, et, oo, mõtlen progemisele ja. Siis. Tuleb kohe. Oi, loll. Oled meelega, et oleks vähem Konkurentsi. Ilmselt küll. Mõtlesin sedapidi, et. Ee, noh, ma olen Ikka viiskümmend. On ju et. Tegelikult, ee, et ma vaatan, kuidas see Ai järjest tuleb. Sest mul on pigem see tunne, et see, et päriselt aru saada, mis taustal toimub, hakkab olema nagu uus hügieen, et
Õpetaja: et ma ei tea, kas must arendaja saab.
Õpetaja: Aga
Õpetaja: Vähemalt ma tahan aru saada, et. Noh, et, ee, mina olen loll või see, kes mulle midagi müüa üritab.
Õpetaja: No vot seal kõigil on erinevad motivatsioonid. Vaata, kõik ei tahagi võibolla arendajaks minna ka. Vaata, onju? Aga kui tulla nüüd selle küsimuse juurde, et kas, ee. Kas tarkvara arendaja? No juuniorid. Enam ei ole vaja. Siis. Ee, see. See sõnum vist. Me. Noh, Mina, ma, Eks mul jääb teravalt silma, kui ma näen. Vahepeal oli eriti mingi
Õpetaja: pool aastat tagasi tuli nagu mingi riburada pidi mingi kolm neli artiklit Kuskilt tulid, mis oli selle nurga? Alt, Vaata et umbes see amet on nagu surnud. Ja juuniorit pole vaja ja bla, bla, bla, blabla, Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: ei ole. Ee, ei ole. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kedagi peale ei tule. Seene võib saada seda. Rääkisime ka ja se seda arutasime ka,
Õpetaja: aga Tulles tagasi selle juurde. Vaata, et tegelikult on vaja Aga siis hakkas siis nagu, siis. Ee, See, mis see, mis oli nagu tuline, oli See, et et eks seal oli.
Õpetaja: Seal, oli mingi üks, kaks inimest, kes oli nagu selgelt umbes ee
Õpetaja: sellises sellise mõtlemisega, et ee, agendid Saab nagu nii võimsaks teha. Seal taustal ise Hullult teevad, et sa annad. Noh, üks ko, üks. Aa, vend rääkiski seal mingi päris asjades et no, mingi
Õpetaja: monstertöö ära teinud, et neil on mingisugused spekid ja spetsifikatsioonid ja tehnoloogiad on nagu mingi millimeetri Noh, välja. Mingi millimeetri haaval Nagu tükkideks võetud ja põhimõtteliselt kindel. Vaata, nagu kõik on ära kirjeldatud. Mida tohib. Kuidas peab? Mida? Ära tee, mida teed ja nii edasi, nagu nii hullult. Ja siis sul on seal mingi agent, mis kontrollib seda Seda output I ja bla, bla, bla
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt nagu sisuliselt, nagu Oli nagu niimoodi, Et nagu, et. Et, noh, pole inimest vaja.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, arendajat Pole vaja, siim vene. Ma ise kavatse ka pärast, et keegi võiks kohe ära vaadata. Kes ta üldse on, Nagu ma ei saa. Ta. Ta oli ka kuidagi haridusega seotud.
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, nad töötavad, siis ma. Kindlasti ma võtan ühenduse kusjuures tegelt. See, mis ta rääkis. Oli minu jaoks huvitav. Muidugi,
Õpetaja: Ja siis seal oli üks. Ee, üks, Aa, ühe mingi ettevõtte esindaja, kes, ee,
Õpetaja: hästi, palju Mingi manufactury. Mingi ja nii edasi. Seal loetles, et on mingi mingid protsessid, mis tal on Mingi üks insener ja teine insener. Ja Kolmas insener
Õpetaja: Ja siis. See suund, mida tema üritas üldse rääkida, oli see. Vaata, et et need Tööriistad ja vahendid. Ja ka mingi süsteemne ja kasutasõnad. Skill koguaeg, Siis skill. Meil on skill, Id ja skillid, ja orkestreerimine ja bla. Bla, bla, et et seal oli nagu siis tema, point oli hoopis see. Vaata, et need kandja, need eksperdid, need, kes teevad oma tööd, need Ensileeri,
Õpetaja: et nemad on nagu hakkavad vaikselt ise tarkvara tegema. Vaata sellepärast, et nad nende tööriistadega suudavad seda ära teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu point võibolla oli siis et kas nagu tarkvara arendajat on vaja? No kui te oleks näinud neli inimest, kes seal paneelis istusid, ja kes on ettevõtete, Ee, niiöelda. Noh, enamus seal. Vist. Põhimõtteliselt neljast. Kolm vist. Olid siis tegelikult rätsepad. Üks oli Telia oma toode, vaata onju
Õpetaja: Raino Koit ma teda väga austan. Ta. Ma ütlen, ma tean teda ka. Veits, et ta Hästi, tark inimene,
Õpetaja: et sa paneel nüüd loomulikult. Sellega ju ei ei nõustunud tegelikult, et tarkvaraarendajat ja tarkvaraarendusfirmasid pole vaja. See on kohti, kus see töötab kindlasti. Ja on Domeen ehk valdkondi äri ja, noh, Mingisuguste setup. Ide Selline asi võib töötada,
Õpetaja: et et, noh, oma töötajad põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: või kellele iganes või mingi poolautomatiseeritud protsessidele annad speki ette mida Ma tahan. Nad oskavad hästi kirjeldada. Spetsialistid oskavad hästi kirjeldada. Sellega Ma nõustun, et kui sul on spetsialist, kes oskab täpselt ära selgitada, mida sa tahad.
Õpetaja: Ja Nüüd Sul on olemas põhimõtteliselt mingi ai lahendus, mis suudab sellega nagu korrektselt enamvähem fineilt ära teha. Jah, I can see That happening ja sihukesed nagu töötavad mudelid. Aga see ei kehti nagu üle maailma kõigega Igal pool Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: et see nagunii ei ole. Noh, meil oli seal erinevad punktid ka mida me arutasime, nagu. Ja need vaated olid nagu ajaliselt ka erinevad, et me kord me rääkisime Sealt mingi kolmest neljast aastast. Kord räägiti mingist kolmekümne aasta pärastest asjast. Nagu, et Noh,
Õpetaja: mõni. Asi oli tegelikult ülikama. Vaata, onju, koolid ja Institutsioonid. Seal oli kooli kood. Jõhvi oli seal kohapeal ossa. Keegi julges nende kohta isegi isiklikult öelda.
Õpetaja: See on mingi jama Naine tõusis püsti nagu andmiseks,
Õpetaja: ma ise olin ka seal. Tegelikult. Ee, mu ülemus oli ka seal. Muidugi ma ei tea, mis temast arvab, aga ma ise Olin ka natuke Fast I sellepärast, et ma nagu ei tahtnud. Nagu nõustuda ka nagu mingi mõningate väidetega. Nagu jama. Mind rohkem tegelt huvitas Ka Paneeli arvamus ka rohkem kui kui need, mis seal vahepeal arutasid. Aga tähtis on tegelikult ka selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ee, nagu proovida mõelda tõesti Ka nagu neid teisi argumente. Vaata, mis nagu. Võibolla ei ole nii meeltmööda. Minu huvi oli Ainukene asi oli see, mida ma üritasin sellega välja tuua. Lihtsalt öelge mulle, mida ma õpetama pean.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt öelge midagi. Ma sain sealt. Ma kohe näitan ka. Ma tegin mingi kokkuvõtte.
Õpetaja: Aa, Jah, aga see oli selles mõttes tuline. Sellepärast, et see vend, kes pani seal seda pläusti suust välja. Vaata, et jaa, et nagu võtad Kõik millimeetrid kaupa paigast, nagu paned Teed mingi põhimõtteliselt, et ei olegi vaja. Ja kõrval istus mul mingi tüüp kes hakkas rääkima. Ei, no Ma põhimõtteliselt võin mingi nädalavahetusele panna mistahes rakenduse püsti, et ütlen talle piisavalt hästi. Töötab seal vigu see on Fine, Vaata ja siis ta Üritas ka kuidagi öelda, et
Õpetaja: paned seal mingi viisteist tuhat agenti proovima, et nagu, et kas see asi nagu kukub pikali või mitte, vaata,
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, et agent kontrollib sul seda tööd nagu. Vaata, et, ee, mängib läbi testimine, kes või mida iganes, onju? Ma mõtlesin nagu seda, et ma küsin ta käest seda, et.
Õpetaja: Kas sa päriselt tahad öelda mulle nagu seda, et vaata, et sa ütled näiteks paned mingi väga hea speki vastu. Ta ütles, et ta ütles, et võib pimesi usaldada. Me hakkame jõudma sinna kohta, kus on pimesi usaldada. Nagu Aa pangasüsteem, et tahad, öelda, et sa nagu päris furiilne. Kui ütled nädalavahetusega, et pane, tee mulle. Tee mulle pank. Tee mulle pangasüsteem.
Õpetaja: Kas päriselt julgeksid, Nagu seda usaldada, et et sisse ei vaata. Ja et nagu ei olegi vaja mõista. Vaata, onju. Ja ma ütlesin, et sina räägid mingi Viieteist tuhandest agendist, kes lihtsalt võibolla ei jõudnud selle prooviga. On ju? Kuna sinna näiteks mingi sada tuhat inimest nagu kasutajad taha. Vaata, Tahad öelda, et see ei kuku pikali või? Muidugi kukub. Pikali on ju? Ja probleem on selles. Vaata, et need asjad ei oska väga hästi parandada ja teha asju paremaks.
Õpetaja: Nad oskavad võibolla nullist uuesti teha. Võibolla kuidagi paremini, aga ma ütlen, et see oli Minority Anyway, Ee nüüd, Mis paneel muidugi rääkis, oli ikkagi see, et ee, on vaja endiselt juuniorit.
Õpetaja: Nad tõdesid ka Loomulikult seda, et et on tõesti see shift toimunud. Vaata, et on vähem vaja. Inimesi, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga mis puutub juunioritesse, siis. Ee, nüüd hakati see suund rohkem oli nüüd selline, et on vaja teistsugust juuniorit.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Aa, kahjuks. Kahjuks. Nagu selles mõttes see. No kohe vaatame detaili ka. Üldine Foon oli see, et on vaja paremat Juuniori.
Õpetaja: Nad Tegelikult tahaksidki seenioreid.
Õpetaja: Juuniori nahas meil On vaja uusi inimesi.
Õpetaja: On Vaja uusi inimesi, kes tulevad. Nad soovivad, et nad juuniorid oleksid Paremad,
Õpetaja: tugevamad. No uskuge mind, te eksite väga valesti. Vaata, te tegelikult te peate aru saama. Vaata, Juunior on tegelikult ettevõttele kulub see lause, käis läbi eile ka. No argument stare.
Õpetaja: Te olete kulu, see on nii.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ongi, see et ettevõtted on arvestanud selle kuluga ja Nad elavad selle kuluga. Seal oli vahepeal ka debatt. Sellest. Vaata, et kas koolid peaksid rohkem ära tegema. Aa, või ettevõtted. Vahepeal seal need Kood, jõhvi. Inimesed olid nagu umbes niimoodi, et tulge tee meile vastu ja tehke päris palju ise. Ära vaata,
Õpetaja: aga nende sõnum oli nagu See, et tead, me tegelikult juba teeme seda päris palju ära. Me ei saa rohkem teha ja seda ei saa. Vaata ka, et siin oli natukene. See lõpus oli natukene üldisem. Vaata, nagu diskussioon, et ühiskondlik kokkulepe. Ja seal oli Niukene väikene joonis, kus ee ühel pool oli Koolimaht
Õpetaja: siis oli keskel puuduolev osa ja siis oli seal kolmas Aa nagu Tulp oli nagu siis, mida ette võtad
Õpetaja: ja need vahemikud siis Põhimõtteliselt, ee. Ma ei saanudki kohe sellest kohe tol hetkel. Ma ei saanud päris täpselt sellest aru, aga lõpu poole ma hakkasin aru saama. Selle mõte See mõte on see. Vaata, et meil oleks siis nagu Niukene arendaja, kes sobib sinna. Ettevõttesse. Vaata, sest tal on need teadmised ja oskused vaja. Saada kõik, mis on kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ongi see. Vaata, see kool nagu teeb mingisuguse osa ära ja nad ettevõtted teevad mingisuguse osa ära. Siin keskel on siis see probleemne koht. Vaata
Õpetaja: mida keegi nagu ei kata. Vaata, me jõuame sinna ka veel Nii Nüüd ongi nagu küsimus. Vaata, et et nagu ee järsku nagu sealt Aa kooli jõhvi poolt, nagu hakkasid. Nemad nagu hakkasid Push ima. Vaata Seda, et see, et see, see, nagu nende niiöelda osa peaks nagu suurenema
Õpetaja: nagu tulge, nagu teie rohkem meile vastu. Vaata, on ju aga Sealt oli tegelikult näha targad inimesed. See ei olnud lihtsalt see, et nad mingi mõtlevad mingile profitile või midagi. Seal oli niimoodi seda. Vaata, Tegelikult, eraettevõtlus ei suuda seda lihtsalt finantsiliselt ja rahaliselt välja kanda.
Õpetaja: Sest tegelikult nemad peavad ju ka tulu ka teenima. Ärme unusta ära, Vaata, on ju? Nad ei saa seda nagu välja kanda. Siin on teine probleem ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes, et me saame palju rohkem. Ee, Noh, ma ütlen, et ma nüüd ise praegult natukene nagu oma mõttes. Nagu Mis need mõtted? Olid, Sest et see hästi, natukene niisugune kaootiline, Et need teemad ja käsitlused ja igaütt mingi inimesel käsi püsti küsida. Vaata, et seal. Noh, teemad nagu muutusid ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: aga nagu See üldine nagu mõte oli Siis nagu see. Vaata, et et see ei ole ka väga realistlik. Vaata, et me saame niukse ühiskondliku probleeme teha. Vaata, et ettevõtted panustavad rohkem, sest et siin on see mure. Vaata, et on mingid mõned ettevõtted, kes võibolla panustaks rohkem,
Õpetaja: aga tegelikult Need ettevõtted on rämedad. Vaata ja kõik sellest kokkuleppest arvatavasti kinni ei pea, et seda on väga raske teha ja ma arvan, et nagu Nende mõte oli nagu rohkem see, et võibolla ikkagi tegelikult
Õpetaja: see pool. Ehk siis kool saab ikkagi tegelikult kooli ülikoolid seal. Noh, valdavalt olid Seal ülikooli, mingid inimesed ja nii edasi. Kood, jõhvi. Ja, noh, meie ja nii edasi. On ju, et et ka nemad nagu, tegelikult, Ee, Üldiselt seal isegi oli arutus väga tugevalt selle üle. Vaata, et kas kolm aastat Bakal on piisav?
Õpetaja: Kas kolm aastat paka on piisav
Õpetaja: ma kohe vaatama. Jah, no see oli ka arutusel. Vaata, see oli ka arutlusel. Vaata aga, Seal korra oli jutt nagu neli. Vaata siis hakati juba rääkima, Aga kunagi oligi Neli ju. Vaata, mis me siis kolme peale läksime ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et seal oli nagu seda arutlust ka. Vaata, on ju, Aga aga. Nagu selles mõttes, et. Noh, ma ütlen mille peale. Nagu väga palju ei keskendatud oli ka tegelikult. Noh, seda Tegelikult Seda keskendumist tuli ka, et tegelikult see ei ole. Ainult ei ole see maht, mis peab suurenema, vaid, ee, ütleme hoopis ka See sisu ja kvaliteet
Õpetaja: peab muutuma. Koolide mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ma paras aeg seda vaadata. Seda, mis ma kokkuvõtte tegin. Ma Nii palju ma telefonis kirjutasin, ma täna Chat iga nagu veits. Tegin seda, Korrigeerisin
Õpetaja: nii. Vaatame, mis me siis rääkisime. Seal?
Õpetaja: Millised on oodsad juunior arendajale laiem arusaam, kui Ainult programmeerimine
Õpetaja: peavad liikuma rohkem äripoole ja protsesside mõistmise suunas noh.
Õpetaja: Arusaadav, Mõistma, milline on, päriselu töö ja süsteemid oluline on. Äriprotsesside mõistmine siin On mõned punkt Siin on mingid punktid. Ma ei jõudnud kirja panna. Oli veel neid turvalisus. Projektijuhtimine, ärianalüüs. Rohkem saan ma aru
Õpetaja: peaks olema Üldine arusaam arhitektuurist näiteks pilv serverid, Süsteemide ülesehitus. Ilmselt ka suhtlus nende vahel.
Õpetaja: Baasteadmised süsteemi disainist, ja programmeerimise loogikast Nii
Õpetaja: mõtlemis õppimise oskused analüüsi Oskus, kriitiline mõtlemine, oskus. Mõelda ja probleeme lahendada.
Õpetaja: Ee võime tulla toime muutuvas maailmas Võime iseseisvalt õppida ja areneda. No See puudutab natukene nüüd seda. Vaata seda vahemikku ka
Õpetaja: ei saa. Koolis ei saa töölt. Noh, töölt aega veel minna. Võibolla vist on vaja siis ise kuidagi saada hakkama.
Õpetaja: Võime iseseisvalt õppida ja areneda isikuomadused. No need grupid on veits Chat I pannud, aga teemad käisid läbi julgus
Õpetaja: iseseisvus töökus ja pingut Pingutamisvõime.
Õpetaja: Suhtlemisoskused. See oli ka suht teema Siin on üks hea punkt, mis mulle meeldis. Tegelikult
Õpetaja: suhtlemis. Ja Läbirääkimis oskused ka kliendiga suhtlus nii tiimis.
Õpetaja: Kui ka välista inimestega või siis kes ettevõttes ise sisendab kliente. Vaadake seda järgmist oskus kuulata.
Õpetaja: Seda ma ise ka vahele ei oska Oskus Kuulata
Õpetaja: oskus, lahendada ülesandeid, põhjendada oma lahendusi.
Õpetaja: Ai oli ka huvitav. No Aid oli seal hästi palju, aga lihtsalt see punkt oskavad ai tööriistu kasutada.
Õpetaja: See on selge, me oleme seal, See on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ei häbene Ai kasutamist. Kohe toon näite ka.
Õpetaja: Oskavad Ai d teadlikult ja eesmärgipäraselt orkestreerida,
Õpetaja: mäletate? See on minu, see dirigent. Vaata, me läheme selles suunas.
Õpetaja: Ma korra Tulen nüüd selle eelmise punkti Ee juurde. Tagasi Ei, Häbene Ai kasutamist.
Õpetaja: Noor. Tal tegi seal siis. Ee, Noh, päris palju neid suveülikoole asju. Ja. Ja neil on hästi palju neid proovitöid ja Nad andsid mingisugusele suurele satsile nagu proovitööd ja proovitöö andmise käigus. Ütlesid, et Davai võib kasutada.
Õpetaja: Nad ütlesid Ai D võib kasutada
Õpetaja: nad ütlesid Kõikide osalejate seast. Ee, kes siis seal nagu tööd tegid? Põhimõtteliselt, ee. Ei, keegi peaaegu ei olnud seda väga kasutanud minimaalselt ja nad küsisid ka seda iga kord. Vaata, et kas sa kasutasid Ai, D. Siis oli see vastus. Oli Jah, natukene siin seal.
Õpetaja: Jah, noh, üldse tulemustest oli ka näha. Need kasutused tundusid pigem Copy paste Chat Gptse ja tagasi nii.
Õpetaja: Ja nad olid selles mõttes üllatunud sellepärast, et nad tegelikult Ootasid seda, et inimesed just kasutavad seda.
Õpetaja: Nad ei olnud seda võibolla nii. Ee, nagu selgelt. Võibolla väljendanud. Nad ei öelnud seda niimoodi, aga Ma arvan, et
Õpetaja: nad olid selle kindlasti välja käinud. Sest muidu see inimene ei oleks hakanud üldse mainimagi seda. Ja rääkima, aga nad üldse, et Te võite kasutada. Aa, ei. Sa võid kasutada tööriistu ja asju. On juba see, et ei ei või. Noh, ma ei tea, kus See on. Kas ta on kinni mingid ampides, et nad ei julge või tahavad ise või ei oska.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, tea, ee, mis, mis See nagu võis olla, et, ee, seal nad tõlkki jah selle välja. Et Nagu, et ei häbene Ai kasutamist, nagu seda. Peabki, nagu tegema Seda ongi vaja.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis veel on. Nüüd on see punkt. Me arutasime seda, et. Ee, mida, mis? Nagu nende ootused ka enda et Mida Nad tahavad koolidelt rohkemat No ma rääkisin seda, et me arutasime selle pikkuse ülevaate mahu üle, aga nüüd räägime natukene sisu poole pealt ka
Õpetaja: rohkem projektipõhist õpet.
Õpetaja: Rohkem reaalelu töökogemust. Nagu et peegeldust Nagu justkui onju Tiimitöö ja koostöö harjutamine.
Õpetaja: See suhtlus oli rohkem kogu aeg seal Valdavalt muidugi. Kogu selle arutelu vältel oli pigem nagu ülikoolid ja rakenduslikud koolid. Ja need noored ja nii edasi by the way need. Rakendused Lähevad seal üheksandas kaheteistkümnendal ja õpivad mingi eriala selgeks seal venda, kes oli ka kohal ee ülijärsult nagu ütles et
Õpetaja: need nendega ei ole võimalik üldse tööd teha.
Õpetaja: Nagu et kes tulevad ja õpivad. Nad tulevad. Nad õpivad seal kuskil. Noh, keskkoolis põhimõtteliselt põhimõtteliselt üldse. Keskkoolis võib progemise ära kaotada.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga ei ole mitte midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Ma saan sellest täitsa aru. Vaata, ma. Aga Ma arvan, et sinna taha on hoopis peegeldas Ka tegemist on liiga noorte inimestega,
Õpetaja: kes tulevad. Vaata, õpivad ja mõtlevad, et nad oskavad.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult nad ei oska mitte midagi. Ja teine asi on see, et neil ei ole nagu kõiki neid teisi pehmeid oskusi välja arenenud. No ma olen varemgi kuulnud Vendadelt ka. Vaata, miks nad tulevad. Vali It stihtipeale võtma Isegi ülikoolist seda võtta. Seal on tegelikult noored inimesed. Aa Ongi lihtsalt see, et siin on välja kujunenud inimesed, Kes on ju juba suutnud praktiseerida tiimis töötamist, suhtlemist
Õpetaja: koostööd, Kõike seda ee. Sellest, nagu ei rääkinud. Kuna alustavad. Ütleme esimesest klassis koolis, Siis Kõik õpetatakse nagu teistpidi.
Õpetaja: Mingil hetkel. Sa pead nagu ennast.
Õpetaja: Me nagu niimoodi ei arutanud seda. Aga hästi korraks käis üleüldse läbi, nagu ma Nii suured probleemid, mida sa väikses ruumis sa nagu ära ei tapa. Vaata, onju? Seal oli seda üldist arutlust ka. Vaata, et nagu selle nurga alt et Ai on nüüd nagu tegelikult, peaks ka kuidagi haridusse üldse ka kolima. Vaata kasutamist õpetama ja nii edasi, et
Õpetaja: et selle nurga pealt oli. Aga muidu me nagu, mingi esimese klassi juntsusi seal, nagu eriti ei ei puudutanud.
Õpetaja: Ee Selles, vestluses, aga ma panen edasi, Siis me saame veel arutada ka, mida nad veel tahavad, Siis
Õpetaja: aa. Rohkem suhtlemist teiste inimestega
Õpetaja: õpetada Laiemat profiili, see käest korduvalt läbi laiemat profiili väga täpselt. Ei saa aru, mis see nagu tähendab, Aga aa, mitte ainult kitsas tehnoloogiat.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd See oli. Küll Selge, Vot, see on see. Ma loen neid asju. Ma tegelikult näen, et minu meelest meie programmis kõik on pea olemas. Vaata, Me tegeleme nende asjadega, eks? On veel ruumi veel kindlasti paremaks teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, suurem rõhk. Üldistel programmeerimistel põhimõtetel arusaamisel, mitte detailidest. Noh, me läheme ju selle
Õpetaja: ai poole, Vaata, et Ai teeb nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, elutsükli mõistmine õpetada et, projekt ei lõpe valmis saamisega oluline. On ka mis. Juhtub pärast hooldus? Edasiarendus?
Õpetaja: Bla, bla, Bla
Õpetaja: praktilised oskused. See on nüüd kellegi mõte. Vaata aga, ma arvan, et see on nagu päris hea äriplaanide ja projektide tegemine, Noh, enamus See vestlus on nagu ülikooli kontekstis. Natukene rohkem või pikema nad ei ole. See ei olnud suunatud valideele või kood jõhvile. Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: ee, Äriplaanide projektide tegemine. Ee, nüüd see on punkt. Praktiline oskus. Vastutuse võtmine meeskonnas
Õpetaja: vastuse võtma iseenda koodi eest kindlasti
Õpetaja: ee. Oskus ise õppida. Noh See tuleb teist korda läbi. Vaata, noh, see on. See oli see, mida nad ootavad ja mida nad ootavad? Ee, et rohkem õpetatakse, seda Enam ma mõtlen, kui tähtis mul on näidata seda Cloud I
Õpetaja: kui näidata, kuidas, kuidas saab ise uurida ja küsida
Õpetaja: ja teha asju selgeks, Vaata, Te peate. Te peate ise selle vahemiku kuidagi
Õpetaja: ära täitma. Eriti teie sellepärast, et ei ole mingi kolm, kolm aastat ülikoolis, ma ütlen, Ma ülikool. Ma ei arva ülikooli programmides. Tegelikult. Ee, ma arvan, et neil on hästi. Ma olen selle ise läbi teinud, neil on ka Tegelikult hästi palju veel Kasvuruumi ja need teemad käisid läbi Ja veel tulevad ka siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, rohkem analüüsi oskuste oskuse arendamist. Vaata, et mõtlema Niiöelda. No, projekti vaates sa ta tegelikult saab.
Õpetaja: Aa, kriitilise mõtlemise arendamine. Kuidas? Aa, see on kuidagi veits. Vales kohta. Läinud. Kuidas inimene vastab Sisu viis kommunikatsioonistiilis täiendavad ideed. Suvekool, intensiivsed programmid. Ta võttis mu notes neid. Niiöelda. Nüüd on huvitavam punkt, on hoopis see, mida ei ole vaja Õpetada
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes, et meil oli arutelu Seda, et me tahame, nagu. Et programmid lähevad pikemaks. Noh, koolijõhvi kestab kaks aastat ilmselt nad Ei oleks huvitatud kolm aastat tegema, on ju
Õpetaja: ülikoolid? Nendel on ka muidugi selles mõttes, et ega see, et teeme nagu jälle mingi vana Süsteemi hoopis neli aastat, nagu see on nende pädevuses. Nad saaksid seda teha. Nad Tahaksid sellist reformi.
Õpetaja: Kas nad seda väga tahavad? Ma ei tea. Ee, see on mõeldav.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga et kui me ei saa nagu asju pikemaks venitada, siis on võibolla vaja midagi maha võtta.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas keegi ülikoolis on läinud mingit eriala õppima ja siis saanud aru. Vaata, et nagu mingi kolmkümmend protsenti on siis eriala ja Ülejäänud. Staff on nagu mingi muu
Õpetaja: üldained. Ülejäänud on kõrgharidus.
Õpetaja: Jah, see ei tähenda. Vaata, siin on ka nagu, me, no me arutasime ka seda teemat, et sa käis sealt korra läbi. Vaata, noh, tuli ikka see Klassikaline filosoofia ja midagi niukest välja. Vaata, onju, et et tegelikult Ka neid asju võiks õpetada.
Õpetaja: Aga kurat, olgu nad siis praktilised. Nagu minu mõttes. Nagu kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Nagu kuidagi midagi. See sisu kuidagi läheks muutuma, ei ole ka niimoodi, et meil koguaeg see kontekst jookseb. Et kontekst läheb ju kogu aeg suuremaks järjest, et mõtle, minu laps käib täna koolis Ja ma mõtlen, kuidas mina käisin koolis. Ikka loeme mingi mardi leiba. Arutame mingite. Noh, samadel teemadel, samal ajal kolmkümmend aastat on nagu Vahepeal, Noh, elu on ju teil mingi Mega. Hüpe on see. Vaata, et elu läheb niivõrd
Õpetaja: rämedalt kiiresti ja edasi, et nad ei jõua Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee. Ja nad ei jõua sammu hoida samaga Seadusandlusega Jah Kasvab, aga. Aga nüüd ongi. Noh, sellepärast me arutasime ka seda vaata, et Võibolla nagu oleks aeg nagu hakata asju teistmoodi vaatama.
Õpetaja: No, siin ongi siis. Ee, see esimene punkt, mis kohe toodi välja, oli see, et Vot on ee, matemaatika
Õpetaja: ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Seda saaks tegelikult. Noh, me räägime mingi kõrgemast matemaatikast. Ja, noh, ma isegi räägi. Ülikoolid õpetavad seda Ja tegelikult keskkoolid panevad ka minust mingid rütmid ja mingid asjad, nagu tegelikult. Vaata, see on nüüd, kus nad ütlesid, kui see tehisintellekt tegelikult Teeb palju parema töö ära juba.
Õpetaja: Ja kui on vaja, siis. Noh, keegi spetsiifiliselt võiks õppima minna. Kas meil kõigil on vaja seda õpetada? Kas tegelikult ma. Ma ütlen, kui ma. Ma tundsin tohutut hirmu, kui ma olin It. Süsteemide arendus läks õppima. Meil oli kolm ee, matemaatika Ainet
Õpetaja: diskreetne matemaatika Ee, kõrgem matemaatika. Viimane oli mingi bla, bla, bla või mingi analüüs. Ma ei mäleta. Kõrgem matemaatika.
Õpetaja: No olge. Eemal nagu Mingisuguses
Õpetaja: Ma ei olnud põhikooliski mingi eri. Ma olin. Ma olin Niukene vend, kes lihtsalt nagu koolis väga ei käinud, aga ma olin selles mõttes piisavalt, et ma suutsin aru saada, Kus jookseb see piir.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee, Kust ma saan ilusti koolist läbi? Vaata, on ju Ja Kui laisk ma saan nagu olla. Ma teadsin, kus see piia asub. Ma Tundsin seda väga hästi. Ma käin, ma olin smart,
Õpetaja: aga ma Oleks võinud olla tegelikult vabalt mingisugune ka. Ma oleks tegelikult seda, kui ma nagu täna läheks tagasi ja saaksin olla selles noores kehas ja Natuke parema elu mõistusega siis. Ma oleksin tegelikult noh.
Õpetaja: Rohkem, nagu õppinud ja teinud vaata. Onju, aga, ma tegelt olin piisavalt tark et, ma ma Ei, tea, mul klassikaas lõpus isegi imestanud. Ma räägin, kuidas see kooli ära lõpetas. See ei käinudki meil kohe. Ma käisin, siis kui Kontrollitööd oli. Ma tegin ära
Õpetaja: ja matemaatikas. Enne seda ma läksin Aleksandri juurde ja läksin. Koputasin Uksele ta. Ütles mine, ära siit vaata. Et, Sa Ei, tule jälle. Siia. Ma ütlesin, palun, please, lõpeta mind
Õpetaja: olemas. Matemaatika vajalikul ajal Ma võtsin ennast kokku ja õppisin, Aga mul oli Nagu siuke küsimus, et kas. Nagu see kõik see kokku ei ole nagu
Õpetaja: kuidagi kogu see ai asi selles kontekstis tundub nagu endiselt nagu Lühinägelik, et väga paljusid asju Pole, vaja, et on rohkem. Noh, nagu
Õpetaja: umbes. Ei ole vaja seda matemaatikat ja bla blabla, kas me ei ole. Mingi mõne aja pärast ei ole siin, et neid inimesi ei olegi piisavalt. Kes seda Ai D ka arendaks? Tegelikult, sest kui me Teeme kõik. Et Noh, umbes, et hakkame koolist pihta, anname teise klassi vennale selle kätte, et aina, lollimaid otseses mõttes inimesi tegelikult hakkaks tulema Ma ei oska sellele nagu otseselt vastata. Aga ma isiklikult sellesse. Ma pigem usun. Ikkagi see sellesse
Õpetaja: vabatahtlikusse ja huvisse ma keegi ei ole kuskile öelnud. Vaata seda, et. Ee, et üldse mitte. Matemaatikat Näiteks on ju aga nagu liigne
Õpetaja: toores matemaatika, et ütleme niimoodi, nagu mida me Nagu Kui Vaata, siin ongi see mahu küsimus. Vaata, kas kas me teeme nüüd niimoodi, et me õpime nagu arstid? Viis aastat üli bakalaurus Põhimõtteliselt onju õppinud viis aastat üldse bakalaurust.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, no näed, see on nagu, et see mõte oli, nagu, noh, mu mõte on nagu, see. Vaata nagu, et ee. Me peame tegelikult ikkagi õpetama neid asju, mida nad tegelikult tahavad ju. Vaata, praktilised asjad. Projekti, bla, blabla ja Ma kohe arutan veel mõningaid asju, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja Ja kuskilt. Sa pead tõmbama selle nagu midagi. Maha. No
Õpetaja: ma ma räägin, kuidas minul ta Tallinna tehnikaülid. Taltechis. Kuidas oli? Ee, neil on Niukene setup. Kõik loengud on nagu arvutis paika pandud. Millal hakkab? Mis ruumis meil on? Niukene süsteem automaatselt hakkab seal filmima rekordima. Kõik läheb automaatselt pilve kuskile. Keskkonda on keegi Taltex käinud?
Õpetaja: Saab sealt töid videosid vaadata mingi kolmsada, Kuuskümmend Echo. Mida iganes oli, saate vaadata. Kõik oli üli. Ülitimm, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui ma läksin sinna ülikooli kõrge matemaatika Kristiina
Õpetaja: Aa naisterahvas Ee, Tol, Hetkel ma pakun mingi nelikümmend viis vahemikus pluss midagi Ülesse Kõrge matemaatika kolm kolm ainet, kaks nendest, tema omad, kõrgem matemaatika, statistiline analüüs ja Mida iganes see oli nagu ka
Õpetaja: kõikides ainetes, oli autorekord ja sa said asju järgi vaadata. Aa live s vaadata, ja mida iganes, vaata
Õpetaja: Ee, Kristiina ütles, et tema nagu ei rekordimist, ei tee üldse mingit online. I
Õpetaja: move your asseeria. Tule tee või thats it, vaata onju Ma olen niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Esimese päeva mõistsin selle vaata. Et, ma hakkan nüüd õppima vaata. Kuidas, Ma, ei suuda neid logaritme ja asju nagu never Nagu ma. Ma ei suuda midagi kaasa
Õpetaja: haarata selles tunnist. Niimoodi Ma ei ole võimel. Ma võin käia siin kohal andes parima. Vaata, aga Ma ei suuda õppida, et nagu ainukene aine. Nagu mis üldse siin nagu vajab Võimalust järgi vaadata pausile panemist, mõtlemist, uurimist. Asja Ütlete, et Nüüd siin,
Õpetaja: siin. Ei, te siin ei rekordi. Sellepärast, et äkki muidu te ei tule mu klassiruumi Klassiruumi tuleb. Me ei ole põhikool. Minu mõte oli. No ma üritasin ka moosimise ja kõigega. Minu isik Arvamus on see, et Camera Ads Five.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tahtnud lihtsalt telekas olla, Mulle ta väga meeldis. Mul flirtsin temaga ka. Mul niuke milfilik värk läheb peale.
Õpetaja: Ee, jälle
Õpetaja: ma sain läbi, aga ma siin rekordi peal Ma ei taha üldse midagi kommenteerida. Kohvi nurgas, ma arvan.
Õpetaja: Ee, Aga tulles tagasi selle point I juurde, ja et tegelikult tõmmake nagu neid asju sealt maha. Nagu Aa toores matemaatika. Ai, ja kõik need on matemaatikal baseeruvad. Ee, kas siin on oht, et Vaata, meil ühel hetkel Polegi nagu kedagi, kes neid asju asju oskavad arendada. Ja mudel.
Õpetaja: Ma ei usu, sest on. Alati on inimesed, keda see asi lihtsalt huvitab, Ja kes näeb sellest võimalust ja õpib ja teeb. Mina nagu näen, et iga asjaga peaks olema niimoodi, et anname mingisugune kõigile, et maitse, Saad suhu edasi. Liigu ise.
Õpetaja: Kas sulle meeldib see asi? Päeva lõpuks, mis ma rääkisin ka. No millesse ma usun, kirg,
Õpetaja: kui sul on asja vastu. Armastus
Õpetaja: küll tuleb sinna taha ka töökus ja energia. Ja sellega tulevad tulemused. Mida sa surud mind seda kõrget matemaatikat õppima või Kedagi teist,
Õpetaja: kes seda tegelikult lihtsalt ei taha ja ei oska. Ja. Ja vaatan. Ja nüüd need ettevõtted ise ütlevad ka meil ei ole sellega midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Nagu see, kes see tavaliselt süsteemi arendused Ei, vot siin on see, va see vana niiöelda müüt. Vaata, et ee programmeerimine on matemaatika.
Õpetaja: Me ei näe. Me ei te siin ühtegi teed. See vaimuke tee, mis me tegime, oli Balance miinus nagu mingi.
Õpetaja: Me ei Tee siin tegelikult mingisuguseid rehkendusi sellisel kõrgemal matemaatil kujul. See ei tähenda, et need ei ole kuidagi tähtsad ained ja asjad jah, aga jah Ma Ka nagu ei usu sellesse. Vaata, et seda peaks õpetama. Sest et meil on piiratud aeg ja Maht ja ressursse kontekst mõtleme, Aa, Ei,
Õpetaja: keegi tegi seal vahepeal nalja ka. Et ütles mingi asja Mingisuguse sõnumi kellegi teisele ja teine tüüp ei saanud aru, siis tegi nalja Nagu et tundub, et see promp läks kaduma. Vaata, on ju konteksti. Asjad on ju
Õpetaja: nüüd, mida ei peaks tegema. Paljude keelte ja raamestiku Pindmine tundmine. Ee, kurat. Ma palusin seda ära parandada.
Õpetaja: See ei ole see. Ta tõlgendas valesti. Minu märkmeid ma korra nüüd võtan Ee, allapoole,
Õpetaja: Kus me olime? Siin Kuskil olime, onju, Mida, mida ei ole vaja õppida,
Õpetaja: Õpetada liiga paljusid programmi programmeerimiskeeldi korraga. See oli tegelikult sõnum.
Õpetaja: Ma Olen ise ülikoolis käinud. Alustame püütonist. Lähme jaavaga. Oh, nüüd lähme mobiili maailma. Mis seal kõik ees ootab.
Õpetaja: Ee, see ei ole hea, sellepärast, et sa õpid igat ühte Natukene,
Õpetaja: aga sõnum oli läbivalt. Selline tuleks õpetada üldist programmeerimist nagu printsiipe.
Õpetaja: Õpeta seda ühte keelt Vahet pole, milline Neist
Õpetaja: vahet pole, On see püüton. On see. Jaava on see.
Õpetaja: See on see. Olete kuulnud sellest töötlemist?
Õpetaja: Kõikide asjade Ee proff, Tegelikult ei Ole proff. Mitte üheski nendes asjades, milles ta on.
Õpetaja: Master of Old Race meister. Kõikide kõikide nende Aa,
Õpetaja: nagu tööoskus, töö või amet, kõikide Ametite oskaja. Mitte ühek spetsialist,
Õpetaja: Nagu see natukene. Sellega ma nõustun. Aa, seda ei ole vaja. See tegelikult rikub kõike Minu meelest ta põhimõtteliselt See Rain. Ee, Raino. Kolik ütles kohe. Ära Vaata, et ee. Isegi ei oleks mõtet seda. Vaata, et õpetame mõlemad. Oopia, funktsionaalne programmeerimine.
Õpetaja: Võtke Lihtsalt üks nendest. Üks keel, üks kontseptsioon. Õpetage, õpetage see selgeks. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: ja ülejäänud asjad. Vahet pole lihtsalt mingit vahet pole. Vaata, kui sa Oskad ühte? Sa oskad teie kõiki teisi ka. Hea küsimus,
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: kõik need punktid üldiselt ju kõnetavadki. Kogu seda tööturgu Vahet ei ole. Juuksur. Võib raamatutega tegelikult punktida. Päeva lõpus loob. Loeb look.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, ainult see oskus oli ju?
Õpetaja: No jaa, ei ole tegelikult. Vaata, kui me scroll Ime oskustööst ülesse. Vaatame uuesti. Vaata, tegelikult siin on nagu need
Õpetaja: mõtlemise Analüüsi oskus kriitiline mõtlemine probleemide lahendamise oskus. Need tegelikult ei ole. Vaata, Need on nagu tegelikult niuksed. Üldised. Ee, üldised asjad. Vaata, onju, need ei ole siin. Ei soovi keegi. Vaata, ütleme juuksuri poolt. Tõesti, eelkõige Tahaks saada mingit Nice. Vaata, on ju. Aga kas ma tahangi mingi niukse inimese juurde minna, kes nagu suhtleb nagu mölakas, on kuidagi üleolevalt Või
Õpetaja: või oskame kuulata. Näe, kuulamine.
Õpetaja: Ma Ma üritan sulle öelda. Vaata midagi. Ta võib, olla kui ta. Kui ta. Tal on õige vi Tal on endal peas mingi visioon, kui ta siukseid lõigata. Aga see on vale,
Õpetaja: sest ta võib lõigata selle visiooni korrektselt, aga seda ma ei tahtnud. Vaata onju? See on see kiige värk ka. Veits on ju, eksole?
Õpetaja: Sama asi eest, et nad saavad selle algfaasi teada ja Siis, kui nad lähevad nüüd sinna sektorisse, on see tööstus. Või on see
Õpetaja: ekaubandus? Siis nad spetsialiseeruvad Tegelikult seda vahendit.
Õpetaja: Kõige olulisem see ka, et ta saab aru, kuidas peab tegema või teeb nõutud teha.
Õpetaja: Kas meil on võimalik reguleerida? Nii et kui me näiteks õpime, selgelt saavad
Õpetaja: Ja näiteks rohkem. Ja mul on vaja mingit, ee. Püüt, onju asja teha, Kuigi ma ei ole püütand õppinud
Õpetaja: ja ma tõin selle pronkiga Ja ta töötab. Kas see nagu on aktsepteeritav? Nagu tänapäeval? No, seal oli seal oligi. See on eraldi arutlus. Vaata, et noh, vaata, me. Me See oli kõige üks tulisemaid teemasid. Ee, milles ma ise ka sekkusin.
Õpetaja: Ee, et, ee. Kas Sellepärast, et vahepealt. Noh, see, siim vene oli kandja nagu see, et ei pea teadma. Mida Program, mida, mida,
Õpetaja: Mida see ai sulle kirjutas? Vaata, kui ta töötab ja ta vastab kõikidele nõuetele kriteeriumitele. Noh, siis kas ma pean teadma? Vaata See oli tema nagu mõte, vaata onju? Noh, paneel sellega nii mõistnud ei innustunud Onju? Mina ise ka mitte, Vaata, onju,
Õpetaja: et, ee. Kui sinu sõna sinu hüpotees on, nagu sa oskad. Vaata, on ju? Ee. Promptiga läheb sul mingisugune püüton või mis iganes muu. Vaata keel, mida sa nagu ei mõista, on ju, et kui see nüüd töötab ja toimib, vaata, Et siis, kas see on nagu aktsepteeritav, on ju? See on natuke see sama küsimus, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Tegelikult see see vastus niimoodi ee, seda väga, nagu ei tulnud sealt. Aga see pigem paneeli pealt oli, niimoodi, et täna veel peab koodi tundma ja sa vastutad selle koodi eest. Vaata, nad tegelikult ikkagi tahavad neid, kes oskavad frontida ja asjadega kõike toimetada ja teha ehitada.
Õpetaja: Aga Nad saaksid ikkagi aru ka. Vaata, Et Mida see kood teeb? No tegelikult praegu. Täna seda veel ei vaja. Vaata, onju, et.
Õpetaja: Noh, see oli see sama jutt. Vaata, nagu, et kuskil kaugelt tulevikus. See ilmselt on niimoodi. Ee, et ee. Pigem on see. Vaata, on nagu justkui see kuidagi äripooli inimene või organisatsioon Vaata, nad teavad täpselt, mida nad tahavad. Senikaua, kuni nad oskavad põhimõtteliselt sellele spekina kirja panna, et mida neil on vaja, kuidas see töötab, onju?
Õpetaja: No muidugi, see ei ole selline. Süsteemid ei ole kunagi nii üks rakendus. Süsteemid on süsteemid. See tegelt on nagu selles mõttes keeruline, et kindlasti kunagi saabub see päev ka. Vaata, kus siis Tegelikult põhimõtteliselt. Ee, keegi lihtsalt ütleb, mul on midagi vaja, annab kirjelduse, ta teeb selle sulle ära ja keegi sisse vaatama Ei peagi,
Õpetaja: aga me ei ole veel täna kindlasti kindlasti ei ole veel täna seal
Õpetaja: ja. Ja See ei ole kindlasti see, mida nad ootavad, et se seda nad ei vaja. Nagu Nad tunnistasid tõesti seda. Vaata, et see on nagu Selles mõttes nagu keerulisemaks läinud. Vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et, ee, et ee, et. Noh, millised? Nagu töölõike. Vaata nagu siis nagu nendele juunioritele. Nagu anda. Vaata aga, see sõnum oli ikkagi. Noh, Rain Raino kolk oli. Ütles küll. Et endiselt on kohti, kus tegelikult sul on vaja juuniorit Ja päeva lõpuks nad niikuinii. Nad saavad sellest nokini saba lahti ja olukorras ka aru, et et kui sa ei ei too neid juunioreid juurde ja ei koolita neid. Siis sul pole ka varsti enam neid seenioreid. Et see
Õpetaja: See süsteem kukub ju kokku ju Varsti vaata on ju, et.
Õpetaja: Et see on nagu. See on hästi, nagu keeruline, Aga nagu mida, Nagu mis, Mis mina sain, mis? Mina sellelt kohtumiselt siiski Sain, on see. Ee. Kahjuks seda aega pikemaks ei saa teha. Vaata, on ju? No nad rääkisid sellest ja et ülikooli õpilased peaksid seal Mingi meil peaaegu neli aastat käima koolis. Vaata või mida iganes vaata rohkem õpetada,
Õpetaja: Aga ma tegelikult sain ikkagi enda mõttes validatsiooni, et me Oleme õigel teel. Mida me. Siin teeme? Me teeme projekti
Õpetaja: projektipõhine. Õpe. Me simuleerime päris tarkvaraarendust Me teeme tiimitööd, me suhtleme, meil on suhtlus kõvasti sees. Ma õpetan teile, kuidas. Ai ga midagi orkestreerida ja midagi teha. Ma õpetan, kuidas õppida juurde
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes, et meil on Need komponendid siin selles programmis. Tegelikult on olemas, mida nad otsivad.
Õpetaja: Mul veits oli isegi nagu see küsimus, et. Kurat, No ma ei saa niimoodi kõva häälega öelda. Aga et kurat, nagu miks te. Nagu viimasel. Miks te teete nüüd mingid oma mingit ülikooli asju? Miks te lihtsalt ei võta. Nagu rohkem siit.
Õpetaja: Siis ta ei võta rohkem nagu siit. Mul Üks inimene ütles. Vaata, ta tegelikult, Ee, hoiab. Silma vennad, vaata Mis teemad? Ma istusin nendega ära. Mis teemadel on? Vaata, et. Ee. Ma tean mul külas. Käin neil kunagi.
Õpetaja: Ta ei pea. Ütleme kaasa võtma paar praktikanti. Aga meil on natuke keeruline, kui nad tihtipeale need tööd teevad. Seal on öeldud, et peab ei saa olla nagu juunior, vaid. Noh, mingi seenior. Mida iganes, Vaata
Õpetaja: Aga nad võtavad iga aasta paar tükki. Aga ma ütles, et. Aga vaata kuskilt ülikoolist, Miks te Valite asja. Vaata, ma ei teagi nagu, et ei ole nagu mõelda, et tegelikult üks inimene on ju? Ta on väga hea. No kas Sa valid ennast tunda, et kuidagi nagu meelest ära läinud, Onju
Õpetaja: Oleks tahtnud teha promo, aga ma ei julgenud teha. Sellepärast koodi. Õhi oli ka seal ja mingid muud.
Õpetaja: Lähme teeme pausi. Ee, ma arvan. Me saime mingisugust mõtteid. Kuidas te soovite? Ma võin selle Pdf Ina
Õpetaja: Paneme Sinna teeme viisteist minuti pausi ja siis teeme fronti. Me kuidagi on jälle läinud.
Õpetaja: Aeg Me teeme. Pole vaja. Me me hakkame varsti tegema Päris nagu, jaava asju. Vaata, Step by Step
Õpetaja: siin eile arvuti kaasa.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, rääkisime. Vaata, see on nagu selles mõttes suures pildis on Fine, aga tõesti. Võibolla. Siis mõelge lihtsalt, kui siltidest, onju? Sildid ja objektid, objektid ja sildid.
Õpetaja: Aa, sest sealt hästi natuke võis jääda ka mulje. Vaata, et me räägime objekti, et sildi taga on mingisugune objekt. Mis on mälus? Vaata, seal ongi just see punkt.
Õpetaja: See mälu sisu võib muutuda objekti Sisu. Võib muutuda ja nii edasi, on ju? Aga mul on nagu tähtis, et saate nüüd sellest Ifelsest natukene, ee, lisaks sellele süntaksile aru. Kui on sulgude sisu tõene, Ta tuleb siia. Koodiblokki on nii.
Õpetaja: Kui siin oleks mingi muuttoid defineeritud selle koodibloki sees, siis Tema elutsükkel on
Õpetaja: selle koodiploki sees, onju? See on see väike asi, mis me ennem arutasime. Nüüd, If else puhul. No vaatame korra seda,
Õpetaja: Kui midagi on ee, tõene, tullakse siia koodiploki ja ülejäänud kood käivitub ka. Mis on nüüd selles mõttes selles mõttes erinev, et meil on mõlemad olukorrad ära, et peab juhtuma midagi. Kui on true, aga peab juhtuma midagi. Kui on False
Õpetaja: ja ülejäänud asjad peavad käit, noh, käivituvad Siis, noh, lihtsalt edasi käivitudes ka
Õpetaja: on lihtsalt see, et meil on mitu tingimust.
Õpetaja: Kui on mingisugune, võrdub viiega, tee seda, kui on neli, siis nii. Ja nii. Ja lõpus on nagu põhimõtteliselt vaikimisi. Aa, et kui ükski nendest olukordadest ei realiseeru, kui on keerulised tingimused, siis see annab ka teile selle. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et ee. Seda viimast tingimust. Siin saab ka olla ju Else If. Vaata, negatiivne hinne siis võiks olla et On väiksem, kui null saab, saaks teha, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga see on nagu annab teile võimaluse ka, et te ei pea kolme asja kontrollima, Okei, Siin on nelja. Vaata, üks, kaks, kolm. Ja see on kaine. Neljas
Õpetaja: Delse onju, siis? Everything Else Siin On hästi natuke. Abstraktsiooni
Õpetaja: ee. Ma, Mõtlen seda. Vaata, kui sa koodi loed. Vaata Onju niimoodi, et kui on. Teil on tegelikult võibolla viis tingimust. Viimane tingimus on see, et Kas number on negatiivne? On nii? Selle näite puhul.
Õpetaja: Kas number on negatiivne siin? Kuidas
Õpetaja: negatiivne hinna on väiksem kui kolm, siis jah. Aa, Okei, siin on kaks. Ja see vaata onju siia X sisse saaks siis panna see, et kui on kaks või on üks, kind, onju saaks panna või alla. Kolme. Noh, lihtsamalt on ju,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, aga selles mõttes, et see tegelikult on idee järgi siin siis põhimõtteliselt neljas tingimus. Aga lihtsalt Else. Ta katab selle, ära, kuna eelmised välistavad. Selle
Õpetaja: Noh, ei saagi olla ju midagi muud enam, kui kui ta ei saanud viite. Ta ei saanud nelja. Ta ei saanud kolme. Järelikult Ta sai siis kahe või ühe Ja meie ütleme, et see on negatiivne Hinne on ju nii
Õpetaja: et ee, niimoodi. Hea tava on. Sellest ei pea tingimata kinni hoidma. On see, et kui kasutad Aa If else If I, Siis üks nendest on lõpus. On Else,
Õpetaja: Aga vahel on ka niimoodi. Et on If Else, If, else, If ja kõik seda Else blokki ei tule.
Õpetaja: Parem on kui ta. Kui seal on mingisugune niukene asi. Sellepärast, et teil peab olema siis see kood sada protsenti läbi mõeldud, saate aru? Vaata, kui midagi ikkagi peab toimuma.
Õpetaja: Ütleme, et siin on selle asemel, et siin on praegult Ee. Mitu If I on. Vaata, üks, kaks, kolm.
Õpetaja: Ja kõik on ju kolm. If I ee. Kui tegelikult. Aa, Me teeksime niimoodi, et me vaataksime nelja If, I Ja me mõtleme, et me oleme kõikvõimalikud sisendi mõttes. Vaata, et mis see väärtus seal on, Oleme ära katnud.
Õpetaja: Siis see võib nii olla. Ja meil seda idee järgi justkui ei oleks vaja. Aga mis siis? Aga mis? Siis, kui sa tegelikult ikkagi tegid oma loogikast nagu Mingi mõtlemises vea
Õpetaja: on mingisugune sisem, mis ei ei vasta Ühele Ghifile.
Õpetaja: Mis siis saab? Vot selle jaoks ongi, Else. Noh, siis ta läheb sinna koodi blokki. Loodame, et lihtsalt see vähemalt käitub seal siis nii nagu vajab.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd üks asi, mis ma ainuke asi, mis ma Annan selle presentatsiooni juurde visa visata. Miks me neid üldse kasutame? Aa, süntaksimõtts on Jah, see truu Ja läheb sisse ja nii edasi, on Ju
Õpetaja: see on meie põhielement millega me saame enda süsteemis protsesse juhtida.
Õpetaja: Mine vasakule või mine paremale.
Õpetaja: Või siis mine vasakule. Otse või mine Paremale, Jah, Mine nagu Sinna, sinna, sinna, sinna. See on number üks komponent number üks. Niiöelda asi, Ee. Ja millega me programmi juhime,
Õpetaja: Me Kasutame siin igast aa
Õpetaja: toredaid asju. Aa, mis? Mida me hakkame jaavas arendama Meil on hästi paljud asjad, mis kuskil Karukohus niiöelda Springpuud teeb meie eest ära. Me ei näe, nagu me näeme oma are tavapärases arenduses. Seal ei näegi nii nii palju neid If E kohe. Võibolla On ju? Aga vahel ongi. Ma Küsin, nagu mängima. Kirjutame mingeid koodi. Ma küsin teie käest, mis me siin teeme. Vaata ja see on Ifo olukord,
Õpetaja: et et siin, Me peame vaatama midagi Me peame otsustama
Õpetaja: ja siis me peame vastavalt sellele minema Natukene ühte või teist teed pidi. Mõlemad pooled tuleb ära programmeerida. On ju? Aga et see on nüüd siis see programmeerimise peamine. Tööriist
Õpetaja: otsused Protsess peab kuidagi liikuma, et See on meie number üks tööriist. Yes,
Õpetaja: Noh, see valgusfooria. Kõik asjad. See kõnetab mind. See oli, ee, päris hea analoogia.
Õpetaja: Aa, loogilised operaatorid Siin ma lisaksin ühe asja.
Õpetaja: Ee, tõeväärtustabel. Mulle meeldib, et see on see kuidagi tekkinud. Ee, Täpselt, see on nüüd Aa, diskreetne matemaatika ainukene Matemaatika aine, mis mul seal ülikoolis nendest kolmest meeldis. Mulle meeldis õppejõud. Ka. Ta tegi seda kuidagi nagu hästi, mõnusalt nagu
Õpetaja: see nüüd änd Ja need hoor ja niuksed asjad need samasugused. Ee, niuksed asjad. Nende kutsutakse loogiline värav
Õpetaja: Keit tähendab seda täpselt samamoodi, et tegelikult on kaks suunda. Vaata, otsusta ära. Kummale poole
Õpetaja: need samasugused? Ee, Asjad on? Protsessoris sees.
Õpetaja: Kui üks on. Kui seal on and Gate, siis tähendab seda, et Ta annab seda voolu või seda signaali edasi. Ainult siis, kui mõlemad pooled tuleb särts sisse. Ütleme niimoodi. Näiteks
Õpetaja: see on änd. Kuidas Änd töötab. Vahet pole, mõlemad pooled peavad olema truu. See on ainus. Vaadake, ta on ainus. Ainus olukord. Andil on see
Õpetaja: Noh, truu. Kõikidel Teistel kordadel on,
Õpetaja: kui on vasakul false või true Vahet pole, kui
Õpetaja: kui üks kahest poolest on Care see on. See on tähtis ka Vaata, False Force. Vaata,
Õpetaja: miinus miinus teeb kokku. Pluss ei, miinus märk. Sulu ees muudab.
Õpetaja: Okei, ikka teistes koolides ka nii, eksole, Ee, et tähele panna. Põhimõtteliselt vahet pole, and iga on see, et mõlemad pooled. Ja tegelikult juba mõelge mõttes kõik pooled. Sellepärast, mida me siin õpime, Vaatame, õpime
Õpetaja: on siis nagu selles mõttes. Ee, on niimoodi. Et, ee, vahet pole. Kumb Poolest on true? Siis on true Ainult siis, kui Mõlemad pooled on Falls
Õpetaja: Siis on ta False, on nii?
Õpetaja: See diskreetse matemaatika sellega võibki enamvähem lõpetada. Okei, inversioon ka järgmine, see on ka veel vajalik. Vot
Õpetaja: see on väga tähtis asi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja et on olemas selline asi nagu not või pöörab va inversioon. Keerame lihtsalt väärtuse tagurpidi,
Õpetaja: Kui mina teeksin niukse meetodi. Aa, Aa, mis on? Vaata võtab sisse vanuse numbri ja meetod on
Õpetaja: siis mida ta peaks idee järgi Justkui mulle tagastama. True False.
Õpetaja: Ei, ei, praegult. Küsi lihtsalt niimoodi. Kui mul on meetod
Õpetaja: Kuidas Kuidas see asi peaks töötama? Mida see meetod peaks, tegema kui me teame ainult meetode nime. Sisend on number.
Õpetaja: Jah, ta annab meile Ainult oletame, et mul on. Mul on Niukene protsess, Kus Mul ei ole. Ma nüüd korra lähen sinna If. Ide juurde. Läheme tagasi
Õpetaja: Oletame, et meil on täpselt selline olukord, nagu siin on,
Õpetaja: Kui mingisugune asi realiseerub, siis tee midagi
Õpetaja: meil. Mis olukord meil ei ole Hetkel ei ole see olukord, et kui mingi asi on tõene, Siis tee ühte asja, kui mitte tee teist asja. See on nüüd hästi tähtis aru saada. Meil on selline olukord.
Õpetaja: Oletame, et Aa,
Õpetaja: mul on Niimoodi Vaata, see on kasiino kasiino sisse logimine ja seal küsib su vanust, kui vana sa oled
Õpetaja: ja kasutaja paneb numbri lihtsalt sisse. Vaata, Mina olen kaheksateist või ta Lo logib sisse. Ee, ja siis sealt sealt. Ee, sellest Id kaardi andmetest saab kätte. Vanuse. Vaata, vahet pole, onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, oletame niimoodi, et. Aa, noh, okei, kurat, see on halb.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast ma tahan. Ee, ma teen mingi teise näite sellepärast, et Siin on kaine käsi, et ära luba. Vaata, ma ei taha Ifelset.
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha seda, et kui on üks asi, siis ühtepidi teistpidi. Vaata, ma tahan ainult niimoodi. Meil on kliendid.
Õpetaja: Meil on kliendid. Meil on sünnikuupäevad. On ee, süsteemis olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, meil on niuke protsess, mis meil automaatselt iga päev käivitub Ja aa, vaatab kõik kliendid üle.
Õpetaja: Kõik kliendid vaatab üle ja siis, ee, kellel on ee, Sünni sünnikuupäev on, Tänane kuupäev Nagu mitu aasta. Vaata vaid lihtsalt See kuupäev ise on ju Siis me saadame neile süsteemist sünnipäeva pakkumisega meili
Õpetaja: miinus viis protsenti Nagu eestis kombeks on?
Õpetaja: Aa, Jess, sünnipäev. Saad soodsamalt. Siis on ju selline asi. Vaata, et me käime ju. Kõik need kuupäevad läbi, on ju, kui me käiksime niimoodi programmiliselt ee läbi seda mõistlikum teha siis, on iga iga Sünnikauba juures on otsustuskoht vaata. Et, Kas, is it Is Birthday. Nagu Ütleme, nii on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja seal selles mõttes on ju ainult selline käitumine, et meil seda elsat ei ole, et kui Sul Ei ole sünnipäeva. Siis tegevust ei järgne.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on täna sünnipäev, siis saadame sulle meili. On see arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd meetodid peaksid Alati võimalusel, Eriti kui nad on niuksed. Mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, meetodid peaksid alati esiteks olema nimetatud Aa jaotavalt või positiivselt,
Õpetaja: mitte kunagi eitavalt vältida, Nagu seda niiöelda.
Õpetaja: No ütleme nüüd teise olukorra välja, Kus ma pean samamoodi vaatama? Näiteks mingit kuupäeva.
Õpetaja: Ja oota, ma mõtlen ka. Tegelikult Aa,
Õpetaja: Kas sul mingil korral on plaanid? Tehtud
Õpetaja: Konkreet. Kas mingi kuupäeval on plaanid tehtud?
Õpetaja: Kas sul on mingil kuupäeval plaanid tehtud? Aga see on Jälle jaatav. Ma tahan vastupidist olukorda Vaata, et need kuupäevad ei kattu. Vaata, ma mõtlen, ma ikkagi. Ma proovin, Ma proovin midagi teistmoodi, proovin teistmoodi. Ee, meetod on
Õpetaja: ja inimese. Viskad sinna lihtsalt sisse. Vaata on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja meil on mingi siukene olukord, Kus, Ee, me tahame ainult seda kontrollida. Me. Sa tahame saada inimesele ainult teavitust. Et Ee, et sa pole endiselt siit meie süsteemi pannud. Näiteks
Õpetaja: on mingi süsteem ja Seal on nõue. Vaata, et. Noh. Sul peab olema said teha mingi konto ära teha mingis, et hilisemas etapis saad lisada seda, on ju See on
Õpetaja: niiöelda meie süsteemist. Aa, aga inimene on seda jätkuvalt teinud. Meie süsteem Võibolla siis vaatab uusi kontosid ja vaatab kõik, mis on Mingi ee, vanemad kui nädal aega. Vaata, kellel ei ole. Nagu siis hoopis neil Saadame notification I vaata, et ta pole jätkuvalt nagu sisestanud meie süsteemi. Vaata oma mingi andmeid.
Õpetaja: Siis Nüüd on ju tegelikult. Ee. Kui me vaatame nüüd aa kõiki neid kliente, kes meil on andmebaasis, On ju? Siis meid ei huvita need inimesed, kellel on vaid meid. Huvitav Huvitab taas. Not
Õpetaja: vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: siis, aa, nüüd me oma Programmis ei soovi, et meil on tegelikult kaks korda implementeeritud ära. Põhimõtteliselt sama loogika. Ainult tagurpidi.
Õpetaja: Me ei soovi et meie süsteemis on Niukene Meetod has, driving license ja on meetod.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ee, me ütleme niimoodi. Oletame, et meil on mõlemat vaja. Varem või hiljem aga erinevas kontekstis erinevat pidi
Õpetaja: või Kasvõi läheb ühte vaja. Vahet pole eitavat meetodit. Me ei tee nüüd see inversioon.
Õpetaja: See tagurpidi. Nii, Kate, vaata see Tuleb nüüd tagasi siia.
Õpetaja: See nüüd on meie tööriist, Kus ta nüüd oli. Siin
Õpetaja: See nüüd on meie võimalus. Vaata, et me käivitame meetodi. Vaata Mingi andmetega. Vaata, me paneme sinna hüüumärgi ette.
Õpetaja: Mis tema nüüd teebing? License vaatab, et kas sul on? Ta ütleb, et ei ole Ei, nüüd kui
Õpetaja: paned selle tagurpidi nii, siis ta muutub truuks.
Õpetaja: See See väärtus tal ei ole. Aga meie If peab käivituma true puhul, et. Aga nüüd saada notification.
Õpetaja: If Lause tahab seda, et et palun käivita mingi protsess.
Õpetaja: Tal ei ole, aga inflauses Ei, peale ei käivitu Protsess ju
Õpetaja: me ei saa teha. Vaata, mida me ei saa teha on see. Ma tulen jälle selle If I juurde. Meil ei ole Niukest. Ee, võimekust.
Õpetaja: See sama if lause Vaata, mis on ainult üksinda. Meil ei ole niukest asja. Koodis tööriista, et kus saad öelda, et If not.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru. Protsess käivitub ainult siis, kui on truu.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja rehkendada välja. Ära vaata, kas on see olukord. Meil On vaja truud siia sisse saada Aga meil on olemas meetod, mis tegelikult tagastab eitava.
Õpetaja: Ja siis sa lihtsalt paned selle hüüumärgi sinna ette, mis ta teeb? Ta keerab selle tõe väärtuse. Lihtsalt tagurpidi truuks
Õpetaja: meetodi ette.
Õpetaja: Seda siin ei kaetud siis. Jah. Vaatame.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin samas on Vaata, õpilane on. True on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee, siin on see, et vaata, et kas mõlemad pooled. See on I õpetamine. On See muidugi Praegult, onju? See pool on tõene. See pool on tõeline. Siis ta läheb sisse, onju? Siin on? Ei, vaata, korraks. Näed, siin on see, et kui ei ole õpilane, näed, sest, et tema väärtus tegelikult taustal on truu. Paned hüüumärgi ette, põmm.
Õpetaja: Ta keerab selle tagurpidi. See sisu, Vaata, see osa siin.
Õpetaja: See väikene osa rehkendub truuks,
Õpetaja: aga see keerab ta taga. See See ei tööta kusjuures. Paideway.
Õpetaja: Ei, ikka on ikka Hea ta on. Ei, see ei tööta. Ei ole õpilane. Siin ei tööta ju
Õpetaja: või töötab? Vaata, mul oleks endal ka juba juhe sassi, Sest et õpilane on truu. Ta tuleks muidu siia sisse, kui seda hüüumärki pole. Kas selle koodinäite tegi?
Õpetaja: Kui sa võtsid selle, ta ei Tule siis siia, sisse,
Õpetaja: Okei, Tähendab, õpilane on ju? Meil on õpilane. Vaata ja kõik on õige. Jah,
Õpetaja: ta tuleb siia sisse ainult siis, Kui ei ole õpilane,
Õpetaja: ei ole. Vaata, korra. Jah, Vaata, me. Me peame mõtlema seda. Vaata nüüd, Me peame mängima seda, et see on Siin, Vaata, vaadake. Kui see on Falls, siis kui seda ühumärki pooleks, siis ta siia sisse ei tule, on nii
Õpetaja: nii, Aga kui ta Nüüd on False ja meil on see You märk ees. Niiöelda Siis ta ju muutub truuks ja tuleb sisse ja öeldakse, et ei ole Õpilane, Jah, selles mõttes näide on õige. Aga me lihtsalt siia siin näites. Ta ei tule siia sisse lihtsalt
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et see on truu, Aga kui, noh, me. See mõte ongi see. Vaata, et me programmis kunagi ei ole nagu need väärtused, nagu sisse kirjutatud, nii nagu siin Praegult on. See on lihtsalt õppekood. On ju,
Õpetaja: et see õpi on õpilane. Võib olla mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Siin see sama, See hashdriving Lices,
Õpetaja: siin Ongi siin see. Vaata, et me tahame saata sõnumit. Vaata, et Aa on muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kui see on truu, siis siia sisse ei tulda, Ju Skip Ib selle. Ja et, noh, vaja mõelda, on see. Vaata, et meil on olukordi, kus me meil on olemas mingi tõe väärtus, Vaata Ja meil on vaja vastupid teda keerata ta vastupidiseks selle hüüumärgiga.
Õpetaja: No see siis see. Oota, me Kujutame nüüd jälle. Vaata ette, Vaata et See on False.
Õpetaja: Ei ole õpilane.
Õpetaja: Kui sa tahad mitte õpilasele saata sõnumit, siis praegult sa seda niimoodi saadki, Sest et on õpilane, vaadatakse Süsteemist ei ole õpilane. See on False ja meil on ainult vaja saata siis sõnumit. Kui ta ei ole õpilane,
Õpetaja: siis ongi niimoodi vaja teha.
Õpetaja: See võib natuke segane olla. Harjuta selle mõttega. Tähtis on nagu saada sellest aru, mis ma tegelikult siin ändidest teooridest tegelikult tahtsin rääkida Selle slaidi puhul, mida ei ole siin, on väga mugavalt. On praegult Aa, ainult kaks osapoolt ja siis on seda mõtteharjutust hästi lihtne vaadata Ja mõelda
Õpetaja: nagu selles mõttes. Vaata, et. Noh, et kuigi vasak ja parem. Noh, sa vaata töövõrdlustabelit ja kui mõlemad ei ole tõene, vaata, Siis ta ei lähe ja läheb, on ju? Aga nüüd tuleb mõelda seda. Vaata, tegelikult see Andi mõte on see, et sa saad veel Mitu tingimust ju panna?
Õpetaja: Ma küsin ma. Selles mõttes on küll. Ja avastanud. Hästi, ruttu. Vaata, teeme hästi lühikese mõtteharjutuse. Mina hästi kiirelt panen teile selle.
Õpetaja: Ee, Lähme siis. Service klassi kuskil. Kustutan selle jama ära Sealt, mis siin oli.
Õpetaja: No tead, ma teen lihtsalt uue klassi ruttu, et Ei, oleks. Üldse Teeme mingi ajutise. Main classi. Mingi temp. Main Mida iganes
Õpetaja: Midagi ma saan käivitada ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme selle meetodi, mida On võimalik siis noolega Kasutada?
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen if lause. Ma ei kasuta isegi muutujaid. Ma lihtsalt kasutan. Ee, ma panen siia Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: on Ee, tõene.
Õpetaja: Tuleme siia koodi sisse. Teeme selle siis. Kas te deepbooginud olete? Kunagi Üldse
Õpetaja: väga hea? Siis ma, Kes ei ole oma näitena Igal juhul teeme nüüd natuke väikse mõtteharjutuse. Ma panen lihtsalt staatilised väärtused. Kirjutan koodi sisse,
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan true.
Õpetaja: Mi ülisuvaliselt panen neid.
Õpetaja: Mhmh,
Õpetaja: noh, Hea mõtteharjutus.
Õpetaja: Öelge nüüd, Ee, mulle. Me võime kõik koos seda vaadata, et kas me nüüd tuleme siia sisse või Ei, tule siia sisse,
Õpetaja: Nüüd me peame hakkama asju natuke teistmoodi vaatama. Kuidas teie vaataksite Seda
Õpetaja: Mina ütlen juba praegult ära, et tuleb sisse, Ma pean käima ka, Mis teie ütlete? Noh, ma ütlen oma arvamuse ära. Vaata, onju? Ma pakun praegu puusalt. Ma. Nagu, Ma ei. Ma ei vaadanud neid niimoodi detailselt läbi, vaid kasutades lihtsalt oma väikest nagu loogikat. Siis mul peaks olema sada protsenti, et tuleb sisse ja ma selgitan ära ka, miks
Õpetaja: Näe, on tõene. Tuleme siia koodi sisse.
Õpetaja: No me saaksime Jupiti hakata, vaatama neid. Aga mis te arvate, kuidas ma teadsin? Ära vaata, et Tuleb see,
Õpetaja: kuidas.
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame, Kui me vaatame nagu neid asju, mida me peame omavahel siduma. Kõik on ändid, on ju See asi saab rehkenduda truuks
Õpetaja: ainult siis, kui kõik on truud,
Õpetaja: sest et nõuab, et mõlemad pooled on truud. Kui üks neist kolmest ei ole truu, Siis see on. False on õigus,
Õpetaja: on nii? Vaata, kui ma võtaks sinu jaoks klassikaline olukord. Vaata, näe,
Õpetaja: see on see. Kas see saab rehkenduda turuks.
Õpetaja: Mõlemad pooled peavad olema true. Siis on true. Kui ei, siis on False mõlemad pooled Ei ole, onju. No, siin on ju veel seotud. Lihtsalt vaata, et siin on nagu see. Seda, mida ma tahtsingi. Rääkida. Kõik osapooled peavad olema truud, sest nad on and iga omavahel seotud. Kui üks neist on False, siis see on False.
Õpetaja: Nüüd selle ma tegelikult saan mõttes asendada Lihtsalt nüüd juba False iga
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd on mul Orid. Vaata, Orid ju töötavad niimoodi. Et kui üks osapooltest on truu,
Õpetaja: siis on Fools, et kui ma vaatan nagu seda, et
Õpetaja: kui on False või False, siis ta jääb False Iks, See kõik jääb lõpuks, Iks, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, pole vahet. Ja kui üks osapooltest on truu, siis ta on truu, et kuidas ma nagu nägin. Ära vaata, kui ma vaatasin kohe seda seda, asja, mis ma ise siin niimoodi tegin, oli see. Vaata, tegelikult ma juba teadsin selle osa ka siit ära
Õpetaja: ma vaatasin, et siin on ainukene hoor ülejäänud on ändid Ja edaspidi, mul on üli savi. Mul on üli kama. Kas see siin on true või? See siin on False? Sellepärast, et ma näen, et Kogu see ülejäänud jada on põhimõtteliselt rakendub sellele oorile Ja Co pooltest On True Kui üks osapooltest on true, siis järelikult on
Õpetaja: true,
Õpetaja: Noh, see tuleb veits kogemusega, aga ma tahtsin lihtsalt nagu rääkida seda. Vaata, et tavaliselt, et ändid ei ole niimoodi ühekordsed kunagi peaaegu ja Siin tulebki see näide. Näiteks seesama asi. Ma teen ruttu paari teen siin, teeme
Õpetaja: truup. Teeme ühe.
Õpetaja: Ee, Has Priving,
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd räägin ära. Ma. Ma olen alati seda teinud. Ee, seda me kulutame nii või naa. Selle aja kuskil. Ee, paneme
Õpetaja: kiisad alt.
Õpetaja: Paneme midagi juurde, nüüd Nagu midagi muud ka veel sisu. Tegelikult Isegi kama praegult. Ee, Paneme näiteks siia juurde ka. Nagu Nüüd teeme nüüd niimoodi taas. Not.
Õpetaja: Ee, Päästport.
Õpetaja: Ee nii midagi veel. Ee, nii heita, et taas. Not have insurance.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ärme praegu keskendume. Võime varsti sellele keskenduda. Tegelikult Ka Vaata, Onju, Teeme veel midagi. Muidugi teeme niimoodi. Ei, nüüd kanname ikka Ülesande kätte. Vaata, on ju? Ee,
Õpetaja: nii, Tegelikult, need väärtused on ülikama, sest et see ei ole selle mõte.
Õpetaja: Need on muutujad. Need võivad olla meetodid. Mis iganes. Vaata, onju, ma panen siis kuidagi niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis Sa Ei, luba.
Õpetaja: Mul tuleb meelega praegu ainult anda.
Õpetaja: Saad alt selle. Mõõdan ümber.
Õpetaja: Nii nendel tingimustel. Kas me tuleme siia meetodisse sisse või ei tule, Okei,
Õpetaja: Kurat, ma pean mingi voore panema ka siia sisse. Mida ma tegin liiga lihtsalt teile.
Õpetaja: Ma tegelikult mõtlen midagi muud, kui Te tulete, vaatate seda asja näiteks taas. Not have insurance.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me nüüd seda lugema peame Sa pead mõttest siis lugema.
Õpetaja: Sisu on savi, Has insurance.
Õpetaja: Nüüd siit sa loed. Siin on taas Not have report siin. Seda siin ma ei kasuta Inversiooni. Näiteks et siin Sa pead nüüd lugema. Seda eitavalt piisavalt juba. Pead lugema taas not.
Õpetaja: Kui teil on eitus sees ja teil on meetod või mis on eitav, siis Nende asjade peas protsessimine läheb raskeks. Kuidas mina seda õppisin, Code Review. Mul oli vaja teha ühte meetodit. Ee, mis? Vaatas et midagi, et ei ole. Ja ma tegin sellise nimelise meetodi
Õpetaja: ja sain kohe ee. Seeniorilt nagu tagasisidet Nagu, et, ee, Palun, ära tee niimoodi, ma ütlesin Miks, nagu,
Õpetaja: et miks ma. Miks ma ei tea, Mis seal nagu heita? Vaata, ma ütlesin, miks see. Miks ei tohi, ma Ütles, et Saad aru? Vaata seda, et me kaks korda ei hakka tegema sama loogikaga meetodit.
Õpetaja: Sul on mingisugune asi, mis midagi rehkendab. Ja mõnikord see Võibki olla mingi jõhker protsess, Mitte mingid niuksed tobedused, nagu ma rääkisin. Teeme,
Õpetaja: mis rekendab. Lõpuks Me ei tee kakte. Ee niiöelda me ei Tee sellest hiljem kunagi positiivset, kui on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ja sa ütlesid, et kui sa nüüd kunagi hakkad kuskil nagu mingi meetodi seest lugema, vaata, Sul on eitav meetod. Vaata ja sul on. Kui üldse olekski Niukene muster. Vaata, et vabalt võime kasutada eitavad meetodid, et kui nad on Niimoodi vaata. Ja me uusi meetodeid ei, tee, et me kasutame neid inversioonis. Sul läheb lõpuks lihtsalt see mental. Gümnastika läheb lihtsalt niivõrd raskeks,
Õpetaja: Kui nad vähemalt kõik on vähemalt kirjapildis Jaatavad
Õpetaja: Ja siis tuleb see jutumärk sinna juurde. Sul on lihtsam see not sinna kuskile mõttes juurde lisada igat meetodit, või mis? Te loete? Vaata, mis ütleb midagi. Vaata mingit. Noh, nagu tegevus. Vaata, onju mingi siis kui viitaks vaata, et Nii siis mõttes on lihtsam alati jaotus ja lugeda eituseks.
Õpetaja: Ja ma niimoodi peangi tegema. Selles mõttes, et vaata, Kui mina tulen, loen seda Rida siinse. Ma pean mõtlema sellest Driving Lisence,
Õpetaja: kui siin. Ei, kui siin on inversioon ees. Ma pean nüüd mõttes seda lugema. Taas Not Have driving license. Vaatamata sa aru, Sest et see on siin see mõte. Vaata, on ju.
Õpetaja: Ja mul on seda alati lihtsam lugeda, kui Ma satun mingi niisugusesse olukorda. Ma mõtlen, ja jällegi nagu. Ärge mõelge seda niimoodi, et et see saab olema mingi tšilli pilli,
Õpetaja: ärge mõelge, et see saab olema niimoodi, et seda seda meetodit on kuskil niimoodi ühe. If I se või? Noh, seda on kuskil seda ühe If I sees nagu kasutatud. Kui see nii oleks, poleks eriti Raske onju üks koht, kust lugeda.
Õpetaja: Noh, saaks veel hakkama, aga kui siin nüüd Oleks veel mingi ändide ja Oridega. Ja ma ütlen ka, et mingi bändoori. Mingit nagu niukene segane värk on onju, Ja seal mõnel on Mõnel ei ole. Siis on niimoodi, et sa lihtsalt mõtled, et
Õpetaja: miks? Ma üldse seda teen? See on jama. Sellepärast ei saa teha kunagi eitavat meetodit. Ärge tehke eitavat meetodit.
Õpetaja: See ei tähenda. See ei tähenda seda, et ei saa olla nagu negatiivne meetod midagi. Mis on ebameeldiv nagu. Vaata, et kuidas seda kirjeldab Aga eitavat. Ärge tehke. Mõelge alati lihtsalt sellele, et juhul kui sellele meetodile peaks panema lihtsalt Aa inversiooni peale,
Õpetaja: siis, kuidas see asi tunduks, kui see on? Nagu Tundub igatepidi Fine.
Õpetaja: Loetav, arusaadav ja lihtne. Sa pead natukene kasutama protsessorit ka, et mõtlema, et äkki ta mingi muu asjaga, nagu koos ja mingi muu tingimusega. Vaata, et. Noh, kas, kas nagu arvad, et nagu jääb, aga eitavad meetodit. Ärge tehke, kas tuli siit enamvähem välja? Miks ei tohi?
Õpetaja: Ärge tehke seda. Aa, siis Ei, tule seda ka. Noh, see oli ka Niukene. Okei,
Õpetaja: meetod. Ee, mis on jaama meetod? Koodiplokk, mis sooritab teatud tegevust, mida saab korduvalt välja kutsuda. Iga meetod peab olema osa Mingist klassist algab tavaliselt tüübi märkimisega.
Õpetaja: Aa, noh, jah, tegelikult. Meetod tavaliselt algab nähtavusega.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra ka.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd on veel Study siin Ka sees veel.
Õpetaja: Jah, ma seda nagu mingi aeg räägin. Natukene, ma arvan. Detailsemalt ja paremini. Aga konstruktor vaatab, mis siin kirjas on.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, Noh, õige,
Õpetaja: okei, Seda peab nagu veel nagu üle rääkima. See on selge
Õpetaja: ja. Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, see on see põhiline.
Õpetaja: Noh, need on lihtsalt Teemad, mida ma niikuinii? Ee, räägin üle. Vaata korra lihtsalt seda. Seda Ma tunnen ka veel huvi.
Õpetaja: Nii okei,
Õpetaja: jah, selle. Ma räägin ka Üle nagu natukene kogemusest. Selles mõttes, et teil ei ole kogemust. Ee, seda kogemust, et kuidas õpetada teisi. Ee, nendel teemadel. Ee, mul seda jagub. Ee, seal need need teemad. Ma räägin niikuinii üle Nad olid nagu keerulised. Ka Aga tähtis oli see, et te juba olete niikuinii neid puudutanud ja nuusutanud.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas sobib? Teeme mingi pool tundi päris arendust ka.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ee niiöelda vaatame edasi, mina lasen kõik siit õhku endal praegult. Mis ma siin vahepeal soperdasin.
Õpetaja: Me vist jõudsime Css iga tegelikult Ära rääkida suures pildis, kuidas ta töötab ja me näpime seda asja veel Ee Niiöelda Praktilise Külje pealt. Nii või naa. Ee, ma panen ühe serveri uuesti käima, kuigi ta juba siin taustal käib,
Õpetaja: Me tegime ära vormi.
Õpetaja: Ee, me väga paljudele vist kujundust ei jõudnud. Anda.
Õpetaja: Ja ma arvan, me ei hakkagi seda tegema me tegime need Näited ära. Ee, kuidas selektorid töötavad,
Õpetaja: mäletate? Ee, se lektorid käivad niimoodi. Noh, peab siis käima ka. Või?
Õpetaja: Ee selektorid siis niimoodi käivad nagu järjest ülevalt alla ja vaatavad. Lihtsalt Html is. Kas on midagi, mis tuleb üle värvida või mitte, on meeles?
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ei ole meeles, Siis tuletame meelde selle osa, et, ee, meil on praegu eraldi failist. Nad nii, nagu meil meeldibki teha, et see põhimõtteliselt brauser või kes Iganes käib niimoodi, et. Hei, otsi ülesse. Kas siin lehel on seda? Hei, kas otsi ülesse Kas siin lehel on seda? Kas on kuskil Body
Õpetaja: bla, bla, bla, blabla. Ee, see näide ka. Ee, Näete, Body on siin ju kenasti ära määratud, et background on Aqua, on onju
Õpetaja: Nii kui ma lähen praegult siia tingimuste alla, siis see on valge.
Õpetaja: Miks see valge on kalli lehm
Õpetaja: Sest et siin selles indeksis on meil ära määratud, et me kasutame väikest asja nagu styleshit. Aga kus see teine oli? Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, Kuhu alla ma topisin? Nad panin, onju? Näiteks kui me tuleme hinnakirjale, siis tema ei tea sellest midagi, onju? Laen hinnakirja ei tea midagi,
Õpetaja: aga kui on, siis teab samamoodi, on Siis selle ee teisega.
Õpetaja: Mis see teine oli? Ee, tingimused,
Õpetaja: Html tingimused. Selles mõttes. Siin on Body Block. Näete, on ju,
Õpetaja: Miks teda ei Värvita on lihtsalt seda, et ta lihtsalt ei ole teadlik, et ta peab see. See lektor käib ka aina vastupidisena, kui see, et hei Kehtesta kõik. Ee, Mine nagu ava nagu see stiil ja kehtesta kõik need reeglid sellel Html, Il.
Õpetaja: Noh, kaine on niimoodi, et ta käib üle. Ja meil oli siis tähtis just see järjekord. Niiöelda me vaatasime seda ka Aa, ja siis vaatasime ka veel seda, et kui panna veel important juurde, siis see mõjutas seda, et sa saad kaine nagu üle sõita.
Õpetaja: Ee nendest tingimustest nii ja naa
Õpetaja: nüüd. Aa, asi, mille juurde. Mina sooviks järgmisena minna. On Siis Ee Action Jackson Ee ja Avascript.
Õpetaja: Mm, Ma vist isegi tegelikult need materjalid on olemas. Ma tahaksin ennem natukene Javascriptist rääkida.
Õpetaja: Ee, päris materjalidega, mis mina olen. Mina olen nagu juurde lisanud, Mitte nende Ee, mitte nende,
Õpetaja: Mitte praegu. Tead, ma Küsime kindlasti Cloudilt ka, et ta nüüd meile midagi viskaks. Ee, aga ma tegelikult tahaks näidata ühte joonist,
Õpetaja: et te hakkaksite mõtlema asjadest ikkagi Kui objektidest.
Õpetaja: Noh, andmeobjektid. Loomulikult.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kui me tuleme siia koolituse käigus klassiruumis
Õpetaja: jaama Script,
Õpetaja: interpreteeritav keel mitte kompileeritav. See tähendas seda et ee Kui java kontrollib kõik üle, kompileerib koodi paikkoodi, siis Javascript seda ei tee, paneb linnulennult linnulennult konstandid ja muutujad. Ee, siis ee, kui me Hakkame rääkima nüüd muutujatest.
Õpetaja: Siis Jaavas on meil tüübid ja avascriptis. Meil ei ole tüübid.
Õpetaja: Meil on seal nagu selles mõttes kahte tüüpi Aa, Lett on, see, et mingisugune muutuja, mille sisu võib muutuda. Objekt Taustal võib muutuda. Mäletate seda silti? On ju
Õpetaja: Silt saab olla nagu ainult Üks kuskil kontekstis. Aga küsimus on see, et kas ma tohin panna mis Mul oli siin see nagu. Vaata, et kas let tähendab seda, et ma võin seda sama silvi käest tõsta. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: siduda erineva objektiga. Kui ma defineerin selle sildi, siis ma ütlen, et siin sisu võib taga muutuda. See on lett
Õpetaja: alternatiiv. Sellele on konst
Õpetaja: konstant. Seal tähendab see seda niimoodi. Et kui ma ühe korra loon sildi ja panen selle väärtuse külge, siis ta jääbki selle objektiga seotuks. Ma ei saa enam vahetada,
Õpetaja: et ma kuskil programmiliselt hiljem tahan öelda, et näiteks mingi First Name. Anna uus väärtus. Ta ütleb, et te ei saa näiteid ka. Konstantid. Valdavalt ongi sellised, asjad mis on konstantselt sama. No näiteks Vanus kuskil programmis. See võib ju muutuda. Vaata seal mingil põhjendusel, Mis iganes, mis me seal programmis teeme, aga B väärtus on ju Fixed For Life, onju?
Õpetaja: Saate aru nagu mõttest või näiteks mingisugune urlirada või midagi taolist. Mingi asi, mis on kindlalt paigas,
Õpetaja: et see ei muutu Me programmiliselt ei soovi, et ta enam muutuks. Siis sa saad nagu kaitsta selle. Põhimõtteliselt. Ära vaata, et sa ise ise programmis ei saa mingit jama korraldada. See on kaitsemänism.
Õpetaja: Sellega aga tüüpi ei ole.
Õpetaja: Pole inti, pole Stringi pole pole neid teisi tüüpe ja avas on
Õpetaja: aga Samamoodi. Kuidas käib sildi loomine? Kui sa kirjapildis kirjutad mõlemad asjad välja. Let Age.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et tekib selline ümbrik, kuhu siis saab vanust panna või silt, on see mõte, selge? Kui ma tahan seda väärtust kuskil hiljem programmist kätte saada, siis ma ei kirjuta enam let Age uuesti, vaid ma ütlen, et ma ei tea prindikonsooli või näite kasutajale. Siis ma juba ütlen lihtsalt ja ta saab aru, et ma Räägin sellest sisust. Küsimusi
Õpetaja: pole. Ee, jaavas. Jah, ei, ma tahan talle öelda. Et. Ee. Lisa sellele vanusele viis aastat,
Õpetaja: kuidas ta teab, et See on arv. Mingite mingisugune.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, nüüd tuleb. Nüüd tuleb siis ee. Ja ava.
Õpetaja: Jaava. On üks suur läbu maa
Õpetaja: tee, mis tahad. Nagu Selles mõttes, vaata Selles see mõte ongi, et. Ee, vaata, siin on need plussid ja miinused.
Õpetaja: Siin on kahjust. Vaata, jaava pluss. Selle tüübi Tundlikkusega on see, et kompilaator pistab kisama
Õpetaja: juba progemise käigus ütleb sulle, vaata. Et Kuule, kui mina ütlen, näiteks vaata, pluss ee, paned ringi, Rain, vaata siis. Ta ütleb, et. No,
Õpetaja: no, no. Kui ma tahan võrrelda. Vaata, kas. Ee. See number võrdub testiga. Ta ütleb, no sellepärast, et Muutujal on tüüp taga ja avascriptis pole.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja ärme unusta ära. Ee on interpreteeritav keel. See on hästi rõve sõna, mitte kompileeritav. See on see, et ta jooksutamise hetkel tõlgendab koode ja tegu tegudeks ja visuaaliks, Mis iganes Vaata kuidas mõelda,
Õpetaja: et seal ei ole mingeid kaitsemehhanisme. Ja kui sa nüüd oma programmis teedki mingi vale liigutuse, vaata, et sul on seal näiteks. Sees on hoopis nimi, onju Ja sa tahad kuskil koolis öelda? Pluss Kümme vaata. Siis lihtsalt tekib jooksutamise hetkel mingi viga
Õpetaja: mis. See pluss on muidugi? Et, mõtleks et, tüübitundetul on See, et, noh, proged on väga mõnus. Kui sa ei pea seal sahkerdama seal koguaeg nende mingi nagu mingisuguste ringide ja asjadega ja Nii edasi. Sa ei pea nagu aeg defineerima seda, et sa saad nagu kuidagi lihtsamalt seda teha. Aga sul kaitsemehhanismid ei ole, Olete kuulnud niuksest Sõnast nagu
Õpetaja: see on jaavascript. Kus on siis ee, sisse keevitatud. Põhimõtteliselt, et ei. Me Ikka tüübid. Defineerime ära.
Õpetaja: Vot nii,
Õpetaja: no siin on? Näited ka. Ee, siis konstadi mõttes. Ee, ka jaaval on oma versioon sellest olemas. On ikka see, et sa ütled tüübi ja mingisuguse nime sellele muutujale. Kas sa paned sõna Final juurde?
Õpetaja: Kompilaator ei luba sul kuskile öelda. Pii võrdub ja anda mingit uut väärtust,
Õpetaja: kui sa oled selle ühe korra. Jah, saad ainult ühe korra defineerida. See, see ka eeldab seda, et sa annad talle kohe otse väärtuse kompilaat, kui sa Lihtsalt lood mingi muutuja ja tal väärtust ta ei anna siis ta nagu ütleb nagu. Kuule, aga
Õpetaja: whats the point of this. Vaata, et Kui Kui sa tekitad praegult siia muuta, mille taga ei ole mitte midagi
Õpetaja: konstantselt sama, et sa ei saa seda hiljem muuta ka et Vaata, kui muutu. Ei lähe. Sa võid, öelda et siin on üks uus sildikene, aga kohe väärtust ei anna kuidagi hiljem programmi. Mingisugus jadasid, Tuleb talle väärtus külge muutuja. Kas see sõna muutuja on ka? Nagu et ta muutub?
Õpetaja: Konstant ei ole. Vaata, muutuja. Noh, ta muuta selle programmilises definitsioonis. Aga konstant on nagu eriliik sellest muutujast, et ühe korra saab talle anda, on ju?
Õpetaja: No tegelikult, noh, kui hästi tehniliselt minna Ja variable. Ja siis nagu konstant. Selles mõttes on erinevad. Aga nagu jaavas kui see nagu see sildikene. Me mõtleme ikkagi, nagu variable, on ju
Õpetaja: nii.
Õpetaja: Ee, funktsioonid.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja Java Scriptis ei ole meetodid,
Õpetaja: Aga see nüüd oli lihtsalt heal Lapsel Mitu nime?
Õpetaja: Funktsioon? Meetod võib ka mõni mõnes kohas olla mingi protseduur tihtipeale. Tegelikult tähendavad ühel või teisel viisil on mingit nimelist koodilõiku, mida on võimalik käivitada tema nime abil
Õpetaja: Ee, funktsioonid nimelised oma loo loodud koodi osad. Vaatame natukene nende. Aga me ütleme niimoodi. Kui me hakkame voes voes, hakkame progema. Me kutsume neid kogu aeg meetoditeks. Me ei hakka kasutama seda sõna funktsiooni, aga tehniliselt võttes lihtsalt nimetus jaoskirjutus on nii.
Õpetaja: Meetodite deklareerimine
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt Function märksõna No vähemalt puhtas jaavas gripis. See nii on. Ee, voe suudab meile ka selle ise niiöelda õigel hetkel külge pookida. Raamistik ise teeb lõppkoodi meile ise valmis. Me võime asju lühemalt mõnusamalt mugavamalt kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Raamistik voe hoolitseb selle eest, et lõpus kõik on täpselt nii, nagu peab olema Tiptop
Õpetaja: Function märksõna. See on siis see, mis teeb. See annab märku. Vaata põhimõtteliselt programmile, et tegemist on nüüd funktsiooniga, mitte mingisuguse muutujaga ega Mingi muu asjaga
Õpetaja: Funktsiooni nimi,
Õpetaja: mille järgi saab ee funktsiooni välja kutsuda. Noh, see on sama jälle nagu objektide puhul need muutujad, kui ma Tahan pöörduda Arturi või Riho poole, siis. Noh, nime abil Ma saan seda teha. Kui ma tahan käivitada mingisugust nimelist koodilõiku, siis nime abil Ma saan seda teha. Kui nime pole, siis on väga keeruline.
Õpetaja: Vanasti Olid küll. Niuksed programmeerimis keeled, mis olid niimoodi? Et Mine, nüüd koodireale Kolmkümmend. Käivita seal. Mingi tegevus. Sealt tuli omakorda. Nüüd käivita mingi koodirida. Nelikümmend viis. Noh, polnud nimesi.
Õpetaja: Olid rea numbrid.
Õpetaja: Go To line.
Õpetaja: Noh, Niukest asja ammu ei ole. Muidugi, loomulikult.
Õpetaja: Aa, funktsioonid, parameetrid, funktsioonid parameetrid. Siis on midagi funktsiooni. Parameetrit, Mis ma tee? Sinna Panin sulgude sees
Õpetaja: Määrame ära, siis parameetrid nb muutuja nime. Ees puudub sõna lett Sisuliselt. See on siin sildi loomine.
Õpetaja: Kui silti. Tegelikult Loome ju niimoodi, et Ütleme Let. Age
Õpetaja: nüüd siin para Sest et jaavas see nii on. Jaavas ütled. String First name kui ta on parameeter, ta on ikka seal tegelikult sildikene selle Ee, sulgude vahel. String First Name Siin ei ole. Nii Siin on teistmoodi. Siin on lihtsalt nimi.
Õpetaja: Kõik, et, ee, Niimoodi näete, Ei ole siin leti ees. Aga ta tegelikult on muutuja. Ta silt
Õpetaja: nb muuta. Nimes puudub sõna, led, konst, mis iganes
Õpetaja: ja Java. Ee. Kui mul on siin kaks, kolm muut või parameetrit defineeritud jaavas, siis on niimoodi Näiteks Get Full Name on meetodi nimi. Sisendina Lähevad sisse first name ja last. Name annab mulle tagasi Täisnime niimoodi, et ühik on vahel näiteks
Õpetaja: siis seal on, niimoodi, et. Jaa, sa Ei saa. Ee. Näiteks kutsuda seda nimelist meetodit välja niimoodi, et ma annan ainult näiteks Rain sinna sisse
Õpetaja: ühest ringi,
Õpetaja: kui see meetod on Defineeritud. Tal on kaks nii öelda Parameetrit siis ainukene moodus. Kuidas ma saan seda välja käivitada niimoodi, et kompilaator ei saada mind, kuke,
Õpetaja: Ee on niimoodi, et ma ütlen selle meetodi nime. Panen sinna kaks seda tüüpi väärtust,
Õpetaja: mis on nõutud. String String Rain
Õpetaja: tüür ainult sellisel juhul käivitub Ja ei kompileeru ka. Kui ma üritan mingit muud jama teha ja Avascret
Õpetaja: teen selle ühe parameetriga. Kutsun selle meetodi välja kahe sisendiga, Kuidas need sisendid eraldame? Mis süntaks on? Vahet pole jao. Ja kuidas parameetreid eraldame, et mitu tükki need on seal
Õpetaja: koma
Õpetaja: koma on ju See, mis annab märku Vaatad. Mul on siin üks asi ja teine asi. Ja kolmas asi.
Õpetaja: Kui mina annan käivitaks sama asja. Vaata, get Full name. Vaata, mis üldse ootab. Tegelikult kahte asja sisse ja anna sisse. Ta käivitub. See on jaava skept. Võid kõike teha,
Õpetaja: läheb tööle, Sest et seal ei ole kombinaatoreid ka. Kas see asi nüüd korrektselt töötab? Kui see poodi lõik käivitub ee ja mul ühtegi viga ei, tule. Noh, siis on vaja ise jälgida, et kõik on korrektne ja hästi. Ja sa teed õigeid asju.
Õpetaja: Ja Ongi see sama näide ka, et võtab sisse. Ee, ma ei tea. Võtab sisse ainult ühe muutuja. Ma üritan käivitada meetodid. Anna talle mingi kolm sisendit omadega on eraldatud Ta käivitub. Kuhu need teised nagu väärtused kaovad. Mina ei tea musta auku. Kuhugi lähevad ära, aga kood käivitub. Väiksed erisused on
Õpetaja: nii? Ee, Tuleme siis siia tagasi.
Õpetaja: Parameetrid, Jah, vot kus me jäime?
Õpetaja: Ee, järgmine osa sellest on siis ee. Funktsioonis. Coop, näete neid punaseid,
Õpetaja: Kui mina Kutsun seda nime, välja. Siis kogu see koodilõik. Vähemalt selles ulatuses. No see on maksimum. Siis justkui see osa saab käivitada siin sees nende Loogiliste sulgude vahel on ära defineeritud. Siis see kood
Õpetaja: siis. Koer on lihtsalt ruut. On ju üks number. Korrutada iseendaga.
Õpetaja: Panen nelja sisse, mis Õige vastus on
Õpetaja: kuusteist. Jumal tänatud, Keegi kaheksa ei öelnud või midagi taolist, et. Ee, see on skoop.
Õpetaja: Me peame saama programmist kuidagi öelda. Vaata, et kui meil on Niuke nimeline nii öelda koodilõik, siis kus tema algab ja kus tema lõppeb.
Õpetaja: Nii Ee funktsiooni tagastus see retoor Lause valikuline. Seda ei pea tegema,
Õpetaja: aga saab teha. Kõigepealt rehkendatakse välja see osa, mis on returnist paremal pool. See kehtib jaagas ka kui Te näete kuskil koodis mingi return lauset. Siis hakake keskenduma sellele paremale poolele üldse, nagu mis toimub. See asi peab ühel või teisel viisil Milleski rehkenduma. Kas on mingi number? Kas on mingi tekst? Kas on mingi tõeväärtus Vahet pole?
Õpetaja: Ee see siis Niiöelda käivitatakse.
Õpetaja: Funktsioonide väljakutsumine, funktsioonide Väljakutsumine Ee Käib Meetodi nime abil. Kutsume välja meetodi nime nimega Square.
Õpetaja: Näete siin Square väljakutsumisele? Anname kaasa väärtuse kaks
Õpetaja: seda võib mõelda ka Kui objekti See on Objekt number kaks.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt rehkendaks sa välja. See osa, mis on märgist paremal pool
Õpetaja: ja siis tekib meile siia sildikene Result
Õpetaja: Led tähendab seda, et see saaks veel hiljem muutuda. Kui tahaks, või saaksin muuta
Õpetaja: ja siis omastatakse, et kui me loeme niukest koodi, Siis selles mõttes me alguses lihtsalt põhimõtteliselt keskendume selle paremale poolele. Lihtsalt nagu me ei tohi. Kui sa koodi loed mind, noh, see annab vihje. Vaata, mida me siit saame, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga põhimõtteliselt nagu kood. Kõigepealt käivitab selle osa
Õpetaja: see. See siin ei saa väärtust, vaid käitub see meetod. Näete, siin on nüüd sildikene. Mis? Nii sildikese taga on? Number
Õpetaja: Kaks on ju? Nüüd ta tulebki siia paremal Poolel tuleb kaks korda. Kaks on neli return. Tähendab, Seda, et kui selle meetodi välja kutsud ja siin teisel pool, on midagi, siis siit selle tulemuse saame kätte Ja see tulemus elab nüüd selle muutuja sees.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kõige tähtsam asi, mida ma korrutan. Nagu Overnover agent.
Õpetaja: See Funktsioon. Või meetod ei tea Oma välisest elust mitte midagi
Õpetaja: ta ei tea. Meil võib olla mingi sadu Scriptifaile.
Õpetaja: Selles samas failis võib olla igasuguseid funktsioone, meetodeid, igasugust informatsiooni
Õpetaja: Ta ei tea oma välisest elust mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tea mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Ta ei. Kui kuskil seal midagi toimub. Mingid muud asjad. Action Il. Temal ei ole seda informatsiooni olemas. Ta ei saa midagi teha millegiga.
Õpetaja: Kõik, Mis informatsioon, mis sa tahad? Noh, selleks väiksed erandid ka, Aga sellest räägime siis, kui jõuame. Kõik see, mis sa tahad, Nagu et sellel sellel koodilõigul Ee, informatsioonina oleks olemas, Tuleb anda kaasa
Õpetaja: parameeter, Kust me ta välja kutsume? Kust ta paika?
Õpetaja: No seal kutsume välja. Kuidas meil on seda vaja? Noh, siin näit siin. Seda me saame Jõuame selleni, kui me hakkame kohe nüüd tegema, et. Noh, ma ei saagi sellele vastata. Praegult Sellele ei ole mõtet vastata,
Õpetaja: aga vaatame korra seda, nagu. Kuidas see protsess on, Siis on ju
Õpetaja: ee, muutuja luua. Niipea kui see meetod käivitub, luuakse uus muutuja N,
Õpetaja: Ta on selle Ümbriku või Sildi nimi on N.
Õpetaja: Tema väärtus Seal sees on. Kaks.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd põhimõtteliselt see meetod, siis. Noh, mis me just rääkisime, käivitatakse kandja nagu sellisel kujul,
Õpetaja: et me võime mõelda. Vaata, et kaks tuleb sisse. Seda sama väärtust on siin kasutatud. Korrutatakse, saadakse omavahel tulemus
Õpetaja: parempool Pool rehkendatakse välja. See pool nüüd tekib.
Õpetaja: Tekitatakse uus muutuja result, mis saab tagastatud väärtuse.
Õpetaja: See return teeb niimoodi et saate aru, kui kõik Mis siin sees on? Kaasa arvatud see n.
Õpetaja: See see sildikene. Millal, ta. Millal ta tekib ja millal ta sureb? Nagu nende parameetrit tekib Nagu siin. See sildike tekib Siin koodilõigus. Millal ta sureb?
Õpetaja: Ta sureb siin. Ära Kui seda retoorlauset ei ole,
Õpetaja: siis on niimoodi, et kogu See informatsioon, mis siin sees oli, on kõik kadunud. See on kõik kadunud, Aga see return lause annab meile võimalusel, et sealt, kus meid välja kutsutakse,
Õpetaja: siis see. See antakse üle siin. Kutsud meetodi välja.
Õpetaja: Retorium tagastab mingisuguse väärtuse. Nüüd me saame seda siin hoida.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see Kood siin samamoodi ei tea mitte midagi, mis siin sees toimub. Tal ei ole neid muutujaid.
Õpetaja: Tal ei ole neid muutujaid tal. Ta ei ole. Kõik, mis siin sees on, on selle selle koodi lõigu oma. See ongi selle mõte. On see, et me ehitame niuksed krotsid, mida sa kogu aeg kasutada.
Õpetaja: Ja need klotsid on taotluslikud. Nad ei ole mitte millegiga seotud, sest et niipea kui nad on mingisuguse väga konkreetse asjaga nagu seotud,
Õpetaja: siis kuskil teises kontekstis. Seda klotsi ei saa enam kasutada, kui ta info mõttes on mingi muu asjaga seotud
Õpetaja: Aga kui Nad on niuksed, eraldiseisvad, niuksed, tükikesed.
Õpetaja: Anna lihtsalt mulle mingi info või midagi kaasa. Mina midagi. Teen.
Õpetaja: Piiritus ongi. Noh, siin ongi varemgi siin Mõned ee ägedamad persoonad on nagu selle välja öelnud. Progemine see nimekiri.
Õpetaja: Et, ee. Sa kutsud teile mingi meetodi. Sa annad talle mingi info kaasa Ja sa saad selle tagasi sa teed sellega midagi. See on lihtne, aga alguses on see väga raske. Ja nüüd ma ütlen nagu, et see osa siin,
Õpetaja: See osa siin ja see osa siin. Noh, mulle meeldib muidugi jaavas rohkem mõelda. On mingil põhjusel kõige raskem kontseptsioon maamunal.
Õpetaja: Ma olen viimased. Ee, viimased kursused. Ma olen nagu rohkem saavutanud seda, et te ikkagi saate sellest aru,
Õpetaja: aga mure on see selline, on üks niuke lause, mida me hakkame niiöelda lausuma? Kuuleme laulu. Ka
Õpetaja: See on meetodi palve.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mina kuskil mingil hetkel ütlen, et Nüüd on piir.
Õpetaja: Nüüd te kõik peaksite saama sellest kontseptsioonist aru.
Õpetaja: Siis sellest hetkest on meil selline asi, et kes ee, seda asja ikka veel aru ei saa siis Ta hakkab aru saama.
Õpetaja: Temast saab meetodi Ee palve välja. Hõiskaja.
Õpetaja: See palve on selline.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kutsud välja meetodi,
Õpetaja: mis midagi teeb? Oota, mis sa kutsus? Ma ei kujuta, kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi teeb.
Õpetaja: Aa, hea küll, nii palju meel meelest ära läinud. Ma pean ise seda korrutanud, aga mul oli nagu sõnastus niimoodi, et ta voolas ikka hästi.
Õpetaja: Mkm, siis ta Midagi teeb?
Õpetaja: Jah, okei, niimoodi. Ee, kui sa kutsud välja meetodi, mis tagastab ee, mingit infot ja sa soovid selle infoga midagi edasi teha, Siis pane see muutujasse. Vot nii,
Õpetaja: kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, nad. Vaadake, Square I, Mis midagi tagastab. Näete seda return lauset seal Ja sa soovid selle infoga midagi edasi teha,
Õpetaja: Siis pane see muutujasse.
Õpetaja: Kui sa ei tee seda, siis see info on kadunud. For good,
Õpetaja: Sa Ei, saa enam programmiliselt mitte kuidagi viidata sellele infole,
Õpetaja: mis pannakse kokku siin ja on siin olemas its Gone
Õpetaja: ja ma mõtlen, ma Nüüd räägin, see on. Me läheme kohe lõunapausile ka. Ee, mul oli au ja võimalus osaleda siim rebase minu eelkäija viimasel ee koolitusel
Õpetaja: ta Tegi küll seda onlineis. Selle ta. See ei olnud enam selle Covidi pärast, aga ta oli juba võibolla saanud harjutada, kuidas ka online is seda teha. Ta tegi online, Siis mul oli võimalus näha. Vaata enda eelkäija nagu vi. Nagu seda viimast koolitust. Vaata, noh, mis moodi tema teeb suurepärane asi.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatasin nagu. Et õpilased nagu kogu aeglivad. Nagu täiega sellega. Vaata, ei saa seda aru. Vaata, kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab. Ja sa soovid selle infoga midagi edasi teha, Siis pane see lihtsalt muutujasse. Võibolla lõpptulemus on see, et sa ei pea panema muutujasse. Ta läheb kuskile otse Return I, Aga vähemalt esimese sammuna võiks seda teha. Alati,
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui te istute kuskil Koodi Real ja Nüüd kujutage ette. Lihtsalt pange ise. Käsi. Kas ekraanile ette, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui te katate selle vasaku poole, kas võrdusmärgiga ära
Õpetaja: nii Ja kui te näete lihtsalt praegu, et mingisugust meetodit, mis midagi tegelikult tagastab. Mingisuguse info,
Õpetaja: Niiöelda algajad progejad. Ja te nagu nuputasite, välja, et Te peate käivitama mingisuguse tegevuse.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi mis annabki mingisugused andmed.
Õpetaja: Kui Te, nagu nüüd jõllate lihtsalt seda meetodi väljakutsumist, siis kuidagi mingil põhjusel Te kogu aeg alati arvate, et teil on see info nüüd olemas,
Õpetaja: Aga ta pole kuhugi ühegi sildiga seda infot sidunud.
Õpetaja: Te. Te olete Õige meetod. Te olete andmete taastamise andmebaasist. Mingi andmete väljakutsumine.
Õpetaja: Ee Noh, mida ta ütleb, mida ta teeb?
Õpetaja: Ta peaks mulle tagastama mingisuguse konto, Mis on nagu andmeobjekt Kus on andmed sees? Ma tahan midagi teha. Sellega
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui sa lähed järgmisele reale ja sul see Caret vilgub seal niimoodi
Õpetaja: kui sa Sa oled selle ära tabanud. Vaata, punkt. Ee, Account. Repositori punkt. Ee. Mingi user Id. Mida iganes vahet pole,
Õpetaja: te Olete kõik sammud ära teinud. Aga te kurat ei pane seda lihtsalt muutujasse. Siis te nüüd vaatate nagu seda vilkuvat joont ja mõtlete, mis ma nüüd edasi tegema pean.
Õpetaja: Ja kui teil ei ole nüüd seda muutujat ja seda muutuja nime nime, nagu seal silme ees,
Õpetaja: siis teie Mängumaa on väga lühikene. Nagu ma mõtlen, et millega te saate üldse tegeleda? Midagi Mis parameetrina sisse tuli? Need on andmed nagu meetodisse endasse, Onju midagi, mi? Mille vastu võibolla otse kuidagi minna. Saate mingeid andmeid ligi. Aga põhimõtteliselt teil, kui teil silme ees ei ole, lihtsalt nagu Mingi Aa, account. Account Muutuja,
Õpetaja: mis on Hall Hall on siis, kui muuta pole kordagi kasutatud. Kui teil oleks see silm ees, siis te vähemalt oskate mõelda. Oota, ma tahtsin saada mingi konto andmeid. Ilmselt ma pean midagi nendega tegema. Ja nüüd, et midagi, teha on teil vaja seda nime seda silti. Nüüd tee sellega midagi.
Õpetaja: Kui te kutsute välja meetodi välja. Te mõtlete, et. Oi, ma ju. Ma mõtlen, see käib Niimoodi ma tulen nagu kellegi selja taha aitama, onju?
Õpetaja: Ütleb, et Davai teeme siis, koos. Aga ma ei tee nii. Ma ei ole see Vend, kes ütleb ette, ma olen. Noh, kolm neli nädalat Olen ette öelnud. Aitab, onju?
Õpetaja: Peab juba hakkama ise pusima proovima. Annan vihjeid ja Mis iganes, vaata, onju ette ei ütle.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, et räägime, Mis sa siin teed. Näed, ee. Jaa. Näed. Ma ütlesin, et räägi mulle koodi, Mis siin teeb? Ee, siin ma ütlen. Ee, Find account by User It siin. Ma otsin üldse konto. Ja väga hea, täpselt seda tegema peabki siin selles Ee, kontekstis siin taaskes sinu ülesandes. Väga hea.
Õpetaja: Ja. Ja siis. Ee. Jah, nii, aga mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Ei, me ei tea, Noh, mis ma üldse seal olen või ma just koos teeme. Vaata, et Noolekene vilgub, sest et ta on kutsunud selle meetodi välja, Aga tal see vasak pool on puudu.
Õpetaja: Ei oska mitte midagi mõelda. Siis ma nagu üritan nagu suunata teda Davai, et lähme korra sinna sinna meetodisse. Kus sul on see aa niiöelda ära defineeritud. Vaata, et nagu mis see meetod teeb, me lähme vaatame seda ülemist osa põhimõtteliselt on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja läheme siin ülesse kohta. Ja meetod seal meetodi definitsioonis on näha seda, et ta tagastab Account objekti.
Õpetaja: Ma küsin, et mida See meetod teeb. See otsib andmebaasist andmeid. Vaata ja siis ta tagastab. Siis ta annab selle objekti sulle. Ma tagastab selle objekti ja tagastab Väga tore on ju? Läheme tagasi sinna, Vaatad sa välja kutsud. Vaata, et siin me kutsume välja nagu meetodi, mis nagu tagastab mingi objekti, et. Noh, et
Õpetaja: et mis sul nüüd nagu edasi võiks teha. Nojah, nüüd see kanto on mul käes aga
Õpetaja: on mul nüüd käes, aga Ma ei oska temaga midagi teha,
Õpetaja: aga auto on käes. Sul ei ole mitte midagi käes.
Õpetaja: See Account oli seal väljakutsumise hetkel see, kes andmebaasis. Need andmed sai. Ta sai selle objekti. Ta näiteks selle objekti valmis. Ja ta tegelt on sulle ka veel. Selle on ju
Õpetaja: aga Niipea kui seal, põhimõtteliselt tema oma töö ära, teeb, siis see objekt on ära kadunud. Me oleme siin koodi failis, kus me seda välja kutsume. Tema ei tea midagi sellest teisest asjast, Onju,
Õpetaja: et kui sa paneksid ta kohe muutujasse, siis oleks teine olukord
Õpetaja: siis me jõllaksime praegu niukest rida, kus seal oleks. Näiteks siis Account. Account võrdub. Ee, Account. Repositori find. Account Pauser Id. Ja siis seal oleks Niukene hall muutuja nimi Account
Õpetaja: Seal oleks vähemalt millestki mõelda. Siis saaks hakata nagu rääkima. Et. Okei, nüüd on Account. Mida me temaga edasi teeme,
Õpetaja: et ja See. See tundub nagu ma ütlen, et kui minu eelkäija, nagu ma nägin nagu hullult, siis ma mõtlesin, nagu
Õpetaja: ma lihtsalt õpetan kohe, nagu selle asja niiöelda selgeks, nagu
Õpetaja: kogu aeg. Nad teevad seda sama asja Nad oskavad nagu õigeid asju nagu käivitada, aga nad mitte kunagi kurat ei pane neid kuradi muutuasse ja siis on nagu juhe koos.
Õpetaja: Ja ma mõtlesin, et ma lihtsalt räägin ja seletan ja kõik saavad aru Ja nii edasi, on ju? Ja mis siis reaalsus oli? Reaalsus oli siis see niimoodi, et esimesed mingi viis, kuus kursust oli niimoodi, et Johhaidii.
Õpetaja: Jahun ja jahun. Ja jahun ja hullult teen mingisuguseid asju. Toon nagu ma nii hullult rõhutan, Ja räägin iga päev nämmutan seda asja Ja Siis on niimoodi, et viies nädal on käis projektide eelviimane nädal. Istun mingi tüübi kõrval ja siis vaatan mine pekki. Its Impossible,
Õpetaja: Ta kutsub välja. Meetodid on õigel teel, aga ta ei pane seda kurat fucking muutujasse. Ära lihtsalt pane see ära. Sinna. Pane see muutujasse, Pane ära. Sest et siis on sul millestki edasi mõelda.
Õpetaja: Siis on millegagi midagi teha. Sul on see silt olemas. Sellele andmetele Sul pole silti. Mina ka ei oska midagi kirjutada, kui mul ei ole Nagu seda. Kui ma. Kui ma saan millelegi enam viidata, mul on. Nad mõtlevad, et ma tõin need andmed ära. Jah, tõid, aga sa ei sidunud millegagi seda.
Õpetaja: No siis ma hakkasin vaikselt tegema. Meetodipalvet
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt ju lihtsalt On see, et midagi välja Sest sa pead. Sa oled nagu vastu ka võtma.
Õpetaja: Jah, see on. Jah. No teeme selle niimoodi. Vaata, nagu, Et, Ee, see missioon on niimoodi. See see missioon on nagu niimoodi. Vaata, see päris Nii et ma proovin tuua. Vaata, et et missioon on see, et Artur tooks nagu selle asja. Mingi selle sama pataka. Tooksin vihole,
Õpetaja: nagu onju tooks Rihole. Ma tahaks nüüd Riho käest nagu küsida, mis sa nüüd leidsid, või Mis Sa nagu, mis, mis sa aitad? Vaata
Õpetaja: aga, aga, Artur lihtsalt toob ära, aga siin ei olegi kedagi nagu. Ja sind on. Aga nagu siit tahaks küsida, et Kuule, mis sai,
Õpetaja: mis sa said, pole lihtsalt nagu kellegi poole pöörduda, sa Tead,
Õpetaja: Pole lihtsalt seda objekti, millega, suhelda
Õpetaja: on vaja seda. Ja see. Te naerata praegu minu arust Ma olen mingi miljon korda seda rääkinud Ja kõik naerad alguses
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Ma tegelt. Ma hakkasin seda varem tegema. Aga nagu, et et ma seda saavutasin, et seda, enam ei juhtunud. Seda läks aega suht kiirelt. Ma hakkasin seda meetodi palvet tegema. Meetodi palve ongi siis see, et kui sa kutsud välja mingi ee, meetodi, mis tagastab sulle mingi info, mida sa soovid edasi kasutada. Siis pane see muutusse. See on nii lihtne.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis ma tegin niimoodi, et me nämmutame. Nämmutame, siis ma ühel hetkel ütlen, et nüüd Aitab. Mine, Mind ei huvita enam. Nagu nüüd ta te kõik saate sellest aru, kas keegi on, kes ei saa aru, Vaikus ei. Või Saame aru, saame aru. Saame aru.
Õpetaja: Ja siis Ma teengi niimoodi, et siis Esimene inimene sellest hetkest, kus ma saan, aru, et ta ei saa, aru, sest me arutame mingi koodi või asja. Me teeme midagi, harjutame Ja kui see inimene ikka veel ei saa aru, siis ma ütlen nüüd. Sina oled meetodi palve hõiskaja.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi, et kui nüüd keegi teine.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd keegi teine jääb sellega vahele, et ta ei saa sellest kontseptsioonist aru, siis ma ütlen ei, Juku, no ta on juba kokku lepitud. Ma ei pea pikemalt midagi ütlema. Siin on see Skill on juba ära pandud nagu,
Õpetaja: ee, Et siis sa tõused püsti. Vaatad sellele teisele otsa Vaata Üritad ka. Oskab seda asja, aga tegelikult ei oska. On ju Tõen püsti. Vaatad talle silma ja ilusti. Ütled. Kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodid, mis midagi tagastab ja sa soovid seda midagi edasi teha, siis pane see muutujasse.
Õpetaja: No siis ainult on garanteeritud, et see vend, kes see esimene vahele jäi. Tema saab selle kindlalt selgeks
Õpetaja: ja teised hakkavad ka vaikselt selgeks saama sellepärast, et Seda Siis näimutame jälle jälle. Jälle. Et siis kuidagi hakkab see paika loksuma. Nii, nüüd kuulame korra seda laulu.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mida laul meile ütleb. See on nii hea biit Nagu ma ei tea, pean see kuidagi download Ima siit ära muidu see läheb kuhugi kaduma veel ka
Õpetaja: ja Siis läheme selle laulu peale. Seda laulu Lähmegi kohe ka.
Õpetaja: Näed see õige,
Õpetaja: Tallinna,
Õpetaja: aitäh.
Õpetaja: Okei, Jah, nii lihtne.
Õpetaja: Jaa, need on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, Jah,
Õpetaja: ei olegi. Tähendab, selles mõttes. Vaata, siin ongi see. Vaata, siin ongi. Nagu see Siin ongi. See See kõige lollakam asi ongi. See. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui sa oled sellise meetodi teinud. Vaata, mis midagi mingeid andmeid toob või kokku paneb. Ja mida iganes. Vaata, on ju, et sul pidi olema, põhjus, et sul on vaja Nagu seda informatsiooni, on ju? Kui sa oled selle meetodi ära teinud ja ta seda tagastab. Vaata siis. Nüüd tulebki see idioot. Siis kuubis. Vaata, onju, et
Õpetaja: kui sa nüüd kutsud selle välja, sa nägid vaeva, Sul on mingisugune asi olemas, Mis toob seda Ära vaata, on ju,
Õpetaja: et kui sa kutsud seda meetodit välja, sa tahad seda infot, mille jaoks sa selle tegid. See ongi see, et sa pead selle kuhugi kinni püüdma, sest et edasises koolituses soovid seda kasutada ja sul on seda silti vaja. Vaata, et nagu, et. Et kas on olemas nagu seda olukorda. Vaata, et. Et sa kutsud meetodi välja. Kas seda infot ei ei vaja.
Õpetaja: Kui Kui kogu selle meetodi mõte on mingi info sulle anda siis ei ei saa olla niimoodi, et sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi Ja sul tagastusega ei ole midagi teha. Sest siis ma küsin, et miks sa siis selle üldse välja kutsud? Ära Siis kutsu,
Õpetaja: kui sul ei ole seda vaja. Siis mi arvutiprotsessor hugab vä ja inimene ootab seal teisel pool mikrosekundi. Võibolla, et millal ta saab oma veebilehe nähtavale, On ju,
Õpetaja: et et ei ole, ei ole niukseid olukorda, kui see meet see meetod ei peaks olema niimoodi. Vot see on teine asi, Mida me räägime hiljem Jälle Kuidagi pikalt läheb. Ee, siin on nagu see, et vaata, et ükski meetod ei peaks tegema midagi rohkemat, kui Ta nimi ütleb,
Õpetaja: et kui sul meetod ütleb, et ee, salvestab uue. Aa niiöelda
Õpetaja: salvestab uue õpilase andmed, Näiteks seal ei tohiks olla niimoodi, et tegevusena. Ta salvestab uue studenti ja saadab välja näiteks mingi notification I
Õpetaja: siis lahing.
Õpetaja: Nagu ma ütlen, meeta nimi. Ma ei vaata kunagi sinna sisse. Ma näen kuskil kutsutud välja. Seda see on. Just
Õpetaja: Ta ei tohiks niimoodi valetada, aga ei tohi valetada ka teistpidi. See on Veel hullem, mina ei tea. Mõlemad on hullud, et. Ee. Kui oleks niukene meetod see on. Lähen vaatan meetodi sisse, Vaatan, et nagu,
Õpetaja: et Lihtsalt salvestab notification. I saates pole haisugi. Vaata, onju jälle valetab, on ju? Kui sul on mingi meetod,
Õpetaja: mis on nagu kett või fine midagi. Something. Vaata, on ju siis tegevusena ta midagi erilist seal muud teha ei tohiks. Kui ainult, seda et ta toob sulle andmed, et Kui sa. Kui ta teeks mingi tegevusena ka. Mingisuguse näiteks notification I saatmise on ju
Õpetaja: Aga samas ta on midagi returnib, onju Ja
Õpetaja: siis Võiks öelda justkui ma tahtsin seda tegevust seal, mida ta teeb. Aga see andmed mind ei huvita. Siis on nagu see, aga see, miks Siukene meetod. Nagu, et, ee, siis on see vale. Vaata, kui sa teed meetodi, mis midagi tagastab, Noh, siis see meetodi nimi peab ütlema, mida ta tagastab.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ongi see point, et seda sa käivitad. Ainult siis, kui sul on seda seda informatsiooni vaja, mida ta sulle annab. Ja kui sa käivitad selle juba selle tegevuse, mis mingit informatsiooni annab, siis vähemalt esimese sammuna. Vähemalt algaja progena koodi Teeme ilusaks hiljem. Pane Ta muutujasse.
Õpetaja: Pane Pane ta muutujasse. Oo, Noh, selles mõttes, et tee see kohe samme. Ära. Kutsud välja meetod Mis põmm põmm. Vajutad arvutil paari nuppu. Sellel. Ta tekitab ise selle muutuja.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui su mõttelõng on seas kohal, et ma kutsun välja mingisuguse meetodi, mis Peab mulle midagi andma. Nii pea. Kui sa selle ära trükid, siis teek veendu, et me teeme niimoodi. Me progedes, kui me kirjutame, me ei kirjuta niimoodi vasakult paremale. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aa, uute nimi Account võrdub. Nüüd hakkame mingit meetodit välja kutsuma. Niimoodi me jäämegi koodi kirjutama. Pigem on Niimoodi me ütleme, et seal klassis ütleme mingi objekti. Nime. Punkt
Õpetaja: Kutsu välja, näiteks. See on nagu laohoidla. See on nagu me räägime andmebaasist, Onju, et ee, account tabelist.
Õpetaja: Find account by user Name. Nii, kirjutame parema poole ennem ära, onju? Ja siis me nagu vajutame. Vaata, et Ta soovita mulle midagi. Ta ütleb, et kas tahad. Ma teen sulle kohaliku Muutuja.
Õpetaja: Ta teeb. Noh, ma pean nii pidama niimoodi ja me Teeme nagu pidevalt. Kirjutame paremat poolt ennem
Õpetaja: vasaku poole. Teeb meile. Ära See on see konks. Ja see on see unustamise hetk ka, nagu Vaata, et kui me võibolla tõesti kirjutaks koodi, nagu mingisugused koledad koodiahvid, et me kirjutaks kogu koodi vasakult paremale, Ai, kes siis võibolla ei saa nagu meelest ära minna. Vaata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aa, ma kavatsen võtta endale. Mul on Account andmeid vaja. Ma teen selle muutuja Account I Panen muutuja nimeks Account. Panen võrdsusmärgi ja nüüd kutsun välja. Ma kahjuks lihtsalt ei proge niimoodi, sest see on lihtsalt kolm korda aeglasem.
Õpetaja: Te Ei tahaks ju seda niimoodi teha, aga siis ongi see. Vaata, et algajatena. Ee, olete. Te isegi tabate ära. Vaata, mul on vaja ühest tabelist andmeid.
Õpetaja: Te kutsute õige asja välja ja te isegi ehitate selle meetodi, Millega üldse saab seda Sealt andmebaasi, mida saab käivitada ja mis andmebaasi poole pöördub. Teate selle ka korrektselt Ära Kutsute välja ka ära korrektselt ära, Aga siis
Õpetaja: viimane samm jääb nagu kuidagi, nagu ja ma Ütlen ka, et ma olen teinud seda igatepidi ja kuskil viiendast kuuendast grupist enam eriti pole olnud neid, Aga enne seda oli niimoodi, et Nämmuta Tee neid palveid, Tee neid asju
Õpetaja: viies nädal, peaaegu kohe.
Õpetaja: See nädal. Lõpetame ja siis vaatad, et täiesti paar.
Õpetaja: Me istume lihtsalt siin Ja ma ei ole nõus ütlema ette. Enam. Ma ei ole nõus enam ette ütlema. Lihtsalt sellepärast, et ma olen seda teinud viis nädalat. Teil on meetodi palvehõiskaja, on seda juba ette öelnud kõigile miljon korda. Ja ma. Ja ma ütlen ka, et ma juba siis, kui ma Nägin, kui minu eelkäija nagu stage õpilaste stagelist, mitte tema.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlesin, et nagu sul pole mitte midagi erilist.
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole mitte midagi Erilist nagu. Vaata, tegelikult Ei, ole. Mitte kui midagi erilist ja. Ja see on nagu mingisugune.
Õpetaja: See on mingi, ma ütleks, see on müstika, Lihtsalt sa lihtsalt mingil põhjusel usu müstika, et miks see kontseptsioon nii raske on?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, ma ei ole sellest aru saanud, kui Ma teaks vastuse, Siis ma oskaks mingeid ravimit. Aga ma võin öelda, et nagu viimastel kursustel, ma olen lihtsalt niivõrd suuri numbri sellest teinud Ja inimesed tohutult kardavad, et nad peavad hakkama olema see meetod palvõiskjad. Nad teevad selle endale selgeks, aga ma ütlen teile ausalt, see ei peaks olema see motivatsioon Lähme tagasi selle eilse vestluse juurde.
Õpetaja: Nad tahavad seda Need tööandjad otsivad seda, et te mõistaksite. Programs programiskontseptsioone.
Õpetaja: No see On nagu A, B, C, S. On see B.
Õpetaja: B On See lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Meil ei ole mõtet kuhugi kaugemale minnagi, kui see selgeks ei saa.
Õpetaja: Te peate hakkama mõtlema seda, et meetod ei tea oma välisest elust mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Ja nii on samamoodi ka niimoodi, et kui minu Selle minu meetodi sees on mingisugune muutaja informatsioon. Siis mina. Mingi teise. Mingisuguse koodilõigu Sisust ei tea midagi.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on seal, on seal Kõik, mis on minul, on minul.
Õpetaja: Need asjad nagu ei ole nagu Connected. Vaata, niipea kui te hakkate niimoodi. Mõtlema, siis läheb elu lihtsamaks. Teil on vaja nagu kuidagi. Vaata, ma rääkisin sellest klõpsudest. Need neuronid ja Need asjad. Kuskilt. Peab see klõps ära käima. Mida varem käib Klõps, Ära See, et hakata mõtlema andmetest kui objektidest
Õpetaja: te hakkate mõtlema nendest muutujatest kui siltidest ja te hakkate mõtlema, et mida te teete, Keel on programmeerimis Keel on lihtsalt suhtlus. Sa lihtsalt suhtled põhimõtteliselt jaava kompilaatoriga. Nagu ütled, nagu ma tahan teha nagu niukest asja. Vaata ja Räägid talle, mis peab toimuma. Mis peab juhtuma. Sa räägid temaga lihtsalt juttu.
Õpetaja: Sa räägid nende siltide abil
Õpetaja: nende siltide abil. Sa saad suhelda temaga Ja nende nende tegevustega. Need meetodid. Need on need tööriistad. Kuidas sa saad suhelda ja öelda, et mida sa, mida ma tahan, et Ee, mis peab juhtuma süsteemis
Õpetaja: Niipea kui selle läbi hammustad, siis juba läheb eluliit.
Õpetaja: Ehitisobjektide värk. Vaata, et ee, ühest tudengist võib teha tuhat objekti. Nad kõik elavad oma elu.
Õpetaja: Kui ma teen student üks ja panen sinna Rainy andmed, siis see on selle sildi ja selle objektiga Seotudent kaks ja panen sinna mingi teise. Kaks erinevat objekti. Vaata
Õpetaja: objektid. Davai, lähme sööme. Mis me ikka siin Ee, jääb? Ime, Ee, saate selle kõik selgeks. Ma ütlen, viimased grupid juba on päris Päris head.
Õpetaja: Tagasi, mis? Nüüd, Ee, teeme siis nelikümmend. Viis minutit.
Õpetaja: Pool kaks,
Õpetaja: palun.
Õpetaja: Jaa,
Õpetaja: teil on toetajate.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen otsa.